we are going to start learning about the
flask web framework
now this is a micro framework that
allows everyone to
build their own web applications using
the python programming language and what
is so
great with flask it allows everyone to
build
web application with only a few lines of
code so
it turns the experience of building a
website to a lot quicker and easier
and in this series of videos we are also
going to start with a very minimal
application
and we are going to push forward until
we have an advanced website
where real users can start using it so i
really believe that in this series of
videos
we will cover everything that you need
to know about the flask web framework
in order to come with a great looking
website alright so let's have a quick
look to the website
that we are going to build throughout
this series okay so this is the final
result of the website that we are going
to build throughout this series
now the main idea of this website will
be to create a marketing system
where different users can buy or sell
their items
so in order to get started i can press
in here in that button
and then you can see that i see a
warning here that i
should log in to access that page now if
i'm happened to not have a user here
then i can basically go ahead and click
register now i'm going to
mismatch these details a bit so you can
be aware of the different error handling
that we are going to apply on this
website
and once i click on create account then
we can see that we receive
several errors regarding to that website
so
as you can understand we are going to
apply a lot of error handling
like in real websites so now i will go
ahead and create a valid account here
so once i click on create account then
we can see that we
are inside a real looking web page
and you can see on the left pane that we
have the available items on market
and each item has its name and also
its barcode and price and we can display
more information
about each of our products and as you
can see in
up top here we have our budget that is
set by default
to 15 grand so that means that we are
going to create a budget system for our
users
as well and if i go ahead and purchase
that item
which its price is 520
then you can see that we receive a nice
message
with the purchase item and we can also
pay attention that
our budget has been changed over here
and further than that we can see in the
right pane
that now on my items i see that we have
a new item
that we have the option to sell it so if
i'm going ahead and sell this item back
to
the market then we can see that our
budget
is back at 15 grand and we can also see
that
this page is refreshed to what it was
before
i purchased that item so it is going to
be a lot of fun building this website
and let's go ahead and get started
all right everyone so you can pay
attention that i'm inside the terminal
in a windows machine but of course don't
worry if you use a mac or any kind of
linux distribution because i'm going to
say the same command that is going to
work on those operating systems
as well and also one more important
point here i'm going to assume that you
have python 3.8
or any version above installed and also
a
ready ide installed that you'll work
with so it could be visual code
sublime text or pycharm and just to
mention off i'm going to use pycharm
in this series but it is not quite
important which id you are working with
just make sure that it is configured
with python correctly
okay so let's go ahead and create our
directory that we are going to store our
project files
inside it so i will go here and write in
make directory and this is the same
command for any linux distribution as
well
and i will type in here the name of the
directory
that i want to make so it will be flask
market and then i will go ahead and use
the
cd command to change the directory and i
will basically type in
the name of the directory that we
created and now before we
go ahead and actually launch this
directory in
our pycharm i want to install the
dependencies that are quite
important in order to start building our
first
flask application so i will go here and
use the pip to install some package and
you can use basically the same command
for any linux machine as well
and i'm going to type in here pip
install
flask and once i have done that then you
can see that we got some warnings that
are saying that requirement already
satisfied because when you go ahead and
install flask it is basically going to
install
some secondary packages that are kind of
dependent to
flask so just make sure that you hit
this command correctly
and then there is no any output of
errors or something like that
and once you have done that let me just
clean our screen here
then we can basically go ahead and test
out if we
installed flash correctly and i will do
that by type in here
flask dash dash version and if you don't
see any errors in this command
then we should go ahead and try to start
our first flask application
because we received a correct output
that
just specifies the versions of some of
the dependencies that are related to the
flask
framework so let's go ahead and build
our first application in python
okay so i have already opened my pycharm
here and
you can basically pay attention that i
opened it in a directory that is the
same directory that we created
so make sure that you point your id to
the directory that we created a few
minutes ago
and then inside our directory we are
going to create our first python file
and you can do that by that way in
python so
i will call it market and then once i
have done that
it is a great idea to bring in from the
web browser
the starter template to basically build
up your first
flask application now flask
documentation already includes
some basic structure that is going to
allow us to build our first hello world
application
so let's go ahead and bring this in our
screen
and make that a little bigger and you
can see here
that inside that website we have a
minimal
application that is looking something
like the following and i will allow
myself to
copy the entire code from here and paste
this in
our python so let's open our ide again
and i will paste this here and
let's see what is going on here so as
the first line
we can already see that we import the
flask instance
from the entire flask package so it is
quite obvious and
it is not surprising but then we can see
that we initialize the instance of the
flask
with the given argument of double
underscore name double underscore
now if you never saw this variable
before i have a video that is quite
explaining
what this magic variable is about
basically this is a built-in variable
that you can always call from any python
file
and it is referring to the local python
file
that you are working with so the flask
instance
is requiring to receive this parameter
and this is why you are going to
see that and don't worry too much about
that if you don't understand it
basically just leave it as it is and now
we can see that
in the fault line we have something that
is called a decorator in python
now a decorator is basically a one step
before
a function that is going to be executed
now when you see here app.route it is
basically
saying that what url in your website i
am going to
navigate through and display you some
html
code so you can see that inside here we
have an argument
that is basically saying a full slash
inside the string
now this is the home page of your
built-in website
so if you just basically go ahead and
type in some url without navigating for
a specific page
then it is going to lead you by default
to
that specific page so you can refer it
as your
root url of your website
and then we can see that we have a
function that is defined here
and then it returns a string that says
hello world
now this is the exact place that we
should see some html code in the future
but for now we are only returning a
basic string
that is saying hello world and those in
flask are trended to call
routes or views sometimes people call it
wheels because in django it is called
views and django is another web
framework of python
but i will try to stick with one word
when i'm going to
refer to those functions that are
routing to a specific page
and we are going to call them routes so
once we understand what is going on
inside this startup template then
it is a great idea to raise our terminal
here and
run in some commands to start this
application
so let me clean the screen here and in
order to make our application run
successfully
we are required to set up several
environment variables
so i will go here and write up set
flask app like this and make sure that
all the letters are capitalized here
and if you are working on a linux
machine this command is basically should
be
export and not set so if you are on
windows set will work and i'm going to
make that to be equal
to the same name of the python file that
we have just created
and if you remember we call this market
dot pi and once we have set that
then we can basically go ahead and
execute our application
by saying here flask run and once i have
done that
you can see that we receive several
warnings
that we are going to explain them in the
future but that last
line is quite important to understand so
you can see that it says that it's
running on http 127.001
and then we see a column here and then a
number after that
now if you know a little bit about basic
networking
then you can understand that this ip is
a convention
ip address that is basically referring
to
your local machine so this ip is going
to be the same for each
machine that this application is running
on and
we have something that is called the
ports that are basically
describing the application that you are
hosting
as numbers so for flask
by default it will be 5000 so
if i will copy this url from here
and paste this in our web browser
then we should see a message
hello world and that is perfect because
we were able to complete
the entire starting process successfully
in the flask web framework so we can
basically go ahead and continue from
here and one more point that i did not
mention
you'll see this hello world text because
this is the root url of your web
application
and basically the hello world function
that we saw before knows how to handle
this
so for example if i was to go here
and type in slash about for example
then we should receive an error that
this is not found because we are not
having
a route that is handling the slash
about so this is the reason we saw the
hello world
message properly okay so i'm back to my
pycharm and
let's actually go ahead and try to
customize this string a little bit
to return a better looking page
so we can basically go inside the
string that we are returning and type in
here some html code
that will basically be rendered in
the page that we are displaying so we
can go here
and use the h1 tag which is basically
the biggest header tag that is possible
in html
and we can write in here some text again
like hello world
but bigger and then we can go ahead and
close our tag
like this now if you don't know anything
about
html don't worry too much about that
because most of the html code that i'm
going to
write here i'm going to explain what i'm
going to do or i'm just basically going
to
copying and pasting several html code
snippets so
we can make our lives easier when we
display
nicer pages okay so let's go ahead and
save this out
and go back to our terminal and restart
our server so i will stop the execution
of
our web server and type in again flask
run and then we will go to our web
browser again
and basically navigate back to the
root url so i will just hit enter here
then we can see that we receive this
message
of hello rolled but bigger now
you could see that in order to display
this text i went ahead to my terminal
and restarted our web application and
you are probably asking yourself if this
process
is required to accomplish every time
that you are changing your code
well the answer for that is for sure no
because you probably don't want to go
ahead and
restart your application every time that
you are taking several changes
within your project so in order to
prevent
such a behavior we should go back to our
terminal
and look up for something that is called
debug mode
right here now you can see that we are
having the debug mode
off and you want to turn it on basically
because
this will allow your application to
being synchronized
every time you change your code within
your market.pi
file so if i was to exit
our web application that time and let's
actually clean our screen again
and we can basically go ahead and set up
one more environment variable
that will turn the debug mode on and
that will be
by the set command again and i will set
the flask on the scar debug to
one so basically this turns on the debug
mode
and then i will allow myself to run
flask run again and then now that time
we can see that the debug mode is on
now let's go to our python again and
change the
string that we are returning on our root
url
and see if those changes will be
synchronized without restarting
our web server so i will go here and i
will basically type in here
change text something like that and i
will go back to my web browser
and refresh that out and then you can
see that the changes
have been affected without restarting
our web server
so we can test this one more time by
adding some explanation marks here
and save that out and go back to our web
browser and
refresh it and then you can see that the
changes
are being synchronized when you are on
debug mode
now the debug mode is something that you
always want to turn on
when you develop your application but
once you go ahead and
deploy this application in production
then you definitely don't want to turn
the debug mode on
because this will cause the clients that
are
basically surfing on that web server to
see errors of your web application
and it is always not nice to see your
bugs
as the one who uses your services so
make sure that if you deploy your web
application in the future
then prevent the debug mode on because
this is
very important okay so let's see what
else we can do
with our routes here so
let's actually revert this back to hello
world again and i will basically create
here one more route
just to practice how routes are working
because we are going to create a lot of
them in the future
so i will write here the decorator that
is
required to make the route to understand
which url you want to enable in your web
application
so i will go ahead here and type in
slash
about and then once i have done that you
should go ahead and create your function
that will handle
all the requests that are arriving to
this url which is slash about and i will
call this function about underscore page
and i will close this out and i will go
ahead
and return one more html string here
that will say about
page so as you paid attention i created
those h1 tags again and just to test
this off in that stage
let's go ahead to our web browser again
and try to
navigate through slash about and this
time you could guess that
the slash about is going to work because
we are handling
what the slash about supposed to do
so i just wanted to show you that you
can create as much as routes
as you want and then you can basically
return some html
response to your web pages now
sometimes you don't always want to go
ahead and
hard coding your routes like we
did until now so if you imagine a
situation
like in facebook where you have
different urls for like
millions of profiles then you probably
can understand
that the facebook developers are not
going ahead and creating
millions of routes by hard coding their
profile names
so besides that we can accept something
that is called dynamic routes and
what i mean by that is that basically
you can go ahead to your route in your
flask application
and receive a variable name that is
going to be
accepted as well so let's imagine a
situation that we want to
display an about page for different
people so let's go here and
type in one more forward slash and then
basically
call the tags and add in here
username now what i have done by this
is basically i allowed this
route to receive any string that we want
after the
about page and since i have done that
i can go here and change this return
to something else so let's go here and
write in a formatted string and i will
open this
h1 tags again and i will close it like
this and then between those i will go
ahead and type in
this is the about page of
and then let's call here the user name
that we receive here now you can pay
attention that
this returns us an error because we
should handle this
variable inside our function as well so
let's
accept this as a parameter so i will go
here and type in username
and now i can basically go back to our
web browser
and check out if this works properly so
i will go back to our web browser again
and i will type in here forward slash
and then let's give a random name
like john and then you can see that we
receive
a page so we see the message here of
this is the about page of john
and i could go here and change this to
whatever i want
i can change it to michael to jim and
to more names if i'd like to so the
important point here
is to understand the behavior of
dynamic routes so just make sure that
you understand the behavior of that
as well
okay so as you could notice here i
deleted
the about route from the last episode
because i want to focus on the next
topic that i am going to talk about just
now
so until now we raised our html text
within our routes
in a hard coded text like you
see here now when we go ahead and design
complex html pages you probably want to
avoid storing long strings within only a
single file
so in order to overcome this we have a
convention in flask to a way we can
achieve such a task and the way we can
basically
do this is by creating a new directory
that is called templates and then inside
the
templates directory we will start
creating our html
files and then we will separate our html
code
within this directory and we will refer
our routes to those different html
files so let's go ahead and get started
and see how we can do this
okay so i will start by creating a new
directory here
and you can see that i'm creating that
inside our flask market
project so it is very important and you
want to
name it templates so make sure that you
don't give it another name like html
pages or something else
just basically go with templates because
the templates
name is actually a convention to a flask
so
the package can understand that you are
going to locate there
some html files and within our templates
directory
we will go ahead and create one more
file and you can directly
select the html file if you use the
pycharm
so i will name it home and then you can
see that it already
returns us some default html code
and just for now i'm going to delete
what is inside here
and let's make our font bigger so we can
understand what we are going to type in
here just in a second
now again for a basic example and
to understand the process of referring
a route to an html file we will
basically
go ahead here and type in hello
i mean home page it might be a better
way to do that so we will call it home
page
and basically i will save this file and
go back to our
market dot py and then besides
returning the hard-coded string like we
did previously
we want to look for a way to point
this route to the home.html
that we have just created so it
basically makes more sense to
change this route a little bit and let's
do that okay and let's go ahead
and call this home page and then we
will close this out and then write a
column here
and then we will return render
underscore template now you could
already pay attention that
this returns us an error because we did
not import it
so we have to realize that we are going
to import a lot of built-in functions
that are inside the flask package so one
of them will be
render template and the render template
knows how to handle your requests and
basically
direct them into html files so let's go
ahead here
to our first line and import here one
more function
from our flask package and it will be
render underscore
template and as i have done that i have
to specify here one more argument
and for sure this will be the name of
our html file
so i will go here and type in home.html
and once i have done that let's go to
our terminal and
make sure that our server is still
running and it is
so let's go to our web browser
and navigate to our root url and then
you can see that we
have completed the render template
function successfully
so this is the proper way that you
always want to work when you
organize your flask projects you always
want to create that
directory that is called templates and
then you want to start
storing your html files in this specific
directory okay so now that we
understood how we can refer our routes
into
different html files it is about time to
start working
on styling our pages so our application
could start be looking like a real
website so in order to start styling
we probably want to import one of the
styling frameworks that are already
existing out there so the most popular
styling framework
will be a styling framework that is
called bootstrap
and you may have heard about bootstrap
already because this is the most
popular framework to style your pages
and the main reason that you want to use
a ready styling framework
is to save time by the process of
styling
each of our html elements because we
really want to focus on the python side
of our web application so you can import
the bootstrap
styling by going ahead to your web
browser
and basically searching bootstrap
starter template
and this starter template will help you
to get started
with all the requirements that are
necessary
to style your web pages so let's
actually go
into getbootstrap.com like i have
already done here
and go to that docs 4.5
so this is right here is the version of
bootstrap so you want to make sure that
you
use the same version as i do currently
because this
might lead to differences if you just
work with another version
so just make sure to work with 4.5 as
well so i will allow myself to
copy the entire html code from here
and paste this in into our home.html
that we have just created
so i will open back our pycharm again
and i will
go inside our home.html and i will paste
this
over here now i know that it is a lot of
html code to sync in
but i'm going to go over each of the
lines once
so we can really understand how an html
structure looks like
so let's go to the first line here and
make our phone
a little bit smaller so we can see most
of the parts of this file
alright so at the top here at the very
first two lines
we have some lines that should be
located in each html file
so basically this specifies that this
document is going to be within a type of
html
and the language that we are going to
use is going to be english so this is
why we see the e
and n letters now each html
file is divided into two
important sections or what is so called
html tags
and those sections are called head
and body now inside a head tag
you are probably going to see a lot of
things
that are pretty much meta information or
some
imports that is pulling the styling
and also some necessary information to
change
your tab name when you navigate for that
specific
page so for example if we
see here inside our head tag another
html tag that is called title so this
should be
our name of the tab that we currently
looking on so i will show the result of
this html file just in a second
and we can verify that the tab name is
going to be hello
comma road so one more important line
inside our head tag will be this line
over here
so you don't want to touch it at all
because this is what importing the
entire
styling for our home.html file
so you can basically see that by the
link tag
and the href attribute is the
url that is probably pointing to that
complex
styling so this is something that is
called css
and the css allows pages to look a lot
better
and more dynamic so it is important to
leave those lines over here
okay so i will allow myself to close the
head tag and let's talk about the body
now the body tag is what is really
important and what really matters when
you want to display some
information within your pages now you
can see that we
also have here the h1 tag that we used
previously
and you can see that its text is hello
world as well
and you know what let's actually go
ahead and change this to home page
so we can have a better understanding of
how this is going to be
look like now when you see the tag
explanation mark and then the dashes two
times
it is basically saying that the
following line is going to be
a comment now you can already understand
that because this is uncolored
in pycharm so this is basically a
comment
and down here you can see two more tags
that are called
script now when you see script tags
those
are javascript libraries that are also
going to be
important and this is also a huge part
when you design a webpage
so you also don't want to touch that
because it
deals with all the functionality within
our pages
so you don't want to touch those script
tags as well
so just make sure to keep them in your
file and you can also see that we
have one more long comment here but you
can see that we have script tags within
those comments
so what that means it means that we can
go ahead in the future
and uncomment those lines so we can make
use of more javascript libraries
but i will leave it now as it is okay so
now we understood the structure of a
basic html file
let's go back to our web browser again
and see the results of this page
so i will go here and close this starter
template and refresh our page then you
can see that already the font
of our page has been changed now i
noticed that i
zoomed in much in this page so i will
basically revert this back
okay so you can see that the font has
been already changed
and this is what bootstrap is
responsible
for so when we go ahead and add more
html code
you are probably going to see that in a
nicer way because of this bootstrap
starter template
that we already imported now you can
also
see here that our tab name is hello
comma world as we have said a few
minutes ago
so this is also something nice that we
can control by ourselves
and we will for sure do that in the
future okay so i think this will be it
about the explanation of how
html page is looking like so as i said
before i really want to keep on
decreasing my
explanations about each of the html
lines that i'm going to
write in so we will have a better focus
on the python side of this flask
application
but for sure if you have any questions
about the html
in general make sure to comment them out
so i can read them off and respond you
all right so let's go back to our market
dot py
and take care of something that is quite
bothering me
until now now you can see that our
homepage
is basically rendered when we went ahead
and did not specify any extra
information after our ip address and our
poll
now in most of the websites if you go
ahead and type in slash home here
basically this will be responsible to
render you the same result
like we saw previously now in order to
handle
two routes for a single html file
it is as easy as going down to our
pycharm
and right in here one more decorator
so it will be app dot
route and then this time we will write
here
slash home and if we want to test this
out
we can basically refresh our page and
then you can see that we see the same
result like previously
and if i delete everything from here the
result is going to be same
so this is something that you want to
keep on your web pages because it makes
sense to display the home page
in both of the cases okay so now that we
have
understand how we can design our pages
nicer
it is about time to give our page a
little bit
nicer style rather than displaying a
home page so we will start by adding a
navigation bar
so our users could have the option to
navigate through different pages so
the page that i will bring in here
will be my personal website and
throughout
this video or in the future
episodes i am going to go into my
personal website a lot
and copying some html code snippets
that will help us to write html a little
bit faster
so i'm going to include a lot of html
code snippets throughout
this tutorial so just make sure to go to
the description of that video
and navigate through the url that is
going to be specified
as the code snippets url and get those
code snippets so it will be much easier
to you to follow this video
so for this example to add a navigation
bar
i will go here and select the second
part of this tutorial
and i will basically go and navigate for
our code
and then you can see that as the first
code snippet
i have here the code snippet of navbar
so i will allow myself to copy
everything here
and paste this in just under
our body tag so let's fix the
indentation here
and paste this in and now we should see
a nice navigation bar inside
our homepage so let's fix the
indentation here a little bit more so we
can have a better understanding
which tag is inside another tag so i'm
just
going to fix that and i think that will
be
enough okay so what let's
delete those indentations and now i
think we are fine
okay so now i will save this up and go
to our website and refresh
that out and then you can see that we
have this nice navigation bar
up top here and then you can see that we
have its
name which is called gymshade coding
market
now we can change this whatever text we
want we just
need to find this specific html tag
that is responsible to display this text
so
let's actually go ahead and find it so
we can have a better practice
of how we can find specific html tags
so i see that we have this text here and
i can basically go ahead and change this
to
flask market and if i save this up and
refresh it you can see that the changes
are affected now you can see that we
have this navigation bar
but we don't have any extra links that
we can click on them
and actually navigate through different
pages
so to add those links we have to go to
our python
and basically add some optional links
so that the user can see which pages he
can
navigate so to ease on that process
i can also go to my website
i mean to my original website and then
copy the
second code snippet here which is called
navbar dash options i mean underscore
so let's go back to our pycharm and we
want to paste this
in right here where we see
a div tag which is with a class
that is named as collapsed navbar
collapse okay so we will paste this in
over here and once we do that
then we should see a better result of
the items that
should be available inside our
navigation bar so if we
go to our website and refresh
that out then we can already see a
better result of how
a real navigation bar looks like and we
can see that we have home
market and we have login and register
now for sure when i go ahead and click
on them
it should not lead us to any different
page
because we did not configure those
routes yet
and we will do them in the near future
now
just to have a better understanding what
is going on inside the second code
snippet that we have just copied
and pasted you can see that we have some
li tags over here and this
is a shortened version of a list tag
so you can see that each one of them
just responsible to
display some item that is available
inside our navigation bar
so we have here this which is basically
a link to
our home and we have that one which is
going to be the link for the market in
the future
and as you could pay attention we have
in the right side
the login and register which we will
configure
in the future as well okay so one more
customization that i want to apply
for this home page is to return it into
a dark mode
now in order to allow the page to be in
dark mode
basically you have to override some
styling
attributes and then your page will be
displayed in a background color of black
and all the text
that you are going to provide are going
to be displayed as
white colors so in order to accomplish
that i'm going to
navigate down in this home.html file
and let's make our font a little bit
bigger here so you can have a better
look
and right after our closure of the body
tag
i'm going to open up a new tag that is
named
style and i will close this up and
between those i am going to provide some
extra attributes
that will override the attributes of our
entire body
so it will be something like the
following so we will start by typing in
body
and then we will open and close curly
brackets
and press enter here so we can enter
inside our
brackets and then here we will override
the two
attributes and the first one will be
background
dash color and i'm going to add here a
column sign as well
and this will be equal to a hexadecimal
value
that i already know that it is going to
display a back color
so if you don't know what an hexadecimal
value is
it is basically another way to define
colors
rather than just text so this is pretty
much equal to
writing here black inside a string
but this is going to make it a little
bit more
close to gray rather than just black so
this is why i defined it
with an hexadecimal value now in order
to
close this attribute we should add a
semicolon here
and our second attribute that we want to
override
will be color and that time i will give
it as a pure text so it will be
white now once i go ahead
and save this file and go back to
our page and refresh that out
then you can see that our page is turned
into
dark mode so make sure that you apply
those configurations as well
in your home.html file in order to turn
your website into a cool looking dark
mode and i just realized that our tab
name
over here is still hello world so let's
go ahead
and change this to finalize our styling
so i will go back to our pycharm and
let's find this title tag that is
responsible to display the tab name so i
will expand our head tag back
and we should change this into something
that they are currently in the homepage
so
let's change this to homepage and remove
the explanation mark
and let's separate those words here and
save that out and
if we go ahead and refresh this then you
can see that our tab name
is changed so i think that will be it
for the
styling part of our website and in the
future for sure we will add some extra
elements
to make our site even nicer
alright so now it makes sense to start
working on some new python code to
deliver
a new items page to our users so this is
why i will be starting to create here a
new route
and we will render a new html template
so
let's go ahead and do this so i will
jump to a new line here
and we will start creating a new route
so i will call
the app dot route decorator here
and it quite makes sense to send our
users to a url that is looking like
slash
market so i will write it like this and
i will continue on and create
our function and we will name it market
page and currently we will receive
nothing as parameters and we will go
ahead here and
return vendor template and we will
send them to a new html file that is
called market.html
now i know that we did not create this
yet so
let's go ahead and do this so as you
remember previously
we just went inside our templates
directory
and we created an html file
and we should name it market so this
route could understand where
we should send our users so let's go
ahead and
name this market and if you use pycharm
then you will receive this
auto-generated html
now to make our lives easier a little
bit
i'm going to copy everything from the
home.html
and i'm going to customize it a little
bit so we can understand
that we are inside the market page and
not inside the home page
so i will go to our home page here
and i will grab everything that is
inside the home.html and i will paste
this in inside our market page and let's
make the font a little bit bigger here
now several changes that it might be a
great idea to
done here is for sure this title tag
that
is changing the tab name so let's change
this to
market and i will scroll down here
let's minimize this navbar and we will
change this home page h1 tag to
market page so we can understand where
we are currently at
now for myself here the website is
currently not running
so let's go ahead and complete the steps
that we are required to
run our website quickly so set flask
app equals to market dot py
and we also have to set the flask
underscore debug
to one and now we are ready to go ahead
and execute
flask run and as we have completed this
let's go to our web browser
and try to navigate through the slash
market route that we have just created
and we can see that the results are
quite great so now we are ready to
work on to see how we can send
information
to this html from our route now to
do this i am basically going to go back
to my pycharm
and we are going to work on the route of
market that we have created and we will
try to send some random data
from this route to our html and see how
we can access it
now the way we can do this is as easy as
going here and
sending more arguments that we will be
accessing
by their keys so let's go ahead and see
an example for that
so let's write in here item underscore
name equals to phone and i will close
the parameters here
back again and let's make this to be
in the pip 8 style and now the way that
we can access this
is by this key name item underscore name
now it makes sense to go back to our
market page now and see how we can
see the value of the item name argument
so i will go to our market and actually
to
access that information we have to start
using some new web templating
engine that is called jinja template now
this might be sound weird what i'm
saying now
but if you remember when we went ahead
and
installed the flask library we kind of
saw a lot of secondary libraries
that the flask library is required to
have them
and one of those libraries are actually
named jinja
now as i said jinja is a special web
templating
syntax that we are able to access
through html
because it is specially designed for
python
web frameworks so to do this i am going
to
go here and let's open here a new html
tag
for example a p tag so it will be a new
paragraph
and the way we can access this is by
calling
the variable syntax and that will be
by double curly brackets opening and
closing like the following
now as i have set those curly brackets
here
we are allowed to access the information
that we have sent
from our route and as you remember we
have sent
the key value of item underscore name so
if i was to go inside our curly brackets
and type in here item underscore name
then we should see the value of this
variable on our page
so to test this out i will go to
my web browser and refresh it and then
you can see that we
see the value of the item underscore
name so this is a quite great
achievement and i hope that you
understood all the process of how we can
display information
from our routes because to be honest
when i saw the ginger syntax first i
really was shocked and did not
understand anything but i hope that this
was a clear explanation
and that you understand correctly why we
have to include
ginger syntax in our html templates
so i will go back to our html file here
and continue from here okay so as you
see i'm back on my
market.py file and now we have to look
forward to
how we can display multiple items on our
website
now to do this we can basically change
the value that we
send to a list now i already have some
information that i already generated up
and this is basically a list of
dictionaries so we will be able to
display better
data on our website when it comes to
displaying some random items
so to bring this code snippet that i
already have generated up
let's go to my website again and
navigate
through the third part of this flask
series and bring these items list of
dictionaries called snippet
now as you can see we are only having a
long list
with three dictionaries here so let's
copy this
up and paste this inside
our market page now let's have a quick
look in this long
list here basically what we are having
is three
dictionaries that they are happening to
have the same keys
so we have id for this and this and that
and also the name key and as well as
barcode and
a price now once i have copied
this out it might be a better idea to
change our send information
in this renderer template and i will
basically delete this item underscore
name equals to phone
and i will change this up to items
equals to items so now we will be able
to access this entire list of items
with calling the variable of items
because this is what we have named
over here now to test this out again
we can basically go to our market.html
and change this to items so
if we save our file and refresh
our website then you can see that we see
this exact
dictionary i mean the list of
dictionaries
over here now you can pay attention that
this looks quite ugly
so to style this up i am going to insert
these values inside a nice designed
bootstrap table
so let's go ahead and do this all right
so we will go back to our
market.html file and in here
we will just delete this paragraph for
now and we have to use an html tag
that is named table and inside here i
have to provide some information
regarding to my tables rows and columns
and to save this work from us i already
have generated a table that is going to
look quite nice
and we are going to add to it some extra
information
to design our rows and columns so to
bring this code snippet
here we will go to my website here and
we will bring this bootstrap table code
snippet from the third part
so i will get this html code snippet
and here i will just replace this with
those table tags so
if we copy this then we can see that we
have here the table tag again
but we have an attribute that we did not
talk about it before
basically when you see the class
attribute inside an html file
it basically refers to bootstrap classes
that
their main goal is to give a nicer
design
to your specific html templates so for
example if we see a class that is named
table hover then we should see a special
effect when we
bring our mouse and hover inside our
table and if we see table dark then you
can probably understand that this table
is going to be
in dark design so in here we
have our table head and table body
and as you can see i already commented
here that we have to create certain
columns here
now since our dictionary includes some
more than one key values then it might
be a great idea to create more columns
to our table so this is why i will go
down here and i will start copying and
pasting this code snippet
three more times and i will replace
those
by the values of the keys that we have
inside our dictionaries
so if you remember we had a dictionary
with a key of name
and we had an id so i did not touch this
column at
all and i'm going to change this to
barcode
and i'm going to write here price
as well so as we have done that the way
that we can
fill in rows to our table will be
easily by going down to the table
body and writing some extra information
inside those table row tags so tr is a
shortened version
of table row now as you can see we have
here
some more tag that is called table data
and this is basically a reference to the
first column that you see here
so if we are happened to copy this out
and paste this in then since this is the
second table data inside this table row
then this is going to be located right
under
the column of name so this is why it is
a great idea to change this to value for
name and i'm going to repeat this two
more times so this will be
barcode and this will be
um price okay so as we have done that
let's test the results inside our
website so i will go to my web browser
and we will navigate through our market
page
and refresh that out and you can see
that we see here a nice table and you
can see that
those are the headers as you can pay
attention that its color is a little bit
more bold
and we can see that we have here
information
that is inside our table so it is quite
great achievement
okay so now that we have done this we
still don't
display the real information that we
have sent
from our market page route so let's
bring up this for a second to
remember this so i will open back our
pycharm
and i will go to market.py for a second
so if you remember we sent this items
list
towards our market.html but we did not
display the actual values
of those dictionaries that are inside
the items list so to do this
we have to iterate over this items
list over here and once we iterate over
this list then we have to access each of
those
keys in some way so
let's see how we can do this okay so
let's go back to our market
dot html well i'm not going to touch the
html code
inside our table head because in table
head we done a great
job because we only want to display here
the columns names so i'm not going to
touch it at all so let's
minimize the table head for a second and
now
as you paid attention each of our tr
tags are responsible to create a new row
inside our table so it might make sense
to
start to launch here a for loop and
start iterating over our items but how
we are going to do this with the
ginger template so if you remember the
ginger template is that special template
that allows us to access the information
that arrives from the route
so i'm going to write here new ginger
syntax that we did not see
so besides doing curly brackets twice
i am going to replace the inner curly
brackets with percentage signs and
what that means it means that you are
going to
call a logic code so if until now we
were able to access
variables that are arriving from ginger
syntax
this time when you see the percentage
signs basically you can
write a code that is quite looking like
a python code
but this time it is not going to be
variable names and stuff like that
besides those are going to be if
statements
for loops and stuff related to actual
logic so in here i can go with
four item in
items now the reason i write here items
because this is
accessible from the market route and
to close our for loop here i will
call those code blocks once again
and i will right here and four
together combined so this is the exact
syntax of how you can
bring in a for loop inside your html
template
and now i'm going to cut this entire
tr html block here and i'm going to
paste
this in inside this for loop that we
have just created
so once we paste this in let's organize
the
indentation for a second great
so now we should see this table row
three times and the reason we should see
this three times because we have three
dictionaries in our items list
so if we save this and go here and
refresh that out
then this is the exact result that i was
talking about
so again the reason we see this three
times because we have three dictionaries
inside our items list okay so
our next problem is quite clear and the
problem is that we
don't see the values yet although we
iterate over
this items list so to access each of the
keys that are inside those dictionaries
we can basically go and open our pycharm
back
and replace those strings here that are
inside the html tags
with the actual value so to do this
i can basically delete this up and call
the variable block again by typing in
curly brackets twice
and i can basically type in here item
dot
id now the id is the key name of the
dictionary
and the item is the variable that i'm
iterating on so this is why i can access
this item variable
and i can change all those three table
datas here to the same
as this one so let's go ahead and do
this so i will
replace this with item dot
name and i will replace this
with item dot
barcode and i can replace this for sure
weight item dot barcode
and we will close our curly brackets and
create a space here
so sorry this should be price okay so we
should change this to price
and now we can go to our html page again
and refresh it then you can see the
actual information
that we meant to display from the real
beginning okay so
this is great achievement so if we are
happened
to add some more information inside our
market.py
then this page is for sure going to be
updated automatically so
one more final thing here to customize
this page a little bit better
we can add here a dollar sign or
something that the
customer that uses this website could
understand that we are referring to
actual money
so we can basically go back here and add
here the
dollar sign and see the effect of that
over
here all right so one more final thing
that i'd like to do
in this table is enabling our users the
options of seeing
more information regarding to a specific
item and also the option of purchasing a
specific item
because we actually want to simulate a
situation
where we have items in market so to do
this
we can basically create one more column
here and we can name it
options and we can add two more buttons
in each of our item
rows so let's go ahead to pycharm and do
this so i will open
my pycharm here and i will find the
table that we
have created so as you remember our
columns are located
inside an html tag that is called t head
so we will expand this back and we will
add here
one more column so we will create a th
tag and our scope will be
col so this is a shortened version of
column
and here we will add options and so
we added the column here and now we have
to add
its value in each of our rows so
to do this we can basically go here to
our table
body and find our for loop and
add here one more td tag which is table
data and over here i will basically hit
enter
so we can add more html elements and i
will call the button element to
display a nice looking button to
show our users the options that he can
do
so let's create here the button tag and
over here i want to
customize this button a little bit so i
will call the class attribute
and inside the strings here i will
specify
the classes so i will write in here
several classes that i already know that
they are going to customize this button
a little bit better
so we will write here button like this
and we will also write button dash
outline
and we will also write here button dash
info now again those classes are made
for
specialize our styling in each of our
html tags
so let's go ahead and close our button
tag and you can see that we already have
the closure for this button
and so now i want to write here a text
like more info and i want to scroll down
a bit so you can see
what i am doing here and so now that we
have completed
this button basically i want to repeat
the same process
to allowing our users to purchase that
specific item
so it will be the button tag again and
this time
our classes are going to be again to btn
and button dash outline and that time i
will type in here button dash success so
the differences between button dash info
to button dash success the button info
is going to
fade into our button a more blue color
and the button success will fade in
the green color so when i go ahead and
close those tags
i can basically write in here purchase
this item now let's go ahead and
test this out so i will open my browser
again and i will
refresh our page and you can see that we
receive the options
right here so this is quite great
now for sure if i click on one of those
buttons
nothing is going to happen because we
did not configure the functionality
behind those buttons
but we will do this in the future so
don't worry about it right now
alright so previously we were able to
display a nice looking
market page by writing this html code
and it was responsible to display a nice
looking page
with several items now if you remember
to display this nice looking page i went
for my home.html and i copied
the entire code from here and i pasted
in
inside mymarket.html and then later on
we
gave it our own customizations now if we
consider
a situation that our website could be
divided into
10 or 20 different pages that will mean
that we have to copy and paste some
basic html code
every time that we want to come up with
a new page
and the reason is we want to keep
certain elements in each page
that we display so for example if you
see in the home.html we
happen to have this long nav
html tag now it is obvious that we want
to display the navigation bar
in each page that our users navigate on
because we want to allow our users to
see the pages that
they can navigate so the main point here
is to think about some method that will
avoid copying and pasting a lot of html
code
and to overcome this we have something
that is called
template inheritance now the idea behind
that
will be to have one base template html
that we will always inherit from and
that way
we will save a lot of copying and
pasting html code
so in order to achieve this what we have
to do is creating one more html template
and it makes sense to give it a name
like base
layout template whatever you like to and
then basically put in there some html
code
that will be always displayed to our
users
so let's go ahead and do this okay let's
go inside
our template directory and create an
html file
that we will name it base so let's
go here and select new html
file and i will call it base as i said
and i will delete everything from the
auto generated html
now as you could guess i already came up
with a base dot html
that is going to save us a lot of time
from writing some base template html
now in order to get that base.html we
will basically go to
my website and bring it on here so we
will go to the fourth part of this
entire tutorial
which is happen to be right there and we
will select the code and
bring in the base.html and for sure once
i paste it i will go over what is going
on here
so we have our base template
and in the next few minutes we are going
to show how we can inherit the entire
html code
from this base template now let's see
what
is going on inside the head tag now in
the head tag we have the same
tags that we were happened to copy
previously in this tutorial from the
bootstrap starter template so
there's nothing really different in here
only what i have done here
is named our title base title so we can
see the effects of it
now if we close up our head tag and
focus on what is inside the body
then we can see that i already have
commented out the location where we want
to
see the navigation bar and also i also
wrote here one more comment
for the future contents that we are
going to add to this base template so
that way we can understand where we have
to insert different html templates
now down here again we see some
javascript libraries that we import like
we saw previously
and this style here is again here to
allow our site to be in dark mode so if
you paid attention
then we see that background color inside
the body
and we also see the color which is the
foreground color as
white so let's also close our style tank
over here now
once we understood what is going on
inside our base.html
it is a great idea to go inside our
home.html
and try to inherit whatever is inside
this base.html
that we have just created so in order to
ease our lives here i will use the
future of pycharm to split
some html files into two or three
different displays
so let's go ahead and do this very
quickly so i will click here
split vertically and on our left pane
we will keep our base.html and
on our right pane we will display the
home.html okay
so now i will basically delete
everything from the home.html
and i will use some special ginger
syntax to
inherit the code that is inside the
base.html
so that will be by the code block
syntax we saw previously so it will be
curly brackets and then the percentage
signs
in that case and then we will use a
function that is called
extends so we are extending this base
template
and basically here inside our string we
can specify the name of the html file
that we want to extend from
because all the html files are located
in the same directory
that we called templates so i will go
here and write in
base.html and once i have done that
i should expect to see pretty much
nothing in our home.html
so let's go ahead and see this in action
so i will go to
our website and i will basically
navigate for our home page
and then you can see that we are happen
to have this black page
so now that we achieve this basically
now we can decide which content we want
to
put inside base.html and which content
we want
our inside home.html so for example
our long navigation bar html tags
are must located inside our base.html so
let's go ahead and do
that so i will go to our pycharm and
let's actually bring this long
nav tag from the market.html so i will
locate our market.html over here
so let's grab our navigation bar
so that will be the entire tag that is
called
nav and i will copy that out and i will
paste it in where we located this
command which is says
navbar here so once i paste this then
we should see a great result where
our base template is having the
navigation bar
so let me customize the indentation a
little bit and i think this looks okay
so we will go to our website again
and we will refresh that out and then
you can see that our navigation bar
is back up again now the beauty in that
process
is that no matter which html file i'm
going to create in the future
all i have to do is using this extends
method
that we saw just a minute ago and then
each time i do this
then we will see our navigation bar so
this is a quite great achievement
okay so even though we have completed
the inheritance successfully
there are still some problems left that
we have to understand how we can figure
out
for example one of them will be the fact
that
you see that our tab name is base title
now we are inside our home page so it
does not make sense to display to our
users
base title each time so what i mean by
that
is that we have to figure out how we can
differentiate between
content that we want to display up on
our each page
to a content that is going to be unique
per page
so let's go ahead and do this so i will
open my pycharm here
and basically on the left pane we got
our base template and on the right pane
the home.html again
and now what i can do is basically
marking any area
in our template that is going to be
unique per page
so the way i can do that is as
easy as going for example inside our
title tag
and write in here some special ginger
syntax
so it will be by using the brackets
and then the percentage sign and then we
have to use the function
that is called block so i will use
this function and i will give it a name
like
title and i will close our block by
using and block now if what i have done
until now
is quite weird for you i can totally
understand that but you will get that in
a few minutes
so once i have done this then i am
allowed to go
inside our home.html and
call this block of code by simply
writing block title and then inside here
i can write anything that i want and the
content that i'm going to put in right
after our blog title
is going to be replaced and use the
content
that we write in home page so let's see
that in action so i will
right here and block again just to close
our block and then inside here let's
write a text like
home page and use the indentation here
so it will give it a cleaner look and
once i have done that
we can basically save this and go to our
website again
and once i refresh it then you can see
that our tab name
is changed to home page so the ability
to
mark certain areas in our base template
as
unique per page areas is quite great
because it is going to allow us to
write more organized code and now
basically we can use this block
functions
in more areas inside our base dot html
and then we can call those blocks in our
different pages
inside our project so i will go to our
python
and declare here one more area that is
going to be
as the area of our body in each page
so we can basically go here and
use the block again and now we can name
it something like
content so let's fix our indentation
here
like that and then we can write again
and block and once i have done
that we can basically go back to our
home.html
and try to call this content block again
and write whatever that we want to write
to display it inside our homepage so
i'm going to go back to my home.html
again
and i'm going to use the block
content and then i will close
our block by simply saying end block
and now we can write a text like
this is our content for the
home page and once i save this
then we should see the this is our
content for the home page
only in our home page so let's
test this out so once i refresh that out
then you can see that
we see this text right here all right so
now that we have applied the inheritance
correctly for our homepage
let's also do this for our items page so
we will basically go to our market.html
and take the same actions over there so
i will open my pycharm in
market.html and before i actually go
ahead and delete everything from here
it is a great idea to copy the table
that we have created previously
and then later on we will paste it
inside our blog
content block so let's go ahead and do
that okay so i will navigate
down here and i will find our table and
you can see that it is right
here and then i will find the closure of
this tag
and i will grab the entire table
and i will basically copy this entire
html snippet
and now i am pretty much ready to delete
everything from here
and using the methods that we have
applied for our home.html so
i will start by writing extends
base dot html
and i will continue on here as using the
blog
title and the block and the end block
again
and then we should do the same process
for
block content so it will be block
content
and again we have to close our block
once again
so once i have done that basically
inside our title
we just have to give it a text like
market page
and inside our content it is a great
idea to paste our table
back in so we can have pretty much the
same page
that we had previously so i will go in
here
and then create an indentation a little
bit and then paste
back our table so i think this should
work let's test this out
by going to chrome again and refresh our
homepage and then you can see that the
behavior is quite same
now i will navigate also to our market
and then you can see that we still get
pretty much the same result like we have
done previously
what we can do is basically adding a
title like market page
and we will just continue with the
customizations
in the future so this is a pretty much
great results until now
and i hope that the entire process of
how we can use
the template inheritance was pretty much
clear for you
okay so there are still customizations
left before we
close this template inheritance topic
and basically
inside our navigation bar we currently
don't have the functionality to
navigate between different pages so to
test this up if i click on home page
nothing happens and as well as in our
market
over here so let's go ahead and
configure them so i will open our
pycharm again
and we will open our base template and
inside our navigation bar
we can basically look up for those
a tags now those a tags are what
responsible to navigate users to
different pages and so if you look at
the
href attribute inside the a tags this
is what is actually sending our users to
different areas now we could have done
here
something like slash home so in that
case it will navigate our users to slash
home
but this is not a great idea because you
don't want to hard code your urls in
that way
so what happens if in one day you want
to change the route to
something else then it is not considered
as a best practice
now again this is going to work i'm not
saying that it is not going to work
but it is quite wrong and we can even
check this out if it works properly so
we can go to here
and refresh our page and click on home
and then this will basically navigate
our users to home page
but we can do this in a more pretty way
and i like to apply that okay so i'll
open back
our pycharm and in here besides hard
coding for slash home
we can basically use a built-in function
from the ginger syntax
that is going to look like url
underscore
four so let's call this up in here and
pay attention that i use the double
curly brackets
so in here i can close this function
like that
and between here the url underscore 4
expects for one special argument now the
argument that we are going to
give for that function will be the value
of the name of our
route that we want to navigate our users
so in this case if we want to navigate
our users to the home page then we
should type in here the name
of our route that we have created to
navigate our users to the home page
and in our case if you remember our
route
name was home underscore page so we can
basically go here
and type in home underscore page
and once i save this let's go to our web
page
and test this out so i will basically
navigate back
to market and i will click on the home
page
and then you can see that it knows
automatically to navigate our users
to forward slash home now this would
even work
if i was to go inside our market dot py
and change this to something else like
home
three times okay let's just do this for
testing reasons
and test that out so i will go to
market again and try to navigate back to
our home page
then you can see that now we were able
to achieve a kind of a dynamic way
to navigate our users to the home page
so we only have to specify the name of
our functions
rather than specifying the hard-coded
urls
so of course i'm not going to leave this
home home home so let's revert this back
and i will delete this from here and
that will be it so let's apply the same
thing for the
market url as well so i will basically
copy
everything from here and i will paste it
in
inside our href where the market is
located
and since our function name was market
page then i will basically
change this to market underscore page
and once i have done that
let's test the results one final time so
for sure now if i refresh
then our flask could not find anything
that is related to
home home home so we will write in here
home back and click on market then you
can see that the behavior is quite great
so the
url 4 is quite useful
in that case
okay so just a quick reminder here this
is the final situation that we have
reached until now on our website
so if you remember those items that you
see
on the slash market page was basically
because of the list of dictionaries
that is arriving from here and is sent
directly to our template and now we want
to look for a way to change this
behavior
so we will be able to store information
inside
an organized database so the way we are
going to do that
is by configuring several configurations
on our flask application
and we are basically going to use a real
database that
is going to store our information inside
tables
now if you never worked with databases
before basically it allows you to store
organized information
within tables where each table describes
some
data that you want to store so for
example you may have a table
that its name is item and it may have a
columns
such as name barcode and price and this
is exactly what we are going to do in
order to
store organized information inside an
organized database
so just a quick brief for the way that
we are going to implement this
basically we are going to use a new file
and that file is going to
store all our information now normally
when you want to store a large amount of
information you should execute a
database service that is running in the
background of your machine
but we are not going to do that because
we are only working on a local
environment
and currently we don't have any case
where a lot of users
are going to cause traffic on our
website so this is why we can allow
ourselves
to use a minimal database and we can
store our information
inside a file besides running a database
service
on our machine so the way we are going
to do this is by using
sqlite3 so sqlite3 is an extension of a
file
that allows to store information and we
are going to connect that file
to our flask application so let's go
ahead and do that
okay so first of first we need a flask
tool
that allows to create tables within that
database that we are going to work with
with using python code now when it comes
to developing websites with python
basically you can create your database
tables
with python classes so in order to
use this feature we need to go ahead and
install some flask tool that allows us
to do so
so we will basically go ahead to our
terminal
and stop our website for a second so we
will basically go ahead and write in
pip install flask dash sql
alchemy now this is the exact package
that will
allow us to write database tables
with python classes and we are going to
see how we are going to
do the conversion from python to actual
database information just in a few
minutes so let's go ahead and install
that and once i click in here
then we can see that we receive a
successfully installed flask alchemy
message
and if you do not receive any errors
here then you should be fine
now let's clean our screen here just a
minute
okay so now we can go basically back to
our pycharm and continue on with the
configurations that we should apply
okay so once we install it we can
basically go ahead and import that flask
underscore sql alchemy so let's make our
phone
a little bit bigger here and we will
basically
say from flask
underscore sql alchemy import
sql alchemy like that
and once we have done that basically we
can go ahead and create an instance of
that class that we have imported
now the convention here would be to call
that variable db
because this is going to be our database
instance and we are going to
rely on that in the future so we will
type in here
db equals to sql alchemy and we will
close parenthesis
to initialize an instance of that class
and once we have done that we
need to pass our application as an
argument to that sql alchemy class so we
will basically type in here
at and if you remember that arrives from
here
where we created a flask instance so it
is important to
complete that line by writing in here
app
now once we have done that basically we
can start creating
our own classes and later on they will
be converted
into database table now those special
classes that are going to be converted
in the future to database table
are called models so we are going to
create one module
that its name is going to be item and we
are going to define several
columns that are going to be inside our
database in the future
so just basically let's go ahead and see
what i said
with a python code so we will go down
here a few lines
and we will create here a new class and
we will
name it item and once i have done that
basically i should
import from a special class that is
going to say to our flask application
that this is a model that is going to be
table
inside our database so this is why i
will open up a parenthesis here
and i will inherit from a class that is
called db
dot model so we will basically start by
creating some fields and we will start
by creating a field
that its name is going to be named
because it quite makes sense to describe
our items
with a name so we will go ahead and type
in here
name equals to and the way we are going
to create a column
will be by db.com and you want to close
the parentheses so we can understand
that we are creating an instance of this
column class
and once i create this then we should
pass in here some extra information in
order to create this column successfully
now one of them will be the type of the
column that you want to
create so we want to make it in string
type so
this is why i will go ahead and type in
your db dot string and i will close the
parenthesis here
as well now inside the string
we can basically limit the amount of
characters
that we should put in each of our names
so i can limit it to
30 characters by basically typing in
here
length equals to 30. so when i go ahead
and do this
basically i am not allowed to create an
item instance
and describe a name with more than 30
characters
and this is something that you want to
do because
you probably want to avoid the situation
where you
allow your users to create items with
a large amount of characters because
this could cause
from database to store too much
information and you probably don't want
to do that
so 30 characters for a name should be
enough
okay so once i have done that i can
basically go
outside of our string class in here
and pass in here some more arguments
right there so one of the first
arguments that we want to pass
is to describe to that column that we
don't want to have
null fields so we can go ahead and do
that by passing in here
nullable equals to false and the next
argument that i'm going to specify here
is going to allow our names to
not have the same name when it comes to
storing a large amount of items
so you probably want to avoid the
situation where
you have two or more items that their
name
are iphone 10 for example so you want
each item
name to be unique and you can do that by
easily saying unique equals to
true now if you remember
we also had some more fields that are
describing our items in this website
so if you remember from the dummy
information that we have generated
from that list we also had barcode
price and also id so let's go ahead and
create those columns as well
so i will basically go in here and
create
price equals to db dot column and that
time we want to change our type of
column to db dot integer and
this will allow our column to store
integers and not
strings like we did previously so now we
don't have to pass in
length for example because this is an
integer and so
we can also continue on by typing in
here
nullable equals to false and by the way
if you never heard about the null
keyword before
basically this is just another way to
say none so if you saw
none from python then you should be fine
to understand
null as well because this is just quite
the same
okay so i will delete that from here and
continue on creating
some more fields now one more field will
be the barcode that we also want to
create so it will be
db dot column and although it is going
to contain some
digits i still want to pass it in as
strings because i'm not going to do any
calculation with this barcode
i'm just going to store 12 characters
that they happen to be
digits so i will go in here and create
string and we will just pass in here
length
equals 12 so each barcode will be 12
characters and again we will type in
nullable equals false and this should be
unique as well so we will type in here
unique
equals to true like that
and once i have done that i also want to
add one more field that we
did not see before and this is going to
be like a paragraph that is describing
what this item is about so it makes
sense to go down here and
type in description equals to db
dot string excuse me db
dot column and now we will pass in here
db
dot string and now we probably want to
give
a huge amount of length in here
something like
1024 something like that just because we
want to
probably describe our items with a nice
paragraph
so once i have done that i can continue
on to nullable
equals false and we can create unique
equals to
true here as well but i am assuming that
we are not going to have the same
description
for our items if their size are
almost 1000 characters but again the
best practice will be to create unique
equals true
and now i also want to create one more
special field that is
quite required when it comes to
sql alchemy now the one more field that
you want to create is called
identifier and this is a type that is
called
primary key so this is just a convention
column that
you should create when you create your
models when it comes to
creating models with the flask framework
so we will go ahead and do that as well
and we will type in here
id equals to db dot
column and its type will be db
dot integer and we will basically go
ahead and type in here
primary underscore key equals to
true now if you not quite understand why
i'm doing this
basically this is a convention to our
flask models
so it can understand the unique objects
that are going to be inside our items
so it is a must thing that you should do
when you create modules with flask okay
so there are still some steps left to
see that item table within a nice
looking database
and we need to add several
configurations to our application
in order the flask to recognize a
database
so the way that we can do that is by
grabbing the
app object and adding in some new
configuration so it will be
add dot config and basically this
statement here is a dictionary that is
going to accept some new key values
from us so we will basically go ahead
and pass in here
some new key value and we can do that by
typing in here
sql alchemy underscore database
underscore uri and then we will point it
to where we are going to store our
file which is going to be the database
file so we can do that by
referring this configuration to a sqlite
3
file so i will basically go ahead and
type in here
sqli3 and this is going to be like a url
but
not besides it is going to be uri and i
will explain the differences just in a
second
so i will basically type in here sqli3
column
slash and we should add two more four
slashes here
as well and once i have done that we
will just give a name to our database
file
so it will be market dot db
okay so i know this line might confuse
everyone here so let's go ahead
step by step to understand this so first
of first we see
this app flask equals to double
underscore name that we have created in
the
very first steps so we use this app
object
and we add extra configuration so our
flask application
can recognize its database and the way
you can do that
is by adding key values that are
considered as conventions
so the flask application can understand
where the database is located at
so the convention will be to create a
key that
its name is sql alchemy underscore
database underscore
uri so uri stands for uniform
resource identifier and this is
different from url that you probably saw
everywhere because
this is not a link to a website this is
why we see the l
at the end of this statement this is an
identifier that
is just a file that is going to be
identified as database and basically the
way that flask application wants us to
do it
is by passing in here sqlite colon
three four slashes and then just give a
random name to the file
that you're going to create okay so once
we have configured this successfully
then we should go ahead and execute some
commands in order to create this actual
file and then we can see it visible
inside our project
directory so i will open our terminal
here and inside our command line we want
to enter to python shell because we
want to import the information from our
market dot py
file so i can basically go ahead and
type in here
python and make sure that you do that in
the same directory as your project so
you will not receive any errors so once
i have done that
basically i can import our market.py
file
like a python module so i will type in
here
import i mean from
market because this is the name of our
python file
import db now the reason i want to
import
db it is basically because i want to
take several actions within that
db variable that we created previously
now once i will execute this you might
receive a warning about some of the
features that are going to be disabled
in the near future
but don't worry too much about that this
is not an error so
you are totally fine if you see this
output
now i want to split our display a little
bit just to see you the result of
what happens when i run the following
command so i will basically locate our
terminal in here
and we'll make it a little bit bigger
like that and now i will go ahead
and create our database now the way that
we can do that
is by saying to our shell to
create all our tables that we have
created inside that python file
and if you remember our modules are
what considered as database tables to
our flask application so i will run
here db dot create underscore
all and if you do not receive any errors
after this command
then you should be totally fine now once
i have
executed this then you should see
the market.db file right
here inside our project directory so
that means that we have created database
successfully so this is quite great now
currently
our database is totally empty from
information so we probably want to go
ahead and create some items
inside our database and the way we can
do that is by accessing our database
like python code so this is what exactly
sq alchemy allows us to do so if by any
chance you
come from django world then you should
understand that the sql alchemy
is quite like the object relation mapper
of django so this is why we
work with the sql alchemy okay so let's
go ahead and create some items in here
so i will basically
import the item model that we have
created so it will be
from market import item
and once i do that then i can basically
go ahead and create an item like that so
let's create a variable
and it will be equal to item one and
this will be equal to
the item class so we will initialize an
item
and we will pass in here name equals to
phone let's call it
iphone 10 like that and we will also
pass in price so it will be 500
and we will also pass in some barcode so
if you remember this is a string so i
will just create some
random numbers in here
and we should have
12 characters so this is quite great and
we should also pass in
description and this will be equal to
just let's pass in a short description
now once i
enter this then we should be fine now
you probably have
noticed that we did not
pass in anything about the id
over here and the reason we did not pass
anything about the id
it is because the fact that we passed in
here primary key
equals to true so if this item is
happened to be
our first item in our database then its
id is going to be one and we are going
to see that just in a second
okay so let's go back to our shell here
and once we have created an instance of
item
then we want to save our changes to our
database so the way that we can do that
is by going ahead and typing here
db.session
dot add and we should pass in here the
argument of the
object that we have created which is
item one
and the next line here will be db dot
session dot commit and you should close
the parenthesis here
like that and this should do the job of
saving information
inside our database now to verify that
you already have
one item inside your database then you
can basically
run a command like the following and the
correct command for that will be
item.query.org
and once i run that then we should see a
result
of one object that is located inside
our database and let's actually show
what happens if we create one more item
and commit our changes to our database
so we will just type in here item two
equals to item
and we will pass pretty much the same
information like we did previously so it
will be name equals to
let's type in here laptop and price
would be 600 and
this time the description again will be
just a short description like that
and what else we got we have to pass in
barcode so let's pass in some
random 12 digits like that
and again we can basically go ahead and
add this object to our db session so
it will be the following command and we
can basically
run here db.session.com
so it will commit our changes and again
now i can execute the item
dot query dot all and
this should display us two items now you
may notice how the objects
are defined as the model name
space the identifying number that i
talked about now this is something that
you can actually
override and you can give your own
customization
to the way that you want to see your
items when you
try to query them by the python shell
so let's go ahead and see how we can do
that
okay so i'm back inside our pycharm
and this is as easy as overriding a
magic method
that is called dunder or epr now if you
don't know what dunder repr
is then i have a video on that special
magic method and basically you can check
my channel out to
see the thunder r apr video okay so
besides returning the default option
that we saw previously
we can basically return a
formatted string and it will be item
and then we will just pass in here self
dot name inside curly brackets just to
refer to that variable okay so once i
save my changes here
then we should load our information
again from the beginning so i will exit
our shell here and i will enter
it back but before i will clean our
screen and i will
type in here python and i will go here
and
write form market import db
and as well as we will throw market
import item and now if i'm executing the
same command like before
so it will be item.query.org
then you can see the differences from
the previous
result as we see our objects
that they are defined in a different way
so this is quite
great okay so i just cleaned my screen
here to show some more examples
now i'm going to show how you can
iterate over all of your items for
example
so it will be four item in
item dot query dot all
because this is the exact statement that
returns all of our
objects and once i iterate over it then
we can access each
field like the fields that we have
created
within our item model so it will be for
example item dot
name and it can be also item.price
and it also can be item dot description
and as well as item dot id and
also item dot barcode now once i hit
enter here then we should see all of our
results
that being shown like here so just
remember that you can access each of
your fields
like we defined them inside our model
okay so if we want to filter our objects
by some specific condition
this is something that is quite possible
as well so let's go ahead and show that
but just before let's clean our screen
here so we can have a better look
like that okay so the way you can
filter by some condition would be by
item
dot query dot filter
underscore by now the underscore by is
actually
referring to some key value that you
want to specify
in between those parentheses now let's
say that i want to filter by
items that they that its price is
500 so it could be basically price
equals to 500 and once i click enter
then it returns us a base query object
like that now the reason you see this
it is basically because you may have
more than
one result by executing that command
so to see the actual result of what
this exact statement returns you then
you
should iterate over it so it will be
full item in item dot
query dot filter underscore
by and again i will just type right in
here
price equals to 500 and once i do that
then i am allowed to access each of our
items
that their price are 500 dollars so we
can basically type in here item dot
name and once i execute this then we can
see that we
only have one item that its price
is 500 and its name is
iphone 10. now again just remember that
you will receive this result because the
filter on the score by
can return you more than one option that
this condition is actually a true
statement for those
objects okay so now that we pretty much
understood everything
that is relating to modules and
databases
it makes totally sense to scroll down
here
and change this dummy information to
something
else now you could probably guess what
i'm going to
write besides this long list that we
have created
so it will be as easy as typing in here
item
dot query dot all because this will
basically
return all the object of items that we
have stored inside our database
so once i save this and go
back to our shell here and let's
actually
exit from our python shell and execute
our server so it will be
set flask underscore app equals to
market dot py and it will be also
flask underscore debug equals to one
and we can execute here flask run okay
so
in here as you remember those three
items are used to be the information
that we have passed in as a dummy
information
now if i refresh it then you can see
that it is updated with the information
that is stored inside our database
and this is the behavior that we want to
reach
when we want to display some information
inside our website so this is totally
fine and it works correctly
so this means that we have done a great
job by creating a database that is
connected to
our web application okay so one final
thing that i'd like to
discuss about is the option to inspect
your database
in a visual graphical user interface
now because we use sqlite 3
as our database engine then we can
download
a browser that knows how to display
information
when it is done by sqlite3
so basically you can go ahead and search
in
google for a db browser for
sqlite and then you can see that it has
a lot of options for any kind of
operation system so
if i'm clicking here for example then
you can see that it has
download links for mac os and as well as
for windows applications
but basically this is something that
you'll maybe want to do because you want
to really have an
actual look for what is inside your
database so since i'm using windows
machine
currently then i already have downloaded
this software
and then i'm going to display you how
you can browse your information
in a visual graphical interface so let's
go ahead and have a look
okay so i will open our sqlite3
weaver and in here what i have to do
is only browsing the file of
our database files so once i click on
file and choose the open database option
then i should point it to the file that
we have just created
and as you can see i'm inside the
directory of
our project and what i have to do is
just selecting this and click on open
now once i do that then you can see that
we
have in here our tables and we
have only one table that its name is
item
now if we want to see its columns then
we can basically click here on that
arrow
and this will display you the columns
that we have created
to create this table so you can see that
we see
all the columns in here and if you want
to see the actual information inside
that table
then you can go easily by right clicking
and click on browse table
and you can see here that we have
actually stored information
and you can see the exact information
that i showed you from the python shell
so this is something that is optional
for me
this tool was very comfortable when i
developed some flask
projects and i really recommended to
look up for
such a tool that will display the
information for you visually
so it will make your lives easier in
certain cases
all right so now if we take a look to
what is inside the market.py file
currently
we have a model here and down below
we have several routes that we have
created
now we are going to create more models
and more routes in the future
and so it might be a great idea to have
a python file that its name is going to
be models.py
and also routes.py where we will store
all the routes now we are going to spend
a few minutes on how to reorganize our
project because it is not going to be
as easy as grabbing the models to a
models dot py file and import stuff
because we are going to end up with a
forbidden import and we are going to
explain that
in a few minutes so let's actually try
to split
our different flask elements to
different python files
so i will start with creating a new
python file
and for sure i will name it modules dot
py
and in here i will grab our single item
module
and i will try to paste it in inside our
modules
and currently i will allow myself to
ignore that db variable that is not
existing here
and i will go back to the market dot py
and i will do the same process
by creating routes.py and then i will go
back to our market.py and i will
grab in everything from here and paste
this in
over here so we could pay attention that
we have several
arrows because several functions are
not loaded inside that particular file
so how we are going to get out of this
so let's first go back to our
market dot py now as you know in python
when you
use the import keyword to import some
file then what python does
it executes the entire file line by line
so if you remember before we actually
moved the routes and the models
we used to have a market.py file
with modules over here and with routes
down below
now we could basically go ahead and
use here import modules and import
routes
but we still have to figure out how we
are going to
give these models.py the db variable
that it's missing so again we could try
to
solve that by moving that line
to modules dot py so i will paste this
in
inside here now we also end up
with missing the sql alchemy
instance so again we could grab this
in from here and paste this in
above here but we are never
going to get out of this because there
is always going to be something
missing in each file and then we will
end up
with something that is called circular
imports now what secular imports are
it is basically two files are trying to
import from each other and it is
something that is forbidden in python
because
each file will end up with some missing
variables
when it tries to load some variable from
python memory so in order to avoid this
python comes up with something that is
named packages
now we can basically package our entire
application
inside a new directory let's call it
something like
market and then we can create one more
python file
for example we can name it run execute
start something like that
and then that python file will know how
to
import everything step by step and the
only thing that we
will have to do is calling that specific
file
and then that python file will take care
of the rest
so this is the design that we are going
to implement
in that video and so by the end of this
video every
file will be at its own place and
everything will totally make sense for
you
so let's actually get rid of those lines
that i just pasted in over here
and revert them back inside our market
dot py
and then we will remove those again and
then now we will basically go ahead and
create a package
and then we will name it market so let's
see how we can do that
great so first of all we will go ahead
inside our flask market directory
and we will create that single file that
is going to take care of everything that
i just discussed about
and i will name it something like run
okay so
it is going to be responsible to execute
our application
and what i will do now is grab
everything
from our market dot py and
i will cut everything from here and i
will basically paste
this in over here now as i have
completed this basically i can allow
myself to delete the market.py
file because the routes are here and
then the models
are here so the market.py is quite empty
and i can allow myself to delete that so
let's go ahead and delete that
i will use the safe delete option all
right
and our next step here will be to create
new directory
and move our templates modules and
routes dot py
into that directory so we are packaging
every flask element
into a new directory that is named
market
so let's go ahead and create a new
directory here
and i will name it market and then we
will
basically move everything from here
to that market directory so
in python that will be as easy as
grabbing it
and just hovering it inside the market
here
then you can see that pycharm auto
completes me by asking
if i want to move some files into
that directory so i will basically use
the refactor option here
and then you can see that our modules
for example is located
inside the new directory now i will do
the same
with routes and also with
our templates
great and last we will also move in
our market.db okay so let's close each
file over here
so our structure right now is that we
have our
market directory and we have our run.py
python file which is outside of that
market
directory so let's see how we continue
from here okay so if we actually take a
look to the lines that
are left inside our run.py file they are
basically
some initialization lines that contains
very important information about our web
application
now what we must do with those lines of
code that are left over here
is to move them to a special python file
that is called double underscore init
now when
you work with python packages every
python package that is considered as a
regular package
is going to include one special python
file that its name
is always going to be double underscore
init double underscore
and what is so special with that file is
that when you
import it then before it loads what you
want to import to your file it is
basically going to execute that
particular file that is named double
underscore init double underscore
so it totally makes sense because
whenever we want to import some objects
or variables from our application
then we probably want to execute those
lines of code because those lines of
code are
what responsible to start our
flask application so we will go ahead
and do that
so i will basically go inside our market
directory and i will create an
initialization
file that will be responsible to define
this directory as a package so i will
name it double underscore init double
unscore as i said
and i will move in whatever is inside
that
run that py to that double
underscore init double underscore file
now what is so
special with the process that we have
done until now is that if we are going
ahead
from our run dot py file and we
try to import market then it is going to
recognize it as a package because we
have included that double underscore
init file
so if we were to try to import that
app variable that we have created then
it is going to be perfectly fine
because it recognizes that variable
from our double underscore init file and
anyway it is going to execute it as a
first step because this is why
we have that double underscore indeed
file and actually the next line that i
can allow myself to do here
is using app.run and
this file is going to be that pointer
file that is going to do the rest of the
job of importing everything so this is
how it is going to work right we are
basically going to import
our application from market package and
then we are going to
run it but before we actually try this
out
let's add here one more argument and it
is going to accept some arguments that
we
already familiar with and it is going to
accept here debug
equals true so we don't have to set up
those environment variables anymore
and one more thing that i'd like to add
here as a convention in python
is to test out if this run.py file
has executed directly now the way that
we can check that
is by writing the conditional of if
double underscore
name is equal to
double underscore main and again if you
don't know what this conditional is
about i have a video on my channel that
you can definitely check out
what this special if name equals main
does but basically it checks if our
run.py file
has executed directly okay so now let's
go ahead
to our terminal and try to see what will
happen if we
execute that run.py file now i know that
there is a great chance that we are
going to
fail and receive some errors but i want
to show you step by step how we are
going to overcome those errors
now that we have our package set up so i
will open
my terminal and basically the only thing
that i have to do now
is going ahead and execute that run.py
file
now our web application will start and
if we actually
try to access it then you can see that
we receive errors
that the root url is not found
now that doesn't make sense because if
we take a look
to our python then we can see inside our
routes dot py
that that we have the route for our
root url but the reason this fails it is
because the double underscore
init file does not recognize the routes
that we have created
inside that route dot py file so
our first step here is going to be to
complete this dunder emit file
by saying from market
import routes and as you remember
if we import certain file then python
is going to try to execute what is
inside that file
so now we can go back to our
web browser and the test results out now
you can see that our web application is
probably down right now because we
see that this site can't be reached and
as you can see
we started to receive certain errors
about the import
so in that route.py file
we don't have the application defined so
let's go ahead and fix that
so i will go to our python
and i will basically type in
from market import
app and as you can see that app errors
are started to disappear
but we still have left with the render
template error
so we can also go ahead and fix it by
saying
from flask import vendor
template and then we also have one more
error
that we must fix in here and that will
be the import of
our models dot py because as you can see
we have a line here that says
item.query.org
and it doesn't know anything about it
because it is not a recognized
model and i can basically import it like
we can
import from a regular package in python
and that will be by
saying from market dot
models import item so now we have pretty
much everything set up in our routes dot
py
and if we have a look inside our models
dot py
then we still have some errors over here
left over
so i can basically fix it by saying
from market import db
because we can import it from our dander
init file
and now everything should work so we can
basically test this up by
going to our terminal and re-run our
application and i will clean my screen
again
and i will try to run that py file again
and now our website is up and running
and i can basically test if everything
works properly
and if i refresh it then you can see
that we receive our web application
as it's supposed to now if i navigate to
that market page
then you can also see that everything is
quite great
so this means that everything works
great
and we have completed our packaging
successfully
now i know that there was a lot of
information that will probably have to
sink in
but i hope that the packaging process
was clear and you pretty much understood
everything about what i have done here
so again the main idea was to package
everything that
is related to market and then having one
single file that we basically can
execute it
and then this file will be responsible
to do everything for us
now i just realized that i did not
specify a lot of times throughout this
tutorial
that our code is available from the
github and you can definitely go
down below to the description and bring
the link
for the repository that includes the
code
of that tutorial and you can download it
in the way that you like them so you can
also use the command of git clone
or you can download it as a zip file up
to you
but basically it is a great idea to go
to that link and
follow the code that i'm writing
throughout this tutorial okay so let's
go ahead and continue so
i will basically have to deal with
a way how i can accept users to our
website
and the way that we are going to do that
is obviously by storing some information
regarding our users
in a database so it totally makes sense
to
go ahead and create a new module and
then we will store some special fields
like
username password and stuff like that
that is going to be
our columns within that model so let's
go ahead and do that so i will go
up top here basically i'd like to remain
the item as our second module
and i will write in top here class
user and it will inherit from db.module
like we did in our previous modules and
our first
column would be the id again so
as you remember i said previously that
it is a convention
and it is a must thing to have that id
field because this is how the flask
wants to identify each of your objects
by their id numbers
so i will allow myself to copy this line
from
here and paste this in as a first line
over there
and now i can allow myself to continue
and creating some new fields so i will
go ahead
and create username equals to db
dot column and i will make that to be
equal to
db dot string and i will close this
out and it is a great idea to limit our
users
by saying length equals to 30 so it will
be maximum 30 characters per each
username
and this is something that we want to
keep unique
because we probably don't want to let
our website users to have
multiple usernames that they are the
same so unique
could be true and we will also
specify nullable equals false and just
to follow this exact same order like we
did previously
i will go here and type in nullable
equals
false and i realize that i missed the
comma here
so let's complete that out okay so this
is our username field
and as you know in most of the websites
we also have to
provide our email address when we
register to a different site
so it is also a great idea to have an
email field
so it will be email address
equals to db.column and this time i want
to
limit this email address as well
but i have to raise our limit a bit so
if there is a username with a length of
30 characters
then it might be a greater idea to give
our
email address a limit of 50 characters
so there is a lot of space for
at email.com something like that so i
will also make that
nullable equals to false and also unique
equals true that is quite making sense
and our next field here would be our
password now i'm going to
name this field a little bit different
because we are not going to store
passwords as plain text
inside our database now doing something
like this could lead to a lot of
security risks
and that is something that is basically
called make hackers life easier
to pull some information from your
website's database
so you'll probably want to avoid this by
storing the password
not as plain text but besides you'll
want to apply some hashing algorithm
or some another way that will encrypt
that password
so even if there is a hacker that is
going to steal some password information
from your website
he doesn't have a lot of things to do
with that because it is encrypted
so i will name this field by saying
password
underscore hash and that will be equal
to db
dot column and we are going to
receive here string again now i'm going
to
give this length 60 because the mostly
used hashing algorithm that flask allows
us to use
will always convert the passwords to
being
60 characters so this is why i'm going
to specify here
length equals to 60 and i will continue
on by
saying nullable equals to false and
i actually don't have to write here
unique equals true because
it is totally fine if two people have
the exact same password in our website
now this is the password field we still
have some more fields to set up for our
users
and the next one will be the budget now
if you remember from the very beginning
of this tutorial i said that we are
going to
apply a budget system for our users so
it totally makes sense to describe
our user's attributes by one more
attribute that its name
would be budget so i will go ahead and
say
budget equals to db dot column
and that time this will be equal to db
dot integer and we will go
here and continue by saying nullable
equals false and we are also going to
set a default
value when this user object is created
now you'll probably want to give some
amount of money for your new users to
start buying and selling
stuff from the market so we will set the
default
value for that for example to 1000
so the users can at least have 1000
coins
at the very first registration attempt
okay so it totally makes sense to set up
a value like that
and one final field that i like to add
here before we close up this module
will be a field that is going to be
related to our items module now what
that means it means that we want to
allow our users to
own several items because this is what
this website is going to be about
so in database definitions this is
something that is called
relationship between a two tables now in
our case we use modules because we work
with python but
we have to use some special field that
is called
relationship and inside that
relationship
field we are going to describe several
arguments
to make the model to understand that the
user can own some items okay so let's
go to here and write in
items equals to so we will type in
db dot relationship
like that and we will close our
parentheses and the relationship is
going to be
with our item model so we will say that
by
writing the model name inside a string
like
this now continuing from here i am also
going to type in
back riff equals to and we will open a
single code and
inside here we will say owned
user and what backref does it is
basically a
back reference to that user model so for
example if we have one user and then we
want to know the items that this user
owns
we are basically going to grab the
object of the user and we will access
the attribute of items
but let's consider a situation that you
have an iphone item
inside your database and you want to
know
its owner now you are going to grab the
item object
and then you will access it by the
attribute of
owned user and that is because you
specify the back reference
of that item so it is quite important to
provide this back reference
because it will allow us to see the
owner of specific
items so the last argument that i will
say here will be
lazy equals true and that is something
that we also have
to set up here because if you don't set
up the lazy equals true
then the sql alchemy will not grab all
the objects
of items in one shot so it is quite
important to specify the lazy equals
true
in that case now i want you to take a
look how
this db is not actually a column
besides it is a relationship so what
that means it means that this is not
actually going to be stored as a column
when we try to inspect inside our
database
so it is quite wrong because we also
want to store
information about certain users that are
owning some items now the way that we
are going to do that
is by saying to our items module
which user is owning it so we will go
back to our items module and
specify one more column that we must
create
in order to make this relationship to
work
successfully so we will go here and we
will type in
owner equals to db dot
column and this will be an integer
and the next thing that we want to write
here is the relationship to the user
model so i will say
db dot foreign
key like this now what foreign key does
it
search for the primary key of your model
from the
module that is related to now if you
remember i said previously that
there is a great reason that we have to
create
this id in here in order to the
sql alchemy to understand each row that
is going to be stored inside our
databases
so now if we go ahead and create foreign
key we can basically say
that this foreign key is going to be
related
to the other modules primary key
so we will say in here user dot
id and this is related
to the each unique row that is going to
be stored in that id so it is quite
important
to write here user dot id in lowercase
okay so now i'm back at my terminal and
i like to
create all the tables from scratch
inside our database so we will go with
python
and we will use here from market.modules
import db and then we can basically
say db.drop all now this will
delete entire information from your
database including all the tables
so we will say that and then we will
recreate
everything now i'm doing this just
because we want to clean our information
before we test
new things out but in production when
you add a new table you don't always
have to delete the entire information
basically you could also execute create
underscore all but i just wanted to show
you that there is the option of
drop underscore all as well so now if i
go ahead and create everything
then if i don't receive arrows then it
means that everything looks great
now we can continue by importing the
modules so we will say
import user and item again
from our market dot modules now we can
basically try to create a new user to
see if
everything has worked properly so we
will say u1
equals to user and we will specify the
username
this will be equal to jsc for example
and we will write in
password underscore hash this will be
equal to
just random string of numbers and we
will also say
email equals to
something like the following now if you
remember we also have the
fields of budget and the owner now
i did not specify nullable equals to
false on both of those
so that means that it should be enough
now i guess i missed the email here so
we should
fix that to underscore address and now
we are fine
now let's clean the screen a bit we will
say
os dot system and we will execute
this cls inside here and now i can
basically
go with db.session.ad
and we will add the u1 in here and we
can commit our changes by saying
dot db.session.com okay so now this
should be enough for our user to be
stored inside our database
now to see this we can basically execute
user.query.all
and then you can see that we have one
user with
the user one statement right here so it
means that everything worked
great okay so i cleaned the screen a
little bit here so i also want to test
up the relationship
if it works great so we can basically
create several items quickly
and set their owners to the user that we
have just created
and see if everything works well so i
will go ahead and say
i1 equals to an item and i will go
by saying the name equals to iphone 10
for example
and we will type in description and we
will just write in a short description
here
and we will say barcode equals to
a string like that and we will type in
price equals to 800 for example
so i just missed up the desk we should
create the description
like that okay so everything works great
and i will go
by saying db.session.ad
and i will add i1 and i will now
use commit so we will commit our changes
now let's repeat ourselves with another
item so i will clean the screen here
quickly
and i can load the previous commands by
using the arrow signs
so i can basically change this to i2 and
this to laptop
and i will change the description to
description too
and the barcode here will be a little
bit different
and the price will be 1000 that time
and we can repeat ourselves again by
saying
[Music]
like that okay so now we have two items
stored inside our database so we can
verify this
by saying query dot all and now let's
try to assign an ownership to the iphone
10 item so
we have to go and filter this specific
iphone 10 object and we can do that by
saying
item.query that filter underscore by
and i can filter by name equals to
iphone 10
like that okay so it also makes sense to
assign this into a new variable so i
will
go ahead and with item one i will assign
it
and now if i access item one then you
can see that it returns us a base query
and now we can basically use this first
method to grab the specific object
itself so now
i have the item1 object in here
and now i want to test up the results if
i try to access the attribute of owner
and now you can see that it returns us
nothing because
it doesn't have a owner now to continue
from here i can basically
say that i want to assign the owner of
item 1
to the specific object of the user that
we have just created previously
with the username of jsc so it will look
like something
like the following so it will be
item1.owner
and this will be equal to
user.query.filter
underscoreby and i want to filter by the
username equals to
jsc and if you remember this entire
statement here returns us a base object
and we have to access the actual object
by saying
that first and as i have done that then
i can continue on to
db.session.com and i can assign the item
one and now sorry i should have
type in here add great and then
i should have continue to commit
now as i have done that then we can see
a several errors over here
now i can see that we have this update
item set owner where item.id
equals to a question mark now i have a
feeling that i know why this happened
and it sometimes that always may confuse
every one of us
and the point is we have to understand
that the only way that we can assign the
attribute of
owner is by specifying the id
of the user so if you remember our
foreign key
is only going to accept the attribute of
id
so this is why we have done a great job
by filtering the specific user
but only we had to give it the attribute
of id
so let's go ahead and fix that so before
everything let's clean the screen
for a minute so it will be cls inside os
dot system
and before i actually take different
changes inside our item one
we have to execute this command which is
going to
look like db.session.rollback
so we can roll back our previous changes
and commits
and once i execute that if i did not
receive any errors
then it should be fine and now i will
just type in the exact same command
that we wrote previously so it will be
item1.owner and it will be
query dot filter underscore by
and we will filter by jsc
and after the dot first in here
we have to give it the attribute of id
and once i have done that then i can
basically
add it to our session which is clean
because we have rolled back the previous
commits
and now we can try to execute the commit
and this should work so if i was to go
ahead
and see the owner then you can see that
it returns us
one and the reason it returns as one it
is basically because this is the foreign
key
of the owned user now we can also test
this by
filtering the item specifically so we
can go with i
equals to item dot query
dot filter underscore by and we want to
filter by name
equals to iphone 10 like that and now we
can basically try to see the back
reference of the item that i talked
about
so if you remember we had that
backref attribute set up so if i was to
go ahead
and execute i dot owned user
then we would receive some errors
because again i missed the
dot first in here and now i can run in
on user then you can see that it returns
us the actual
user that owns this item so this is
quite great
and this is a great achievement that we
have done until now
so so i hope you understood everything
about how relationships of databases
working
because it is quite important to be
aware of that situation
so this is the actual idea of our
website right we want to own
items as users inside our web
application
okay so previously we have created our
user module
but we currently don't have any special
way to create users to our website
besides the only way to do that will be
by our terminal and we are probably
looking for a way to customize a nice
looking html page for our customers
so they will have the ability to
register to our website
so the way we can do that is by
customizing an html form now we probably
want to make this form
smart enough to check certain things to
see if this information is valid
so for example you can't create a user
if there is already a user with the same
name or if your password
linked does not meet the requirements of
your
website or anything else that is quite
dealing
with validating stuff when it comes to
register to
a website so in order to create our
forms to register smart enough
flask delivers already a built-in
package to create phones and this also
allow us to
display it nicer on our html templates
so in order to start working with this
we need to go ahead to our terminal and
install some packages so this is why i
will open my terminal here
and i will basically type in some pip
install commands
so the first one will be pip install
flask dash and this is the first package
that will allow us to
create nice looking forms and then later
on to display them
on our html templates so i will clean
the screen here and
our second package will be pip install
wt forms so you can see that it is
already installed probably this was a
secondary package under the
flask wtf so anyway just write this
command
as well for safety and let's continue
from here
okay so as i said previously the forms
are going to be a quite different
element
in our flask application so this is why
it totally makes sense to
create a python file that we will name
it phones.py
and then each form that we are going to
create for some situation
will be stored there so let's go ahead
and do that
so i will go under my market directory
and i will create a new python file we
will name it
forms and here we will write our forms
that we want to display them on our html
templates
now the way that this is going to behave
is quite
similar to models because we are going
to create classes
and then we are going to create some
fields inside our classes
and then that way those fields are going
to be the
required fields for our customers that
they have to
fill in in order to register to our
website so let's go ahead and do that
but the first step is to
actually import those libraries that we
have just installed
in order to create those forms so i will
basically
go with form flask underscore
wtf import flask form
and then we also want to import some
special fields
that are going to be recognized by a
special type of field
so for example we might have an integer
field for our users if we want to ask
them about
the year of birth or we might have a
string field if we want to ask them
about their name
so this is why we should go ahead and
also import the special fields by saying
from wt form import string
field now we can also go ahead and
import
more types of fields but currently we
will only start with the
string field okay so we will start by
creating our register form so it is
going to be
by saying class register form
and this will inherit from the flask
form class
that we have imported over here so this
is why i will type in here flask form
so the next thing that i will do here is
creating some fields
that they are going to be recognized as
our form fields
so i will start by creating a username
field because it totally makes sense to
register
our users to ask for a username so it
will be equal to
string field because this is a string
and then there is a convention to give a
label for each of our fields so i will
provide in here label
equals to username and i think that will
be it for the username field
now we are also going to ask the email
address from our user so i will go ahead
by saying
email underscore address equals to
the string field again and that time i
will
label it by email only so this should be
enough now i am also going to create two
different fields for
our passwords so it will be password one
and also password two now the reason you
want to do this
because mostly in each website you see a
field about the password
and also about the confirmation of that
password
so this is why it makes sense to create
two separated fields
and then later on we are going to write
a validation
that is going to check if password one
is equal to password two so we can
submit the register form successfully so
to create this
a string field is not considered as a
best
practice because the wt forms has a
dedicated field
for password fields so i will go here
and i will import it by saying password
field and then i will create it as a
password field over here
like that and i will close the
parentheses and the same
will be for the password tool as well so
i will create it as a password field
now let's give it their labels as well
so it will be password1
for the label of that and for the label
of password2
it will be password2 alright so now that
we have created those fields
we also have to create the field that
will allow the users to
submit their actual information now when
you see some forms
not only you'll see areas where you have
to fill in some information
but you also see a button that you have
to submit your final information so this
is why i will create a field
that is going to be by the type of
submit so i will go
to our second line here and i will
import
that submit field and then i will create
one submit field so
it will be submit equals to submit field
and again its label is going to be
submit
so i think this should be enough for now
for
our registered form later on we are
going to go back to that register form
to write some validations in order to
make our form more secure okay so now it
is a great idea to
import this registered form class from
our routes now we currently don't have
any route for our registration page
so let's go ahead and create one so i
will go to my
routes dot py and i will zoom in the
phone here and i will
start creating a new route for our
register page
so it will be at act dot route
and i will navigate our users to forward
slash
register and then we will create this
register page route
by calling this function register page
now the first step here would be to
import that form from the forms dot py
so i will go up top here and i will
import it
by saying from market dot forms
import register form
and inside that function i will
basically
use the register form class to create
one instance of it so it will be form
equals to register form and i will close
this up
like this now as we have completed that
we have to look up for a way to display
the fields of that phone
inside an html page now the way that we
can do that is for sure by
rendering a template with the name of
register for example and then we can
pass as information
our form instance so we will say
here return render underscore template
and then we will send
our users to a template named
register.html
and i know that we did not create it yet
but we will do it very shortly
and the information that we want to send
to that template
will be that form instance that we have
created here
so it will be form equals to form
and i think that will be enough for this
stage and now let's go ahead and create
this register.html
template so it will be here and i will
basically create a new html
file we will name it register
and then we will replace it with some
html code that is going to be
responsible
to display that form in a very nice way
now i will delete the auto generated
html and i will start by
for sure extending our base template so
if you remember we have our base
template
that we have to inherit when we create a
new template
so it will be curly brackets and then
the percentage signs
and then the closure for our curly
brackets
and between those we will type in
extends
and then we will extend our base.html
now as i have completed that we have two
blocks that we should use and then
contain some information
inside there so if you remember we had
inside our
base dot html a blog title
and also a blog content
so i will copy the blog title and i will
paste this in
and i will also copy the blog content
and i will paste this in as well now
let's fix
the indentation here a little bit and
we will continue from here now if you
remember in the blog title we are
allowed to provide
information that is going to be
displayed as our tab names
so it makes sense to type in something
like
register page and in here let's actually
give a random information currently to
test
if everything works properly so i can
validate myself by only writing some
basic html code so
let's write in here register form inside
the h1 tag
all right so we have one more step to
complete before we can go ahead and
actually test this out
and that will be to create a special
secret key
that is going to be identified as the
secret key of our flask application
now the main reason that you want to do
that in this stage
it is because if you go ahead and test
the
form out right now nothing is going to
show up because when you create
forms in html you actually have to
provide one more security layer
in order to show this form up and that
is simply because we change our request
type to our clients
so until now we were able to display
html pages
for our clients but when it comes to
forms
now our clients are going to be able
to submit actual information towards our
database so
this is a quite different action that
must be secure enough
so this is why we have to create a
secret key
for our flask application so the way
that we can do that
is by generating some series of
characters that
is going to be used as our secret key
so i will open our terminal and i will
go
inside python and i will import the os
library because
simply we can generate there a
hexadecimal random characters
so it will be by import os and then we
can basically go ahead and say
os dot u random and then we can provide
here the value of 12 so it will be by
the value of 12 bytes and then we can
basically
go ahead and convert this to hexadecimal
values
and then the value that we'll be
receiving back would be the secret key
that we auto generated for our
application
now there is nothing wrong with going
ahead and generate
more secret keys but just make sure that
if you
use one then stick to it throughout the
development of that application
so let's grab this secret key
and go back to our python and
navigate inside our init.pi and then
here we have to
write in some new configuration so it
will be app.config
and then our key here will be secret
underscore key
and if we paste this in right there
and this should be inside single quotes
as well
then this should be enough to display
the form
that we just created so i will go back
to my terminal
and we can exit the python shell now and
we can basically
execute our application with python
run.py and then we can navigate
back to our website and try to see what
will happen
if i go to fort slash register and then
you can see that we have our page up and
running so this is quite great
now one more thing that i like to do
before we continue is to
actually configure that navbar button
where we can click on it and then this
will lead us to the route of the
register page
so if you remember previously we learned
about the url underscore 4
built in so let's go ahead and configure
that so it will be as easy
as going to our base dot html
and identify that register page
which is right there so this is the
anchor tag for our register page
and if you remember from previous
examples
for example for the home page we use
this built-in
url for function so i will allow myself
to copy the
exact statement and paste this in
inside our href attribute and then this
could be
changed to register underscore page
and now we can test this out by
refreshing our page
and for example navigate to our four
slash home
and we can click on slash register then
you can see that it works great so now
we can continue on customizing that form
okay so i'm back in my register.html
and in here you could notice how i
deleted the code inside our blog
content now inside the content we are
going to
put the form itself and the way that we
can access the form instance
is referring to the variable that is
passed from our route
with jinja syntax so it will be by
saying
form within double curly brackets so
just to check if this works properly we
can basically navigate back to our
website
and see what happens if we go with fold
slash register
then you can see that we see the object
itself of the form
so this means that we can access the
form itself now to access the actual
fields and to visualize them better we
are going to
take some different actions in here so
we have to
create the form tag which is a built-in
tag in html syntax
and we also have to specify some more
attributes in order to
the form to work successfully so one of
them will be the meta type
now i did not talk about request methods
before but basically when it comes to
websites
you have a lot of request methods that
the clients can provide and the most
known request method will be the get
method where
clients are requesting to display some
information
on different web pages but there is also
one more different request method that
is called
post and the post request is a kind of
request that is going to
affect the database of your website
so since this is a critical action to
take as a website client
then you have to specify that the method
is going to be
post so it is important to provide this
kind of information in here
and i will continue on by saying class
equals to form dash register and the
last attribute in here
will be the styling so we want to style
our
foreground color to white so it will be
color
column white so i'm doing this because
we are working on dark mode
and it is quite important to have the
foreground color
set as white okay so inside
our form tag we can basically refer
to our form fields by
saying so i will open the curly brackets
one more time
in here and i will first call the label
of our form fields
and then i will call the field itself so
you will see the effect of that just in
a second
so i will say form.username dot
label and i will open and close the
parenthesis here
and below that we can say form dot
username
and i can open the parentheses and close
them up here again
now what is so special with that flask
forums
is that this statement is going to
accept attributes
like in real html code so we could say
here
class and then we could basically give
it a bootstrap
class so i will say form dash control so
it will be responsible to
display that field a little bit nicer
and we can also give it a placeholder so
our clients
can understand that this field is
designed for providing the username so
we can say
first of all let's add a comma here and
we can say placeholder
equals to user name
like that and let's see the actual
results of a code
like this so if i'm going to our web
browser
and refreshing that out then you can see
that we see
an empty field where we can provide some
information
now i know that this looks quite ugly
and
in most of the websites the information
of filling a form
is starting not from the left position
so we can fix that by containerizing
those fields inside one more
special html field so let's go ahead and
do that so i will open our pycharm
and in here we can containerize our
form inside div tag so i will allow
myself to
type in here the class container
so i will allow myself to paste this
form
inside those div tags and let's fix the
indentation here a little bit and then
let's test out
the differences so i will refresh this
out now
you might be bothered by the results
from that username in here
but this is something that we can change
in our forms dot py so this is the
label of our username field so we called
basically open
our forms dot py and we could change
the label so now you can understand what
the label
does it basically gives a kind of
secondary title
for our fields so we called say here
user name like that and we could also
change
that to email address
like this and we could also add
here password like the following
and we could also change this to confirm
password like that so it makes a lot of
sense to display the label of our
password tool as confirmed password
because it probably looks nicer to our
clients so let's see the results of that
so if i refresh it
then you can see that we have a nice
secondary title
for that field now the way that we are
going to continue
is going to be by copying and pasting
those
form labels and the form fields itself
so we can basically copy and paste
ourselves
four times and we can change this to
email
we can also change that to email as well
and we can change the placeholder to
email
address like that and we can
do this for our passwords as well
so i will paste this in over here
and this will change to password
one and this is going to be changed to
let's scroll down password in here
and this is going to be password one as
well
great so now i can duplicate this one
more time and we can change this to
password tool
we can change this to password two and
this will be
confirm password now to test the results
of that
we can refresh it you can see that we
receive an
error and that is fine because
we defined the email field as email
underscore address so
let's fix that quickly so it will be
underscore address
and underscore address as well now you
can see that
i trained to not cut the arrows that i
received throughout this video sometimes
because
i really want you to be aware of the
possible arrows that you can
meet throughout the process of writing
any html code
or any python related code so this is
the reason that
i'm okay with the arrows and handling
them on the fly
okay so i will refresh that out then you
can see that we
receive a lot of nicer form in here now
i want to give a nice image
for this form and i also want to give a
h1 tag
so the users can see a nice big title
now the code that i'm going to paste in
here you can find it from my website
because i put all the code snippets in
the flask tutorial section
which you can find in my courses so
i will paste it in over here and
you can see in the first tag here
that i have an image tag which is going
to be
responsible simply displaying the logo
of my website
and the h1 tag in here that is going to
say to our users
please create your account so let's just
fix the indentation in here
and i think this should be it and i also
want to add here a
break line tag so we can have a
separation
between our header to our fields
okay so if we test the results then you
can see that we have a
great result where we see the logo of my
website
and we also have a nice title now
it could be a lot better if we could
centralize
these objects so this is something that
we
also can apply and the way we can do
that
is by going in here and overriding
the body tag of our html
file so i will allow myself to make the
font a little bit smaller here
and what we can do here is basically
wrapping the entire
div with a body tag so we can
say here body and then we can basically
use the class
of text dash sender and we can close
this out and we can move the closure of
our body
to the very last line just above the end
block and now if i refresh that
out then you can see that we receive a
nice looking form
where everything looks pretty clean in
my opinion now there is one more thing
left that
is remained to close out this form and
this is the submit field that is missing
in here
so we can basically go back to our
register.html
and we can add it in here so i will
call the ginger syntax in here by using
the double curly bracket
and i will call the submit field so it
will be form dot
submit and now in here we can provide
some bootstrap classes as well so it
will be
class equals to and then we will type in
the
classes that we want to include to
customize this submit button a little
bit better so it will be btn
and i will type in btn-lg which will
responsible to display this button
larger and i will also
say btn-block and this will expand
the button to the entire forum and i
will also type in
btn-primary so this should be
responsible to display the button
in a nice blue colored version so i will
save this out
and i will also add in here one more
vr tag so we will have a nice separation
between those
and okay so now we can basically test
the results
by refreshing this page and now you can
see that we
got the submit button but we have the
annoying
submit text with all the lowercase now
this
happens because of the labels
that we have created for each of our
field again so we should
change this to something like create
account and once i have done that then i
can
verify myself by refreshing it now you
can see that we receive a nice button
for the create account now nothing is
going to happen
when i click on create account and when
i fill in some information
and actually this is something that we
have to handle in a separated way
inside our routes.py and we will do that
very soon
all right so until now we were not able
to configure the
behind the scenes actions of what
happens when we create the
create account button now to do this we
have to go to our routes.py file
and then we have to go for the route
where the register form is located
and then write some pure python code
over there so to do this i will open
my python and in here i can basically
handle
what happens when the user submits on
the create account button
so the best practice in that case will
be to start by
this conditional so it will be if form
dot validate on submit
now there are two main reasons that
you want to execute this conditional
before you
actually go ahead and submit changes
into your database okay so the first
reason you want to execute that
is you'll want to verify that those
comments that
i'm going to write in here are only
going to be executed when the user is
submitted on that button
so this on submit part is actually
checking if the
user has clicked on the submit button of
that form and the second reason you want
to execute this
it is mainly because we are going to
write some validations
that are going to check for certain
requirements
before this form becomes valid so i'm
talking about conditions like you see
in real register pages in real websites
for example your password
should be matched or your user
name should not contain more than 20
characters and stuff like that so this
is why it is very important to
execute this conditional in here and
once this returns true
then i can basically go ahead with
user to create
like that and i will make that to be
equal to an instance
of user and it is a great idea to
import it from the market.models in here
so i will basically add a comma and i
will import the user
and once i have done that then i can
basically give the arguments that are
required to create a user so i will
start by saying
username equals to and in here i
actually want to provide the value
that is received from the username field
within
the form so i can do this by saying from
dot username dot data so this is the way
that we are going to pass
our fields from the form and i will
continue on doing this
with the email address as well so i will
say email underscore address
equals to form dot email
underscore address dot data and i will
perform the exact same action with
password so
it will be password equals to
form dot password one and in here i'm
passing password one
by purpose and you will see in a few
minutes why i am doing this
so i will say that data in here again
okay so this should be enough to create
the instance of our user
and once i have done that then i can
basically execute the same commands
to submit the changes towards our
database
so it will be db session dot add
and i will pass in the argument of user
to create and i know that we did not
import the
db variable in here so it is a great
idea to import it
now i will go down here and
i will say from market import
db now the reason i can import it
directly from the
market package it is mainly because it
is located in the
under init file so i don't have to go
inside
dot something okay so it is quite great
to import it
that way and now i will go back to our
route
and i will say
dot db.session.com and this will save
our changes to the database and once we
have done that
then we probably want to redirect
our users to a different page now
it quite makes sense because now they
are registered to
the website and now we can show the user
the items that are available on the
market so i will use the built-in
redirect function
that the flask package offers us so i
can go
up here and i can go for that line
and i can basically import the built-in
function which is called redirect and i
will also import the built-in
url underscore four function that we
used
previously in our templates so we will
go
down here and we will see how we can
redirect our users to a different page
after the user is clicking on the create
account
button so i will go right after our
commit
command and i will say return
redirect and in here the redirect
function
expects for an hard-coded url now if you
remember previously
in that tutorial we said that it is not
a great idea to
give arguments as a hard-coded urls
so besides doing this i will say url
underscore
form and i will give the url underscore
for the name of the route itself so it
will be
market underscore page and this should
send our
users right to here so it is quite
great okay so we can just test this out
by going back to our chrome browser
and refresh that out and then now let's
try to create a random account and see
what happens okay so we will
say here jsc 2 for example and we will
fill
in some dummy email and i will just type
in
very basic password and i will try to
create account
now you can see that we receive method
not allowed and actually there's a
reason that i wanted us to
see this message because it is quite
important to apply
the step that i'm going to talk about
now when it comes to web requests we
said that we have several
request methods and we should allow our
routes
to handle post requests and the way that
we can do that
is by customizing the decorator of our
route function
so i will go right here and i will say
methods equals to and i will open here a
list and i will insert two elements
and i will give get and i will also give
post okay so it is important to apply
this step so our
route could handle post requests and
before we continue
sorry about that but i think that we
mismatched this line in here
and this should be password underscore
hash
equals to form.password1.data so make
sure to fix that
before you continue alright so once we
have enabled the post
request in that route then there is one
more important step that we have to
configure before we test this out
now when you send information from
client to a server
then it gives a huge opportunity to the
hackers out there
to steal that information and one of the
known
malicious attacks is called cross
site request forgery and this
attack is basically just a way to steal
or perform
actions against your database that are
unwanted
and to protect our website from such an
attack
flask delivers us a very easy future to
apply a protection
so the way that we are going to do that
is as easy
as going to our register.html
and right under our form method post
html tags we are basically going to
say so we will open our curly brackets
to
refer to ginger syntax and we will
easily say
form dot hidden underscore
tag and what this is going to do it is
going to protect us from the
attack that i was talking about by
generating some
token that is basically again just going
to protect us from such an attack
and okay now we can save that file and
once we have completed this
let's actually test if our website is up
and running
and we will now go to our website and we
will
navigate to our register page and we
will try to create a new account
so it will be jc2 for example and we
will try to provide in some random email
here
and we will try to fill in some password
and now if i'm going to press on create
account and going to be redirected to
the market page
then it means that the user has been
created and if i click on that
then you can see that this is the exact
result so that means that we have
created
this account and we can test this by
easily
going to python shell and type in
user.query.org
and this will be responsible to give all
the users and we probably will see the
jsc tool
account that we have just created okay
so although now we have the ability to
register
users we did not set up any special
policy
regarding to how we want to register our
users
and what i mean by that is you saw
previously
how i created a user with a password
that only contains six characters and we
did not even write a python code
anywhere in our project
that verifies that the password and the
confirm
password are match so this is very
wrong when it comes to web applications
and not secure
and actually this is a huge bug now to
solve this we can basically write in
some
validations to solve that problem and
then those validations are going to be
executed before the form is submitted
and the way that we can do that is by
the flask validations
package that is offered by the flask
itself so let's go ahead and
try to apply some validations to
see that the data that we are receiving
is actually
valid so i will make the font a little
bit bigger here
and i will say down here from
wt forms dot validators
and in here there are a lot of built-in
classes
that are going to check for certain
validations
so let's say that we want to validate
that the
username length is maximum 30 characters
and
minimum two characters so we can do that
by importing a
built-in class that is called linked
and now once i have done that then we
can go
inside our username field and we can
call the validators argument
and basically we can say that we want to
validate
the length so it will be length
and then i will open the parenthesis
here and i will say minimum
equals to 2 and i will also say
max equals to 30. so
what this line of code does it basically
verifies before the submission that the
username value includes between 2
to 30 characters and we can write more
validations like that in each of the
fields that we
want so let's say that we want to apply
the exact
same step for our passwords so it will
be as
easy as going to our password one field
and say valley datos again
and this will be equal again to a class
of length
i mean an instance of the length class
and we can now provide here
minimum equals to six and i actually
don't want to set a maximum
value for our passwords because if our
users want to
have a huge password then it is quite
okay
now we could copy the exact
validation to our password tool as well
but we probably want to avoid that
because if this validation is going to
be executed on password one
then we probably don't need to execute
it again on our password too
because we want those fields to be
matched and as i said that how we are
going to verify
that password two matches password one
well the way that we can do that is by
importing
one more class from the
wtforms.validators
and we can basically check if password2
is equal to password1 when the form is
submitted
so it will be as easy as importing the
equal
to class here and go to our password
tool
and say validators equals to
equal to and then in here we will
pass in as a string our field that we
want to verify that it's equal to so it
is
password one and it is quite important
to
write this down because that is what is
going to verify
that the password and the confirm
password are
match now if you remember the password
too is the confirm password and you can
memorize this because we have this label
in here
so this is actually a very important
validation okay so
some more validations that we want to
provide in here
is probably to check if the ad sign is
located
in the email address and the way that we
can do that
is also as easy as importing the
email class from the validators
and we can just say validators
equals to email and this is easily going
to check if the
given value in the email address is
actually
an email address and one more thing that
we can do with the validators
we can basically give one more
validation to each field
and it will be as easy as converting the
validator's
value to a list in each of our fields
so let's go ahead and do that we will
just add square brackets
in the end and in the beginning of each
our values
so i will do that in here and i will
also
do that in here and i will do that
in the password too as well now there is
one more reason that i have done this
because we also want to verify that each
of our fields
are filled in with some information so i
can basically
import the data required class here
and i can add one more validation by
going here
and press comma and now we can type
data required and close this up like
this and we probably want to copy and
paste
the same validation for each of our
fields because we want them to be filled
up
so i will copy this out and i will paste
this in
in here and as well as in here and also
in here and i will just go back to
here and i think we are pretty much done
with all the
validations that we want to apply
okay so now that we have completed this
let's see
in our routes dot py how we are going to
handle
those validations so we will open
our routes dot p y and we will
zoom in here a little bit and down
here we want to check if some of the
validations are failing or not so for
example let's say that we had
a user that provided a username with
only a one
character well in that case it is quite
obvious that
our python conditional is not going to
go inside our form dot
validate on submit because one of the
validations
are not meeting our requirements to
create a user successfully
so to check for errors that are arriving
from the
validations it is as easy as checking
the
form dot errors so if one of our
validations are going to fail
then it is going to be stored inside
this field
and since it is a built-in dictionary
field
then we probably want to check if it is
empty
or not before we actually put in some
more python code
so i will say if form
dot errors is not equal to
empty dictionary and what i say by
writing this conditional
is just as easy as saying if there are
no arrows that
are arrived from the validations so i
will comment this out
if there are not arrows
from the validations like that okay so
it is quite important to write in this
conditional
and once i have done that then we can
basically
iterate over the arrows that are
arriving
from the validations so since there
could be more than one
validation error then we have to iterate
over
the form.arrow so it will be for
err message so just a shortened way to
say
error message in form
dot arrows and as i said that this is a
dictionary then we can basically
access the values of that so i will say
dot values
and i will close this up and we will
enter this conditional
and temporarily we will basically print
the message in the server side
so i will just print the message and
then we should see the error message
in the python shell where we see certain
logs
about our web server that is running so
i will basically print the error
msg up and it is a better idea to
actually write a formatted message
so it will be something like there was
an error
with creating a user and then
we will call the variable that we are
iterating on
okay so i think that we are all set up
to test
if that works properly so now i will
open
our website on the left pane and i will
locate our terminal in the right pane
okay so we can be aware if there are
going to be any arrows
when we create a user so now i will try
to register
and i will verify that our website is
running so i will execute python
run dot py and now we can see that we
receive
an unexpected exception here so it says
that let's actually
see it like that it says that we must
install the email underscore
validator for email validation
support so i will say down here pip
install email underscore validator so
just make sure to run that
and i believe this should solve the
problem so once we go ahead
and install this up and now we can run
our web server again
and now i see that everything works
properly now we can refresh this
and we are right in the register page so
now
i want to create a user with only a one
character so it will be just j and i
will put
a valid email address so
just something like that and i will not
mismatch the password
by purpose so i will create an account
and then you can see that it did not
redirect us to the items page
unlike the previous result and in our
web browser we can see that we received
there was an error creating a user
and we can also see that we have here
field must be between 2 and 30
characters
along so what that means it means that
our
validations are working properly
now if we want to test multiple
validations that are going to
fail then we can basically try to
mismatch the email in here by writing
some numbers
and we can unmatch the password and
confirm password
and we can try to click on create
account and now we can see
multiple arrows so we have the there was
another creating a user
with this message and we also have it
for the message here as well
and i think we saw this twice because i
was looking up here
so sorry and there should be three
arrows so
the third is that field must be equal to
password one
and we also see that invalid email
address
and i think that this explains that our
validations are working
perfect because we saw the results
as expected now i know that this is not
a
great idea to display those kind of
messages
on the server side and in the near
future
we are going to turn those messages and
we are going to
flash them up right in our website
so it is going to be very cool to do
that because this way
our users could also be aware of the
different
arrows that are arriving from the
validations
all right so if you remember this was
the line that was responsible to display
some errors within the terminal of
our web server now to change this to
being
displayed on our html templates flask
gives us a built-in function that is
called
flash and this is basically a function
that will allow us to display
all the given information inside our
html templates
so it will be as easy as changing this
print to flash and for sure this is a
built-in function
that we should import in our first lines
over here so we should type in here
flash so we are importing that built-in
function
and the way that we are going to do that
is
by first flashing some messages and then
we are going to go inside our html
templates
and we are going to use a built-in
function
that is called get flashed messages and
what is so beautiful with the get
flashed messages it will allow us to
gather all the
flashed messages as the function says
okay but we are going to do that
on our template with ginger syntax so it
is not quite
necessary to import it over here i just
wanted to show you
the function that we will be using so
once i have done that
then i can basically go to our
template and use that built-in get
flashed messages
so it will be as easy as going to our
templates
and going inside our base dot html
and we actually want to think of an area
where it could be
nice to display those kind of flashed
messages
now the reason we don't do this in our
register.html
it is because we want to gain the
ability to
display flashed messages for all of our
templates so it doesn't make sense to
call the get flashed messages in a
specific template besides it totally
makes sense to call it
from our base.html so we will go
right under our navigation bar and
we will display the flashed messages
right
before our block content so i will just
go here and i will use the jinja syntax
to grab the flashed messages now the way
that we are going to do that is by
context
manager so it will be with messages
equals to get flashed
excuse me like that messages and then we
will close
this function and we will pass in an
argument
that is going to look quite weird for
you in the first look but we will
explain in a second
and i'm going to pass in here with
categories
equals to true now the reason that we
are going to do this
it is because in the future we are going
to add certain categories for the
different
messages that we want to display so the
important point here
is to understand that not only we can
display some arrows but we can also
display regular information or
success messages and we are going to see
how we are going to do that
in a few minutes now i just realized
that
i implemented the variable block and
with the
get flashed messages it expects for the
block code so i will change the inner
curly brackets
to parentheses and i mean percentage
signs
and this should be great now we should
close this with and
wait like that now inside this
block of code we also want to check if
there are going to be any messages
when each page loads so we can do that
by easily saying so i will call the
block code again
and i will say if messages
and i will close this up
by saying end
if and i will fix the indentation in
here so what we got until now
is a messages variable that is trying to
grab all the flashed messages and then
later on
we are also verifying that the
messages is not known so it is quite
important to do that because we probably
want to check if our messages
are filled with some flashed message
from our route now when we reach this
situation
it quite makes sense to iterate over the
messages if
it is not none because if you remember
in
some cases we could have more than one
messages that we want to display to our
users
so this is why right inside our if
statement in here
we are going to say and we will call the
block code again and we will type in for
message
in messages and then we will
close this up by saying
and for and now this is the actual area
where we want to display some nice
html output to display the different
messages
to our users so i will start by
displaying this message in a very simple
p tag
so it will be just easily p and then we
will say
message inside a variable block so it
will be
message in here and then later on we are
going to give this a little bit nicer
customization
but we will do that in a few minutes now
we can go
to our website and check if this works
properly
so if you remember in our route.py
we actually flashing a message to our
clients
so this should be fine by only verifying
that our website is up and running and
actually
try to go back to home and try to
register again to our
website so i will type in some wrong
information
in here and let's see if everything
works properly so we will try to create
account
and then you can see that we receive
those arrows
with the actual errors that we had when
we try to create account
now if we zoom in here a little bit
we could see that we received the output
as python tuples so what that means
it means that our get flashed messages
divides in the output into
two important things and the first one
is the category
and the second one is the actual message
so what that means it means that we can
change our iteration a little bit to
make it look
even nicer so we could go back to our
pycharm
and actually let's go to our base.html
again
and we could add in here one more
variable
so we could unpack the results of
what is inside the messages so i will
say category
and then we will add a comma and then we
will only display
the message itself and once i do this
then we can basically try to refresh it
and click actually continue and then we
can see that
the result is quite different okay so
this could be one way that you could
display different messages to
your users but we probably want to
give the user a little bit nice
display to those kind of messages so the
user could be aware if this is an
error message or just an information
message
or a success message or something like
that and we probably want to design it
a little bit more colored rather than
just displaying
a blank white text so the way that we
are going to
do that is by going back to our pycharm
and adding in here some categories to
our flash
message so if you remember the
get flashed messages from the base.html
are also responsible to grab the
categories because we
passed in this statement with categories
equals to true
so what that means it means that this
grabs the categories as well so let's
give our messages a category okay so we
could go back here
and we could say category
equals to danger and there's actually a
great reason why i typed in here
danger and you will see that just in a
second
okay so once i have done that then i
should re-customize
this line in here to display a nicer
message
so the way that we are going to do that
is by writing
in some pure html code to display a nice
message
and also doing that with pulling some
classes from the
bootstrap framework that we have
imported in the very beginning of this
tutorial
so i will start by saying div
and i will continue by typing the class
and i will say alert and then i will
also say
alert dash and then here i will
pass in the category that we
send from our route now here is the
reason why i
wrote danger it is because alert
dash danger is going to pull
the bootstrap class that its name is
alert
dash danger and that is responsible to
display a red looking message so
our users could understand that this is
basically an
error and something went wrong and
inside
those div tags i'm going to continue
on by typing here button so this is
going to be
like a wide paragraph where the users
could have the option to close the
different alerts so i will continue
giving here
some more html attributes very quick so
i will say by type
equals button and i will also say class
equals to m1-2
and i will also say mb-1
and then i will type in here close so
those are
some bootstrap classes that i memorize
that will be responsible to just display
it nicer
so i don't want to waste a lot of time
explaining what each class does
and i will also say here data dash
dismiss
equals to alert and then i will also
say area label equals to
close so i'm going to explain some of
the attributes when we see the actual
results and this will totally make sense
for
you so i will go back to here and i will
continue
typing inside sorry about that and i
will continue typing inside
our button the message that we want to
display
so i will call here the span tag
and i will type in here area hidden
equals to true and inside
our span i am going to type in some
convention characters that the
html could understand that i'm referring
to an
x icon so i want to show like an
x close button like we have here in our
pycharm
this is the exact symbol that i want to
refer to
so i can just say times and then
colon semicolon like that so once i have
done that
let's see the results and let's see the
logic behind this html code okay so
let's
go here and let's actually put the
pycharm in the
left pane and our website
in here so it would totally make sense
to see those together so i will
make the phones a little bit smaller
and i will continue on from here so now
i can
zoom out our website and i can
go to our homepage and try to register
back again
and i will again dismiss some
information
by purpose so i will say jc4
and i will type in some passwords and
once i click
on create account then we don't see the
message
and that is because i did not insert
the message itself anywhere but you can
already see the x symbol that i was
talking about
and if i click on then on that then it
closes
so i will just go inside our
button here and i will just call the
message
by only calling the variable block and
pass in
message and actually i think this should
be out of our button here so i will
move this right under the closure of the
button tag okay so once i have done that
let's test the results again so i will
go and try to
register and i will type in a valid
email
but only i will not create proper
password so i will just type in here
some random characters and click on
create account
and then you can see that we see a nice
looking
error and our clients could really
understand
that we have something wrong and we also
have the
option to close this button by clicking
on the x
right there now the attribute of data
dismiss and area label and area hidden
equals true
are what responsible to configure what
the x symbol should do when we
click on it but i don't want to get into
much complex detail about html and
javascript and
some more further information that is
quite not relevant for now
all right everyone so i hope you
understood the entire topic of how we
can
display nicer flashed messages to our
clients
now there is going to be one more thing
that we want to
solve about this registration form
now i will try to create a user
with a username that is already existing
on our database so if you remember in
the
previous actions that i have completed
in this tutorial
i created already a user with name of
jsc now if we try to create a user with
an existing username
let's see the result okay so let's go
ahead and try to pass
in some valid email and actually a valid
password as well
and if i click here then you can see
that it leads us to an
error where it says that the
unique constraint failed now
i know it jumped down here and this is
actually referring to actual error but
this is the error that i want to talk
about so
unique constraint field means that
we tried to insert a user
row to that item table that we have and
then
it failed because we already have a
username with the name of
jsc so we probably
want to avoid display such a message to
our users
one this doesn't look nice and two we
probably don't want to show
our bugs and our code problems to
the users so the way that we can
overcome this
is by easily catching this error
a lot earlier before it leads
to that sq alchemy integrity error so
let's see how we can
do that in python okay so i will
basically open back our pycharm here
and you can see that i'm already inside
our forms dot py and there is a great
reason for that
now in here we want to write validation
that is going to check if the attempted
user from the registration form is
existing or not
and then we can catch up this unique
error before
it leads to the error from the sql
alchemy
itself so that way we will have a
validation error
and then we will be able to display to
our users
this nice red colored error message that
we
saw previously let's go ahead and do
this and i will go inside
the flask form class here i mean the
register from glass
and i will type in some function which
i'm going to
name validate username and i'm going to
receive the cell
for sure and i also want to receive one
more parameter
and we will name it username underscore
tool underscore check okay so we are
checking if the given username is
already existing in our database
and once we have done that then we want
to query
our user model to check if this username
to check
is already existing or not so i will go
up top here and i will import our module
and it will be from market dot modules
import user and i will go down here with
two lines so we will have a cleaner look
and i will continue inside our validate
username
function and i will say user
equals to user dot query
dot filter underscore by and we want to
filter the user object by
username equals to username
to check and what i'm doing by writing
this line i'm basically asking our
entire
user object if there is a user
with the username to check that is
arriving from the registration form
and once i do that then you can remember
from the previous sessions of this
tutorial that this entire
expression returns us an object and in
order to
access the first object of it then we
should go and type in
first like that okay so if this user
object
is filled in with some information
meaning that this entire statement
returns an object then this means that
there is already a user with that
username existing in the database
so we probably want to go ahead and type
in a conditional like if
user so i'm checking if the user is not
none and in here i want to raise a
validation arrow so it will be race
validation error and i will just type in
a message
like username already exists
please try a different
username and you could pay attention
that this
gives us an error in here because we
should import
this built-in exception class from
that line so i will say valley
validation error
right there okay so there is one more
thing that i bet that confuses you
in that case so we were able to write
a nice block of code in here that
is basically verifying that the
user is not exist and then we raise an
error if there is actually a user
with the username that he tries to
create now you're probably asking
yourself
how this validate underscore username is
going to be
executed in somewhere in our project
now in that case what is so
special with the validators library
is that you are allowed to create
certain functions in very specific
usernames and then the flask form
class is going to take care of the rest
so
by writing validate underscore
username like that then what flask form
is going to do it is going to search for
all the functions that are starting
with the prefix of validate
underscore and then later on it is
going to check for the next name
after the underscore and then it is
going to search
if there is even a field with that
given name and we happen to have this
username
field so this way our flask form
class that we inherit from will know to
validate underscore username because we
have a
field with the username right here so it
is quite important to understand
why i named this function that way
okay so the flask form called understand
that
we are going to execute a validation for
the username itself and we could also
do that with our validate email address
so we probably want to check
if there is an email address that is
already existing
if our users are trying to create an
account with an existing email address
so we could do the exact same thing by
going
down here and typing in validate
underscore and here we want to
give the email address as our function
name so i will go by again saying
email address to check
and then we will go inside our function
and we will continue on by saying
email address equals to
user dot query dot filter underscore
by and we will try to filter by
email address equals to email address to
check
and we have to execute that dot first in
here
again and then we can say if email
address then we can raise a validation
error and then we could type in
email address
already exists
please try a different
email address okay so there's a great
reason that i'm not copying and pasting
because as long as i'm doing that
then you are practicing how you can
write such a complex code
when it comes to sometimes rays arrows
and
conditionals and then functions with a
very unique name
so this is why i did not copy and paste
um
and i think this should be enough to see
the actual results
so i will basically go to our
web you know what let's verify that our
website is running
and it is not so let's execute python1
dot py
and then you can see that our website is
up back again
and now i can try to refresh our page
and let's actually go to
home and now we can try to
go back to register and try to create
some account and see the results of that
and in here
let's try to create again an account
with an existing
username but not with an existing email
address so i will give here an email
address like that
and i will type in correct passwords and
if we
click on create account then we see an
error again so
probably something that we missed with
writing the validations
so i think we see this
unsupported type when we creating
the validation so
and let's actually have a look if our
validation is proper or not
um so it is a great idea to go here
and user equals to
user query filter by and then we pass in
this
this username to check but i think that
this should be a little bit different so
i might see what is going on here
now if you remember from our route
dot py we used to access our actual
fields with accessing the data
attribute so i think this is what we
have to pass in here
to query our users so
this is just the same approach so in
here we create the users with grabbing
the
dot data and we should do that in our
forms dot py
as well so i will go
here and i will say that data
in here and i will do the same
in our user query filter in the validate
username so i will
type in dot data and i think this should
be enough to
test it out back again because we
probably don't want to refer to
actual object of the username to check
we want to refer to that
dot data so let's go
back to here and test the results of
that
so i will try to register back again
and i will type in again a username that
is already exist
and we will change the email a little
bit
and the password like that and now if we
click on create account
then you can see that we receive an
alert
besides receiving a complex error
so our users could be notified
with that kind of unique arrow as well
and you can see the message there was an
error with creating a username
username already exist please try a
different username and that is happened
to be the
error that we have raised by ourselves
now if we want to test this with the
email address as well then we can go
ahead and do that
so if i remember correctly then we
had an email with jsc at
jsc.com so this should fail
and if i click on the same password
and try to create a new account then you
can see that our validation error about
email address is also very very fine
and i think that this is beyond then
enough to
really have a very stable registration
form
for our clients
okay so i'd like to start with changing
the way that we maintain our passwords
in the database
now if you remember i said previously in
that course that we are not going to
store passwords as plain text now
actually what happens now
if we actually inspect to our database
with the sqlite3 gui tool that i talked
about previously in that course
then we can see that we have two users
but we see their passwords as plain text
now this is something that is not
considered as a
secure thing to do so we are going to
change this and we are going to
store a hashed password and that is
going to allow us to store
crypted passwords so let's go ahead and
do that and the
first step for that will be to install a
library with pip install command
so i will pause our website for a minute
and i will say pip install
flask underscore be crypt
okay so as i install that then i can
clean my screen again
and i can go to pycharm and import
this library now again what this is
going to do it is going to allow us to
store the password as hashed password
and
not as plain text as we saw so i'm
already located inside my thunder init
file
and in here we need to initialize this
decrypt
library i mean an instance of a bcrypt
class
inside that library so it will be from
flask underscore be crypt import
be crypt like that and i just realized
that we forgot to
delete this vendor template from here so
let's go ahead and do that
and down here i'm going to create an
instance of that and we are going to
rely on that
to use it in our entire application so i
will say
be crypt equals to be crypt and i will
pass our
app as an argument inside the bcrypt
class okay so once we have done that
then we can basically
rely on the bcrypt to start
generating hash passwords rather than
storing them as plain text
so the way that we can do this is by
going
to our user model and start creating
some additional properties now if what i
say right now does not make sense to you
then it is quite fine but in object
oriented programming
there are something that is called
getters and
setters so what this means it means that
we can
basically configure the way that we
want to receive back in attribute
and the way that we want to set the
attribute
so this is going to help us because we
need to
create one more property and we can name
it password and then once we set that
password then we can
execute additional code to turn this
password
to enhash password so let's see that in
action and i think when i
write the code of that it will totally
make sense for you so i will open
my modules.py and in here
we will start creating some additional
properties
now the properties are going to be set
unique per instance so it is important
to understand that
and i'm going to go down here and i'm
going to use the
decorator of property so again this is
just going to be like an additional
attribute that is going to be accessible
from
each instance and once i have done that
then i will basically name it password
and not password hash like i did here
and i will say
return self.password so those lines of
code are not doing anything special
right now
because what this says it says that okay
i have a new property
and i basically return it back when the
user wants it or myself as a developer
who wants to
see some attributes and the tricky line
is actually starting from here so i will
now say
password dot setter so basically we can
allow ourselves to execute some lines of
code
before we actually set a password to
an user instance so it will be
dev password in here again and this time
i will receive
additional parameter and this parameter
is going to be
the password that is going to be filled
in
when we want to set that up so the
parameter
name is going to be plain text password
like that and i will go
down our password.setter and i will
basically
override what is going to be stored as
password hash now this time i'm not
going to
make that to be equal to plain text
password
besides we are going to use the
functionality of the decrypt variable
that we have created so i will go
to here and i will say from market
import b crypt now if you remember this
is accessible from the dunder init file
because we
initialized it over there and now i will
go back to our models dot py
and i will use some of the
functionalities of this b
crypt instance so i will
remove this for a minute and i will say
b
crypt dot generate
password hash
and this generate password hash is
probably going to receive
a plain text password as an argument so
it will be
as easy as giving this plain text
password
as an argument to this function or to
this method excuse me
so now as we have done that then i like
to apply some decoding in here so
it will be just dot decode and we will
use the utf-8
to decode this generated password hash
okay so once we have set this then we
should go to our routes.py
and take some additional changes in
there because if you remember
in our entire project the only code
that is responsible to create instances
of that
user is actually the route dot py
so i will go to here and right under
our register page if you remember we
set our password underscore hash to
a plain text password now the only thing
that i
have to do here is basically
besides giving the password hash
argument
is giving the password argument so
this will be responsible to complete the
entire process
of storing passwords as hashed passwords
because
we set our password and this line of
code
goes inside the password dot setter
because we set a new password to a new
user
and then this line of code is getting
executed and this is
exactly what we need because we storing
enhanced password so this is the process
and we want to test this up actually
in the next user that we are going to
register so
i will go to our terminal and i will
say clean the screen again and
we will execute python run dot py
and once we have this then we can verify
this
by refreshing our page and going to
register
and now i will create jsc
2 3 because we had jst2
and we will set a valid email and now i
want to prove you that we are using
one two six again so i will just cut
this out from here
and paste this in twice and once we
create an account
then the results are quite great but now
to actually verify this i'd like to show
you the results from the
gui that we use so we can
go to here and we can
basically refresh that out by pressing
f5
and now you can see that we have a
hashed password
for the jsc 3 users so this is exactly
what we wanted to achieve
by using the getter and the setter to
differentiate between what happens
when we do each one of them all right so
now that we have secured our passwords
it is about time to start working on the
way that we can
log in our users now currently we will
start by
designing what is required to basically
display a login page
successfully to our users so it will
mostly require the steps that we
probably have done until now
so we will create a login form within
our forms.py
and for sure we will set up a new route
and we will create a separator template
for that
so let's go ahead and start working on
this okay so i will go
to our route dot py as you see i'm
already here
and we can basically start working on
the same process like we have done
to design our register page so i will
zoom in here to make the font bigger so
we will start by saying at app
dot route and we want to send our users
to
forward slash login and we want
to allow the methods of get and post
like we have done in the register page
so
it will be get and then post
like we did previously and then we can
basically
name it login page and we can
go inside our function now i want this
to be more centralized
so excuse me for pressing enter a lot of
time
and now in here we will just start by
returning a render template
and we will send our users to login.html
like that okay so let's go ahead and
create this template as we did not
create it yet
so it will be just as easy as going here
and create
the html file and we will name it login
we will delete the auto-generated html
now i will rely on the register.html to
kind of help us a little bit
so i will open the register.html
and i will copy everything from here and
i will paste this
in in the login.html and
now i want to delete everything that is
under our body text
so i will just minimize the div class
container
and i will just delete everything that
is
right here and there we go we only left
with the
body so i will also change that to login
page
it makes a lot of sense and i will test
our results out
so we will go to our website
and we will go to slash login
and you can see that we are inside a
blank new page so everything works well
now if you remember in the navigation
bar as you see the register works
because i clicked on it but the login
page is not working
so let's go ahead and fix that quickly
so i will go to our pycharm
and it should be inside our base.html
and we should go down and we should
identify this line in the
login style so this is right here and we
can basically
copy the url underscore 4. so you should
already be familiar with this function
and we should paste this in right
here in the href of the login and we
should
change this to login underscore page
because this is the name of our route
so now that we have done this we can
test the changes from clicking here and
let's refresh the page to
changes to take effect so i will go to
home i will click
login and you can see that everything
works fine okay so once we have done
that
then let's start working on our forms so
it makes sense to go to our forms dot py
and basically create one
new form like we did for the
registration
so it will be as easy as going to our
forums dot py
and start working on a new class
but this time we are not going to create
all the fields like in here
basically to log in our users we only
require to have username and the
password
and for sure the submit field to take
some actions
so i will go down here and i will start
creating a new class so it will be
class login form and this will inherit
from the
flask form as well and we will go inside
our
login form and we will start saying
username
equals to string field and
the label that we're going to give here
is going to be
just user name like that and
the only validation that i like to
create here
is the data required so i will say
validators
equals to a new list and inside that i
will
initialize the data required and i will
close the instance of
this class by adding parentheses now the
same
approach will go for the password as
well
so i will allow myself to copy
everything from the username
and paste this in and change this to
password and change this string field
to password fill and change the label to
password and delete the name and this is
fine to
leave it in here and the last action
will be
to submit so now i will also allow
myself
to copy that from the registration form
and paste this in
and the label for that will be something
like
sign in and this should be fine for
creating our login form okay so once we
have done that
let's go ahead to our routes.py
and create an instance of this login
form
so i will start first by importing it
right here in the market.forms line so i
will say
login form and i will go here
and right before our render template i
will say
form equals to login
form and i will close the parentheses
and
now i can basically use here
form equals to form exactly
like we do in the registration
page as well so once we have sent the
information of the form
then it is a great idea to go to our
login.html
and customize this html page now
again since we pretty much implemented
this html
logic in our registration form and
actually to save us a little bit of time
then i already have created this form
html tag
so you can find this code snippet in my
website by
easily going to part 11 of the flask
series
and search for a code snippet that is
going to be named
login form and also make sure that you
paste this in
under the body class text center like we
have in here
and i'm going to paste the form tag and
let's actually go over what is going on
here
so the first here is the div with class
of
container and if you remember this is
responsible to
centralize our information from being
this wide to something like that okay so
this is
containing the information inside of it
and here we have our form tag
with the class of form dash sign in
and right under it we have the hidden
tag which
is necessary for generating the csrf
token so you should be familiar with
this because we covered this in the
registration part
and in here we have a header with please
login and
an image with the logo of our website
and in here we basically use the ginger
syntax
to grab the fields of username and the
password
and once we have done that then we have
a breaker line that is separating
our field from the next html information
now right above the submit
in here we have something new that we
did not see before
so this is the div and inside here we
have a text
do not have an account so i decided to
create this
just because to allow our users to go
back easily to the register page
if they don't have an account so you can
identify this by
seeing the href with the anchor tag
and you can see that it leads our users
to the url of register page so
let's actually see this in action so i
will go to our
website and i will log in
and now you can see that we have the
username field
and we have the password field and we
also have the do not have an account
and we have a button that says register
now if i click on it then you can see
that it leads us
back to the register page now
functionality like this could be also
a lot nicer if we have implemented it in
the register page
so i'm going to do that just in a second
so we will go to our python
and we will easily grab this code
snippet from here
and we will paste this in inside
our register.html so i just opened our
register.html temporarily
and i'm going to go
as we did in the login page and i'm
going to paste this in
right above the forum dot submit
and that time i will say
already have an account like that
and i will lead our users to
login page and it makes totally sense to
change the text in here as well
so once we have done that then we will
see
the same result in the register page as
well so if we click in here
then you can see that it leads us back
to login page
okay so just to memorize what we have
done until now well
probably we want to complete the
functionality of that sign in button
because we
don't do anything special when we click
on the sign in and we want to throw
some errors if there are some wrong
information and we want to proceed our
users to the market page when the
login is successful so it is going to be
a lot of stuff
that we have to configure on our back
side of the application
so first of first we will start by
installing
the library that will allow us to manage
our login system easily with flask
so it will be basically going to
our web application and saying here
pip install flask underscore login
and once i have done that then you can
see that everything is fine and i can
clean my screen
and now we can continue to pycharm and
start working on importing this library
so the library itself is like a
login manager for your entire
application
so it has to recognize which flask
application you
want to manage the login system with so
this is why we are going to start
importing it
from the dunder init file so we will say
from flask underscore login
import login manager like that
great and once we have done that then we
can say
right here login underscore
manager equals to login manager so we
will start an instance of that
and we will pass the application as the
argument
so nothing is different than the sql
alchemy or the pcrypt that we have
done previously throughout this tutorial
all right so
once we have done this we are ready to
work on
our login route to really
write the functionality of what happens
when your clients are going to click on
sign in so we will go to our routes dot
py
and we will navigate to our login
underscore page
and we are going to pretty much apply
the same
logic like we did in our register page
so if you remember
we used to call this conditional
if formed validate on submit and then
if this conditional hits true then we
are going to take several actions
so it might be a great idea to start
with that okay so i will say
in our login page so we will zoom in
here
and we will say if forum
dot validate on submit
now if you don't remember this actually
runs two
functions behind the scenes and the
first is to validate that all the
information is valid
and it also going to hit this
conditional
when we click on that submit button that
we have created for our
login form so i will go inside our form
and now we are ready to pretty much
verify if our users
have provided a great information
so this means that when we put in some
information like username and password
there are going to be two
important steps that we want to verify
and the first will be if the user is
exist
and the second one if the user is exists
then if the password
is actually the correct password of that
user so the implementation of that in
python
will be like the following so we can say
attempted
underscore user equals to
user dot query dot
get and we want to receive only
one user object and in here i'm going to
provide the
data that is filled in the form so we
will say
form dot username dot
data so again this entire statement is
going to
filter out the user by
the provided username but if you
remember in that case we should execute
that dot first method
to really grab the object of the user
now if attempted user is
none then we can say that the client is
providing some wrong information about
its username
so we can write a conditional and say if
attempted user and that will be enough
to test out
if this is filled with some information
and
not none now sorry for deleting that
this is not enough to really
log in our users because now we should
check if the password
matches the user that tries to sign in
but if you remember we store
our passwords as hash passwords so we
kind of
ask ourselves how we are going to check
if the
user from the form matches the user from
the database
so it is never going to be match because
the password we store
is a hash password and the password that
the client fills in
is a regular string of password so to
overcome this we can basically use some
functionality that we have inside the
bcrip library
that is going to help us to verify
that the passwords are match so
now i want to stop writing this
conditional in here
and go to our modules.py
and start working on some function that
could be accessible from each user
object that is going to
really help us to overcome the problem
that i specified
so i will go down here and i will zoom
in
a little bit so we can see better and i
will start writing a function and we can
say
check password correction
and this is going to receive the self as
a parameter
and also it is going to receive the
attempted password
to really grab the password that is
filled in
within the form so in here we can say
if b crypt dot check
password hash and now this function is
going to accept two arguments
it is going to first accept the password
that is hashed
and then the password that is going to
be filled in from the form so we can put
in here
self.password hash
and as the second argument we can say
attempted
password now this entire statement here
is going to return true or false so
if we actually hit this conditional we
can
return true and to actually make this a
little bit more efficient
we can do something like the following
now since
this entire statement here is going to
return us
true or false then we can basically
avoid using the if statement in here and
we can
basically return whatever this statement
is going to return
so if i change this to return then
basically what i'm saying
is execute this function and
return its value back when we call the
check password collection so this is
going to return
us either true or false so once we have
done that
then basically we can go to our
routes dot py now you can remember
how the attempted user is going to be
stored within a user object if this
entire statement
is going to return a user object or not
so i can continue my conditional by
saying and
attempted user dot check
password correction so basically i am
calling the
function that we excuse me the method
that we
wrote inside our user module and now i
can close this in
and if you remember this function
received the attempted password as a
parameter
so we can say attempted
password and i will continue on from
here
and we will say form dot
password dot data and
this should be enough to really write
this
long conditional now i'm going to write
in
this in splitted lines because it
doesn't look a lot friendly so i can
basically
go with something like this
and no not like that but we can
divide that and
that okay so now things look a lot
better
so this entire thing is actually a one
long if statement but this is required
because of the explanation that i made
in the previous minutes okay so once we
hit this conditional
then we can really start logging our
users now we are going to use a built-in
function
that is already existing inside the
library that we installed previously
so let's go ahead and import this in our
routes dot py
so we can say from flask underscore
login import login underscore
user and this should be enough for now
we are going to import more stuff from
this flask login in the future
and i will scroll down back to our login
page route and now
we can call this function like that
and we can provide as the argument the
user object that we want to
log in so it will be attempted user
and this should be enough to really log
in our users now we probably
want to provide some extra information
to our clients
when they have logged in successfully so
we could
say flash so if you remember not flask
but
flash if you remember the flash is the
built-in function that is going to help
us to
provide extra messages for our users
when some important thing happens
and we can type in a message like
success
and we can say you are logged in
as and now we can really give the
username that
is logged in so we can turn this into a
formatted swing
and we can say attempted
user dot username now
again if we are going to hit this
conditional then it means that the
attempted user is not
none so this is why i can access this
attribute so it is fine
doing this and once we have done that
then we want to probably direct our
users to the
market page to start buying
some products so it will be basically
return redirect and we can call it
and we can call the url underscore for
built-in function
and if you remember this function is
going to receive as the argument
the name of the route that you want to
redirect your users
so if you remember we have a route that
we called
market page so i will copy its name and
paste it in over here and
once we have done this then basically it
is a great idea to really finish
up what happens if we don't hit
this long conditional in here so we
want to write the else statement for
that so i will say
else and in that case i want to raise a
message
like this so we can
say username and password
are not match please try
again something like that and i just
remembered
that i did not put in some categories to
our flash messages so obviously we want
to provide
here category equals to
success like that and
this is for the conditional that we hit
so if we were able to log in and
this one should be category
equals to danger so danger is what going
to help us to
display a red colored message because it
is going to be translated
in our base template if you remember to
a
danger message so this is why we have to
provide this danger
as it is okay so this should be enough
to test for the first time
if we can log in our users so we can
go now to our web browser and we can
refresh our login page but we did not
verify
if our website is running so
we should go and execute python run.py
and once we have done that then we can
go to here and see some exception that i
really wanted to see
and so we can solve this together now
this is actually a perfect example for
an exception
where you really want to carefully read
what exception
is about and provide some extra steps to
really
complete this login system successfully
so
you can see that it saves us exception
missing
user underscore loader or request
underscore loader
so we should refer to this documentation
and see how it works so we will copy
this and we will paste this in
here and we can really start looking
of what this documentation is about so
we can see that there is some message
that says how the
flask login works and you can also see
that we will need
to provide a user loader callback
to really make our flask application
to understand that if we navigate from
different pages
when we are authenticated then each
refresh there is a different request
session
that the flask application has to
understand
if the user is logged in or not so
this is why we have this decorated
function in here
that needs to be executed every time we
load some different page so we should
copy this and paste this in inside
our modules dot py and this is why i
will grab this entire code from here
and paste this in inside our
modules dot py right here
so once we have done that then it is
also a great idea to import this login
manager that
i talked about so now you really can
understand
why we created this login manager
instance in the beginning of this video
so i have done this for this exact step
that we should provide later on so
i will go here and i will say login
manager
like that okay so before we continue i'd
like to add a personal correction to
that line
because i remember myself when i
developed the project that we are
working on
this tutorial then this wasn't the
return statement so i'd like to change
this a little bit to
something like query dot
get and in here we will convert
the received user id to an integer
before we really try to get this user so
i will say user id
right between the built-in in function
and
this should be enough now if i quickly
go back to our
documentation then we can also see some
more instructions about how to
make this login system to work
now you can see that we have to provide
some extra
methods to our user module
so you can see that we have to hard code
this method
that method and as well as those two in
here
so this really should mean that we have
to go ahead and write those methods in
our user model
because this is what flask requires us
to
do but to really overcome this i already
know
a class that is already going to provide
those methods
to be accessible within our user model
so what that means it means that we need
to inherit from some additional class
that this class will automatically
include
those methods so let's go ahead and see
how we can
do that so i will go back to our
modules.py
and i will say here so it will be
from flask underscore login
import user mix in
now this class is going to include all
the methods that we
saw in the documentation and to really
prove my point
i will allow myself to go inside this
class
by pressing the combination of control b
if you use visual code then this should
be f12
or in any id you use just make sure how
you can inspect to
your classes so if we go here then you
can see that
this user mixing class already includes
the
is active is authenticated is anonymous
and e
and get id so this should be enough to
inherit from this class
in our user model so i will say here
comma and i will write user mixing
so this really saves us a lot of time to
really go ahead and hard code some four
methods
that the flask asks us to do so it is
enough to add it as an additional
class that we want to inherit from okay
so once we have done that
then we can really go ahead and test for
another time
if we can log in our users so i will go
to our terminal and check if our website
is up and running
and it is so it is a great idea to go
back here and go to our homepage for a
minute
and now go back to our login and now we
will try to login by the
latest user that we created so it will
be jc3 if i remember correctly
and we can say the password as one to
six because this was the password
and now if i click on sign in then we
receive this non-type object has no
attribute first
so this means that we wrote something
wrong in our
query.get inside our rouse.py and
i think we should fix this
by using some another method after the
user.query
so i will go here and
we will close the mixins it is not
necessary now and we will go to our
routes.py
now i will allow myself to ignore these
warnings in here
basically this happens because we
inherited from some another
class right now and it thinks that these
arguments are now not accessible or
something like that so i will ignore
that
because this is not going to affect the
registration
and the exception was in that line
so i think we should change this to
filter on the score by
and one other wow another wrong thing
that i have done
here is i did not provide the key that i
want to
filter out from so excuse me really for
mismatching the filter on the score by
with the get function
basically i'm doing this because it is
working in another way
in django the other framework of python
so this should really be enough to
go ahead and log in our users so let's
test this out one more time okay we will
go to home
and we will click on login and we will
right here jstree
and we will try to sign in and you can
see that
now our user is logged in and we see
this success message that we can also
close when we want
okay so the final customization left to
really close this
login system topic is really giving our
navigation bar
a little bit more styling because now
our users
is logged in so we really want to avoid
to
show the users the options of login
and register and we probably want to
show stuff like
log out or some extra information that
the current
logged in user should see so let's go
ahead and
start doing this all right everyone so
right now i'm inside our base.html that
we have created for the template
inheritance
way a long time ago now i'm going to
take a lot of changes in here because
we want to differentiate between the
options that we
show to our users whether if they are
logged in or not
so to do this we can basically go down
and we can start writing some conditions
with the ginger syntax
so for example we'd like to check if the
user
is logged in or not and if the user is
logged in
then we probably want to show another
information
rather than log in and register
so let's go ahead and start implementing
this so we always want to display this
home and market options
to our users so i will leave that and i
will start writing a conditional
right here so we will start saying
so curly brackets and then presented
sign and we will start writing and if
condition
if current underscore user
now you might be confused how we can
access this variable and
what this is about so if i go to our
router.py
i said that this flask login is going to
have a lot of built-in functions that is
going to help throughout
this session of creating the login
system so this flask login
includes a function that knows to grab
the current
user whether if the user is anonymous
user
or if it is actually a logged-in user so
this is why i can
access it from our base.html so i will
say
in base.html current user dot
is underscore authenticated
like that and if you remember this is a
method that is arriving from the user
mixing
that we have inherited so now once i
have done that
then we will type in else
like this and we will also say and
if like that and now we can
move our different nav elements between
the if current user is authenticated and
also
some of them inside the else statement
right here so if the user is
authenticated
then we probably don't want to display
the login and the register
navigation elements but if the user is
not
authenticated then we want to display
them so it is a great idea to
copy this entire thing from here
actually to cut it and paste this
in between the else statement
right here so now i will fix the
navigation i mean the indentation in
here
and this is great and once we have done
that
then we probably want to display a
nice output like welcome and then comma
and then write in the user's username
and also we want to display one more
element that
will allow our users to log out now i'm
going to configure the functionality of
the logout very soon so don't worry
about that okay so i will
copy this entire thing from here and
paste this in here
and now we can work on customizing our
navigation
elements now if you remember this li tag
is actually a one navigation
so i can just delete one of them
and as a beginner we can say here log
out and i will just delete everything
from the href and add here an aztec sign
to really not send our users to anywhere
if they click here
because we don't have currently the
functionality of the log
out and the other thing that i want to
do here
is copying this again and
paste this in over here and the next
thing that i will provide here
is something like the following so it
will be welcome
and we will add a comma and then we will
use
ginger syntax to refer to the username
of the
currently authenticated user so it will
be
user i mean current
underscore user dot username
and i think we can delete this href
attribute from here
so it really doesn't need this href
attribute
and this should be enough now the reason
i left this in here
is is because we are going to add an
href in the future
and this is never going to send our
users to anywhere
so i'm fine with this approach okay so i
will go to our
website and refresh it out and you can
see that we receive here welcome
jsc3 and we have the option of logout
that doesn't send our users to anywhere
so this is great now one other thing
that i'd like to do here
is adding the budget of our users
in a nice colored way so i will
allow myself to copy one of those in
here
and paste this in right above it and
take some different actions in here
so between our anchor tags we really
want to delete this welcome message
and we want to hit enter now if you
remember from the
very beginning of this tutorial i said
that there are
a lot of styling frameworks that
does some job to really make our lives
easier
to import from some already designed
styling
now we also have one of those to
use different icons now it could be a
lot nicer if we will display an icon
of a coins or something like that for
our users
so the user can really understand that
this is his budget so we can do this by
calling the i tag
like this and we can say class
equals to f a s f a
dash coins and now we can say
between those something like current
underscore user dot budget because if
you remember this is the attribute
that returns back the budget of our
users
now i'd like to give this a little bit
more styling now i also
want to add some styling to our anchor
tag so i will go
here and i will say style equals to
something like color equals to long
green so i already know that this is a
nice way to display the
color of green and i also like to
display
this entire thing here between the
anchor tags
as a ball text so we can do that by font
dash weight and column
and we can say bold and this should be
enough to really display some nice
information to our users
about their budget so we can go now to
here and we can refresh
and you can see that we have the icon of
coins
and we also have the number right here
now i see that the aligning could be
better in here
so let's see what i have done wrong and
i think
this is the fact that i put the text
between the
eye tags so we should cut this from here
and go down a line and locate it over
here so this should be
a little bit better now and now if i
refresh our page
then you can see that the aligning is
quite great now we could also
go here and display a comma
if the budget is going to be higher than
a thousand
because this is not the standard way to
really display
a number so if we will have a user with
a six digit of a budget
then you will see a text like
this so i will show you that here you
will see
a coin like this so we should
write a function that is going to add a
comma every time that we have
larger than four digits and also it
should be located from the
fourth position starting from right so
we can do this
by going back to our project
and we can go to our modules.py and we
can
write here some more property that is
going to be
responsible to display our budget a
little bit more
pretty so we can say add property
in user and we can say here def
prettier budget like that
and we can receive the self as a
parameter and the way that we can
implement this
is first of first check if the budget
includes
four digits or more so we can say if
length of the string version of our
self.budget
is actually greater or equal to four
now the logic implementation of this
case is not going to be easy so i will
allow myself currently to
say pass here and i will also say else
in here
and if this is actually not greater or
equal to 4
then i can basically return the value
itself so
this should be return and we will add
the
f for formatted string and we can say
self
dot budget and right after it we can add
the dollar sign okay so i think i close
this by
mistake let's open it back and now i
want to show you
how we can really work on displaying
comma only in the fourth position
starting from the right so to explain
this
i will open our terminal and i will
clean the screen and enter inside python
okay so let's say that we have a number
and we will call it p
and this should be equal to 1000 and now
i want to
say that we should convert this into a
string
okay so this should return us a
thousand with a single quotes right here
and so
now if i go here and index the
character at the -3 position it will
start
counting from right till it reaches the
index of three so
this is minus one this is minus two
and this is minus three so if i grab
this then this gives us back the zero
now i always want to add a comma only
after we reach the third digit
starting from the right so this is why
i can go with something like the
following so that time
i will display the value of str
p and then we will index it by -3 and
then we
add a column to really display all the
elements
right after the -3 position so this
should be responsible to display all the
zeros and so if we could say something
like the following
so for example let's give a right now
and we can add a formatted string
and we can wrap
those with the curly brackets and now i
can add a comma
now you can see if i print a then we
kind of starting to reach the behavior
that we want to
reach so once we reached this stage then
we should look for a way to
grab all the digits and we want to
stop at the -3 position so this is also
going to be a little bit complex but now
i can say
here so we will add more one more curly
bracket
and now we will call the strp again
so pay attention where i am located in
the terminal
and now i can index this by the
following statement
so i could say give me all the digits
from the beginning until -3
like that and now if i enter and
hit a now you can see that it works
for the 1000 itself now to prove my
point
i could basically overwrite the p by
saying 1 000 like that i mean
100 000 and now we could call the
exact same statement and print a now you
can see that this works as well
so this is why i can grab this
code from here and copy that
out and paste this in
right here as a return
function like that okay so after it we
should change the self.budget
with p so this should be something like
that
and now we can add a dollar sign right
here so i know that this was a complex
topic but i really wanted to show
how i thought when i wanted to done such
a task
because you could probably pay attention
that i prepared to
show you how i developed this project
and so this was one of the greatest
challenges that i had to deal with
so i really wanted to make this
explanation okay so
now we have this dynamic property
that its name is prettier underscore
budget
so we should go back to our base.html
and
change this current user.budget to
paying three tier underscore budget and
once we have
done this then we can go to our terminal
and
run our website by saying python run dot
py
and now our website is up and running
and so now we could refresh this page
and you could see that now we got the
comma
right here but this is great because
this is going to be dynamic
so in the future when i'm going to
purchase some items
then you could see that this comma is
going to be disappeared
because of the way that we implemented
this property
okay so till that point we were able to
customize our login system successfully
but
currently if we press on that log out
nothing happens
so let's go ahead and start configuring
this so the way that we are going to do
this
is by adding an additional route to our
application
and then this route will know to log out
the logged in user and then we will
finish it with
redirecting our users back to homepage
so we will open our pycharm here
and actually i see that i'm inside my
base.html
and it might be a great idea to show you
what i'm going to configure in the
future
so if you remember then we have this
log out anchor tag and then inside here
we are going to
send our users to that url underscore
for
so actually if i'm on the base.html then
i'm going to do that
so i will zoom in and i will basically
copy this from here and
paste this in to here and i will change
this to log out now you are probably
asking yourself
why you are using this url for logout
page although you didn't create the
route
because now i'm going to create this
route okay so
we will go to our route dot py and we
will go down here don't be don't get too
much worried about that we said that
this might occur
because we inherited from some another
class and that is fine
so we will go down here and we will
say at
app.route and actually let's zoom in a
little bit
and we will send our users to slash
log out like that and then we will say
def log out underscore page
and then inside of it we have to use
a built-in function that is already
inside the
flask framework that will allow us to
log out the current existing
users so in order to do that i will
scroll up
here i will import the log out
underscore
user built in function from here and
actually once we imported this then we
can
scroll down and use the function
like log out underscore user
and that is actually it okay so this
will be enough
to grab the current logged in user and
log it out okay so this should be enough
and
the next step is probably the flash
message that we want to raise here
because once we log out our users
it totally makes sense to display a nice
alert to our users
so the user could be basically aware
that he is logged out
so we could say flash and then we could
say you have been
logged out like that and actually it is
a better idea to send its category as
info because it just looks nicer in blue
when we log out users
rather than just green color okay so
this is actually an informative message
that we want to display
and it totally makes sense to redirect
our users back to home page
once the user is logged out okay so we
will say
return re direct
and we will use the url for
and we will say home underscore page
now again the home underscore page comes
from
here okay so our users will come to here
once they are logged out now we can
actually save this out and already test
this because
if you remember we configured as well as
the
button of log out on our navigation bar
so i will go to our website and i will
refresh
our website and it totally makes sense
to check if it is up and running so we
will do that
so once our website is up and running
and then
you can see that our
user is currently logged in and you can
see it from
this message now if i click on log out
then you can see that we are back on our
home page
and then there is an informative message
that says us you have been logged out
so everything works perfect okay so i
think that
our customization about the market page
is pretty much finished because now we
have all our
navigation elements functioning
correctly but currently i'm not quite
satisfied with how our home page looks
like so it could have been a lot nicer
if we had our
logo on that home page and as well as a
button that says get started or
something like that
now i already have an html code that is
ready to display such an home page so
let's go ahead and paste this in in our
home.html
and as usual you can grab this home
snippet
from our website only thing you will
have to do is
going to part 13 of my flask course from
my website
so let's go back to our pycharm and
find the home.html template
and actually i'm going to delete
everything from here and i'm going to
paste this in now let's have a quick
look what is going on here
now here we extend the base.html we
already know how to do that
and we also have the welcome to gymshare
coding market message
wrapped around the blog title because we
want to customize our tab
name and in the blog content we have
some elements that customizing
the image that we want to display if you
remember this is our
logo of our website and this is arriving
from this
big div tag now in here we also display
some nice
h1 text and inside here we have a
paragraph that says
start purchasing products by clicking
the link below
now the link below is this line
so this line is an anchor tag with a
button of class button dash primary
you already know that from our previous
episodes as we
created this kind of button when we
register or
log in our users and you can see that it
takes our users to the
market page if they click on get started
so this is actually something that
should be pretty enough for the
for the most basic home page for any
website
so if i save this and go back to our
home.html
and refresh that out then you can see
that we have a nice
home kind of a banner that really shows
that
this is our homepage now if i click on
get started
you can already see that it leads us to
the market page
thanks to that url for market page that
is inside that angle tag now here
we actually have some problem that you
already maybe paid attention or not
now you can see how currently the
user that is using this website is not
logged in
so we probably ask ourselves if we want
to
take our users to the market page if the
user is
not logged in well i think that this is
something that we can customize
so we probably want to avoid from our
users
to see that page if they are not logged
in
so it totally makes sense if they are
trying to click on get started
and then it will lead them to the login
page first
and then if the login has been completed
successfully
then it will take them back to the
market page like it's supposed to
so we actually have a built-in function
for that as well so
let's go ahead to pycharm and see how we
can use it okay so we will go to our
pycharm
and we will go inside our routes dot py
and we will import this function that
will be responsible to not take our
users to that market page
if the user is not logged in so
it will be as easy as going to that from
flask underscore login line and say
login underscore required okay so once
we import this
then we can use it as a decorator now if
you remember from the very beginning of
this entire tutorial
i said that the decorators are
like functions that execute before the
actual function itself so there is a
reason why we
put in app.route because we want to
execute
this functionality before we create the
route itself
so the same approach goes to login
required we could actually use this
function as a decorator right before
our market underscore page route
executes
so it will be app.route slash market
and then right after it we could
basically
say login underscore required
so it will be something like okay we are
going to that market page so
this line executes and then this line
executes
so this line will be responsible to take
our users
automatically to the login page now
let's actually see if only adding this
line
is enough to complete our functionality
so i will save that file
and i will go to our website and i will
click on home
and then i will click again on our get
started and you can see that
we receive an unauthorized message here
that says us the server could not verify
that you are authorized to access the
url that is requested
now this is fine but we would like to
display the login page
automatically if we require our users to
log in before accessing this page so we
actually have to say to our application
where is that login page located
so i can redirect the user that wants to
log in
so it totally makes sense because if you
take a look in that
login required decorator we actually do
not provide any
extra information about where it should
send our users
so to configure this up we should go to
our underscore init.py file and we
should
specify to our login underscore manager
where is the login route actually
located so once we go down here
and we say login underscore
manager dot login underscore
view equals to and this actually expects
for the
name as a string of our login
route so if we take a look if you
remember this is how we named our
login route so i will copy the name of
the
function and i will paste this in
between those
double quotes so now that we have added
this
this should be enough to redirect our
users to the login page
before the market page so let's test
this out okay i will go back to
home and i will go to
get started and now you can see that it
already leads us
to the login page now you could pay
attention that it shows us the alert not
in the
nicest way but we will solve that in a
minute but i actually want you to take a
closer look to what's going on
in the url bar in here now you can see
that we see the slash login
but we see a syntax of query with a
question mark that says us that the
next url from here will be
market so you can understand this from
this html expression in here
so this means that everything is
actually working
properly now let's fix this alert in
here
so we probably want to specify to that
login manager
how we want to display a flashed message
because when we use the built-in login
required it automatically takes
responsibility to flash a message so we
want to give it a category
so it can understand to display this in
a blue color or something like that
so i will go back to our dunder init
file
and right under this line i will
say login manager
dot login message category and you can
already see that it is a
built-in field that i can fill in
so this will be equal to info because we
probably want to display this in a blue
color
so once we save this then we can test
this out again
so we can go back to home and again
click on get started
and now you can see that it really works
like we
expect okay so we see our regular
flashed messages like we used to see
when we
try to login log out or register
okay so now i can basically try to log
in with a random user that already
exists
so we will try to log in with that gst4
user and i will click on sign in
and now everything is back and works
properly so
this is a really great addition to our
website because this way our clients
could not access this
slash market page unless if they are
logged in
already now i'd also like to show you
the behavior when we try to register to
that website very quick
so let's try to create an account with
jc6
and we will specify a valid mail
like that and we will type a basic
password
and now if we click on create account
then you can see that
it created this account and it already
shows us that please login to access
this page
now you can see that it tries to lead
the
created account to the market page
as well but it requires the currently
registered user
to login now it could have been a lot
nicer if we
raised a message that the user is
created successfully
and then already log in that user so
this is something
we probably wanted to do a lot earlier
than right now
but let's actually do that okay so we
will
go to pycharm and i'm already in my
route dot py
now i want you to take a look right in
here so actually in the part that we try
to
redirect our users to the market page it
could have been a lot nicer if we
do those two things here so first we'd
like to
flash a new message and also we'd like
to
log in our users so we can already see
the market page
as a new user so
i will grab those two lines from our
login route so i will copy those
and i will go back and paste this
in right here now in the argument
let's actually delete the entire message
from here
great now as the argument of the
login user we could basically
pass in the user object
that is user to create so
we can say user underscore 2 underscore
great now if nothing goes wrong with
those two lines
then it means that the user has been
created successfully so we can
log in that user now once we do this
then we can type in a message like the
following
so it will be let's write in a formatted
string here
and we can say account
created successfully
and we can say you are now
logged in as and we can say
user to create dot username like that
okay so let's test this out with another
user that
we probably want to create now now i
forgot to specify the category so
excuse me for that and it is a great
idea to actually
go ahead and say category
equals to success exactly like that
okay so now we can go here and we can
try to register again so we will create
the jsc
7 that time and we will try to
create the we will try to fill in
valid information so we can click on
create account
and now you can see that we are already
in the slash market
and it saves us that we are logged in as
jsc 7
so it is a lot better now because the
new clients that are going to register
to that website
are going to have a lot better
experience with
this approach
okay so if we take a closer look on how
our market page is displayed to our
users
we'd actually like to change this
display a little bit
and the way that we want to do this
probably a
one way that we can do that is to divide
this page
into two main sections and then the
first part of this page
is going to be responsible to display
the available items on the market
and the other part is going to be
responsible to show the items that
i already purchased as a user from the
market so it could have been a lot nicer
if we had a division
where we display all the items in the
left pane and the purchase items in the
right pane so it is going to be more
focus page
about the entire website itself so
the way that we can do this is by
grading system of the
bootstrap styling framework so let's
have a look in the bootstrap
documentation
so i will go to here and i'm inside the
greeting
system documentation of bootstrap now
you can see that we have several
examples how we can divide
our page now i'd like to show this
section in here so this section includes
a div tag and it says that
class equals to row now the grading
system could be implemented
the second that you create a div tag
with a class
of row because it is just as it is
sounds
because it is going to create a row that
is going to be expanded
to the entire page so we could
grab the row that is created and we
could customize
the way that we'd like to divide it so
the way that
this could be divided is by creating
some call tags i mean column
inside this div class equals to row so
the second that you
see this and this this is going to be
responsible to
align our html pages in the
following way so we could already start
imagining this because in the
call dash 8 area we are going to display
the available items on our market
and on the call dash 4 area
we are going to display the purchased
items so
let's go ahead and start implementing
this and if you did not understand what
i explained then it is fine
you probably will get it as we will
start implementing this on our
real website so i will allow myself to
copy
this code statement from here and paste
this in
right under our block content
like that okay so let's fix the
indentation
a little bit and then we are good to go
so the second that i do this then let's
see the results what is going to look
like so i will allow myself to
refresh our website and then you can see
the alignment okay this is exactly what
we
want so we are going to grab our entire
table and we are going to locate it
right where the
call dash 8 starts so let's go back to
our pycharm
and actually i will allow myself to cut
this entire table from here and
paste this in under our call dash 8
div tag so we will delete this text from
here and we will click on enter
and we will basically paste our table
now i know that the indentation is quite
ugly but i'm going to fix that with a
pretty fire just in a second
so if we save that and go
and see the results of that then you can
see that
this is perfect and this is exactly what
we want
because the available items are exactly
on the left pane
now we'd also like to give some spacing
to that table
so i will create some more styling
elements to that row so our table
will have a little bit more spacing
starting from the left and also
from the top so let's go back and
do this so i will start writing
right where our div class row is
something like style
equals to margin dash
top then add a column and then
we could say 20 pixels so we'd like to
give a spacing of 20 pixels
and we could do the exact same thing for
margin dash left and we will say
20 pixels as well now
this is going to be responsible to show
the table i mean the division of the
grading system
in that way and i think this looks a lot
cleaner
right now okay so i said that we like to
fix the indentation
now you got a couple of ways to do that
you can install some plugin to pycharm
that is going to
customize the annotation automatically
for you but
you could also basically search for an
html prettifier
in the web browser so it will be as easy
as
going to google chrome and search for
something like html
freetifier and we could go and click on
the first result
and we could grab our code and we could
paste this in
and we could click on format html and
this will be responsible to
already customize the indentation for us
so you could click the
copy to clipboard section and go back to
pycharm
and paste this back in and we are good
to go okay so you got a lot of ways
of how you can do this so i like this
approach as well but you can definitely
go ahead and install
some plug-in to your pycharm or if you
use another idea like visual code there
are a lot of plugins
for those kind of stuff all right so
let's continue
implementing the logic of the buttons
that we
like to give their functionality now to
avoid actually confusions and to
remember for the future
i like to give the call dash for
name something else so we could say here
owned items something like that and we
call fix
here the div tags like this as well
so it will be easier to remember in the
future that we
like to implement here the owned items
with some ginger syntax as well
okay so if we scroll up here then you
can see that we don't got
any title that describes what the
left pane is about so it could have been
a lot nicer
if we would go right above the table tag
and we could write in some h2 tags for
example and we will close those tags
and we could say available
items on the market something like that
so it will be a lot easier for the users
to catch up
what the left pane of our page is about
now further than that we could also add
one more paragraph in here
that says click on one of the items
to start buying okay
so something like that could be a nice
secondary title as well
and we should write here
lower i so it makes a lot more sense and
i'd actually like to add some more br
tags in here to really see how it
affects the entire page
so let's see the result of that and you
can totally see that it looks a lot
cleaner on our eyes when we
look at it we can really understand what
the left pane is about
and we could really do the exact same
steps
in the right pane where we'd like to
display the owned items
so we could basically go back to pycharm
and copy those lines and
paste this in right here so we could
say in here
let's change the text to own
items like that and we could say
click on cell item to put an item
back on the market something like that
okay so the results of that would be
something like the following so i'm just
thinking the indentation
and if we go back to the market page
then we can see that now
the items page are totally fine and we
could continue on
implementing the logic behind those
buttons okay so now i'm inside the
bootstrap documentation again and i'd
like to show you some of the nicest
features that the bootstrap styling
framework
gives us so we have something in
bootstrap that is called
models now this is not the models like
we see
in the flask itself okay so models
allows us
to kind of display a nice new output to
our users
and it totally focuses us to really look
at the
new output that appears to us because it
graze the entire background of the
webpage so let's actually see a demo of
that
so we have this html code in here which
is basically
responsible to display the model that
i'm talking about
and basically this model could be
configured as a behind-the-scenes
functionality of what happens when we
click on a button
so when we click on launch demo model in
here
then you can see the result of that so
this is exactly what we like to do
when we want to display some more
information about each one of our items
and the exact same process is going to
be like displaying an ensuring form if
we are sure that we want to purchase
that item
so this is perfectly what we need for
our website
now the way that we can implement this
on our site is probably the
exact same steps like creating an html
code
that is quite similar to that and then
we could connect our buttons
with that modal now to actually save us
a little bit of time
i already customized a nice looking
model for us
so let's go ahead and see how we can do
this on our itunes html
okay so i'm back inside our market.html
file
now if you remember from the
demonstration that we saw previously
that the button and the modal element
that was
faded out are actually located in the
same code
snippet so what this means it means that
the modal and the button
itself should be located in the same
html file
but actually pasting the modal itself in
this market.html file could be very
confusing because it is going to be a
lot of lines of html code in this
market.html
and this is just not organized and could
lead to misunderstanding
what each html code is responsible for
so to avoid this we could locate
our model in a separated html template
and then this market.html could import
this model that we want to create
now the way that is going to be designed
it is by creating one more directory
that we will name it includes and within
that includes directory that we are
going to create
we are going to create some html files
that are going to be like helper files
so we could import the code snippet from
each one of them
now let's go ahead and do that okay so i
will go inside
our templates directory and we will
create
a new directory and we will name it
includes
now once we have done that then we can
create a
html file inside that includes directory
that we have created
and we'd like to name it items
underscore
models like that and let's actually
delete the auto-generated html from here
and in here i'm going to paste the model
that i talked about to really save us
some time
so if we paste this in then this is how
the modal
looks like when it comes to implementing
this in html
now i want to give a short overview
about what this html code is about
so you can see that we have this div tag
and then we have a class
that says modal fade so this is going to
be faded
and this is the identifier takes from
here
now we are going to use it in the future
so this attribute is actually quite
important for us
and we can also see that we have some h5
tag
inside our model content and
i said that the title is actually goes
here
and we also see that we have a class
with modal body
and here we are going to display the
actual information that we'd like to
display
in the body of the model okay so this is
pretty much the
important sections of what this model is
about
now the way that this could be imported
in the
market.html is by using the ginger
syntax
so if we go to here then we could
basically import it let's say that we
want to import this in here
now we could say something like the
following so i will zoom in a little bit
and we could say include and we will
open a single code here
and then we want to give the location of
that html file that we'd like to include
so it is going to be includes
four slash items underscore models
dot html like that okay so
once we have done this then it is
basically going to
use the code from here and located
inside
this market.html now to explain the next
topic that i'm going to talk about
i'd like to divide the display here so i
will go to
window and edit all tabs and select
split
vertically okay so in the
left pane we have our items modals
and in the right pane we have the
market.html
so let's zoom in here and as well as
let's go here to the button
of more info now if
i now go to our web browser
and refresh our page and click on more
info then you can see that
nothing happens and the reason that
nothing happens it is basically because
this button doesn't know which model it
should
trigger so we should specify some more
attributes to that button
so let's go to our pycharm and right in
here so i'm going to scroll a bit and
right where our
more info button is i am going to
specify
some html attributes that are quite
important for
this trigger to work so i will say data
dash
toggle equals to modal
like that and i'm going to scroll here a
little bit more and
zoom in so we can all see and
right after it i'm also going to say
data dash target equals to
now the value that we'd like to
give here is the exact same
name of the identifier of the model that
we'd like to
display so this is why i said previously
that
this identifier string is going to be
quite important for us in the future
so i will allow myself to copy this
entire string
and paste this in right inside our data
target
now we should also include the hashtag
sign
to really specify correctly the
target that is going to basically
displayed when we click on that button
okay so now we can allow ourselves to
test this out
so i will go to our page and if we
refresh that out and click on more info
then you can see that we can see our
model
and this is quite great now we can also
see if we click on the
other more info because it is
implemented for both of the buttons
now you could pay attention that the
background of this model is white
and we probably want to change it to
really make it fit to our entire website
so the way that we can do that is going
to our items dot
models which is right there and
write in some more styling that will be
responsible to
customize the background color for the
background color that we want
so we will create some style tags and
inside that
style tags i will say dot model
dash content and i will open
a curly brackets in here and inside that
i can say
background color
is going to be equal to the hexadecimal
value of our background color so it will
be two one two one
two one like that okay so we can save
this out
and refresh our page with f5
now if the regular refresh doesn't work
for you sometimes the combination of
control f5
is a stronger refresh so it also loads
the entire styling
again so i recommend you to do that if
the regular refresh is not working for
you so i will do that as well
and if i click now on more info then you
can see that it is implemented correctly
and we can also see the title unlike the
previous result
and the reason we did not see this
before it is basically because the
title color was also white so we could
not see that
and now it looks a lot better than the
previous result
all right so now i want to solve some
important problem that we have on the
website
now i will open this from here and we
want to display the button
itself right here okay so
if you paid attention in the website
itself we
saw that if we click on more info
no matter which item is then we see the
exact same information
now we probably look for a way to change
this behavior
because we want to show different
paragraphs for each of our items
so what this means it means that our
modals
should be unique per item so
the way that we can implement the logic
that i talked about
is by the following way so let's go back
to our pycharm and see that
okay so right here you can see
that we have an iteration with a for
loop that
is right inside our market.html and
this is why we see the different items
now
you can see that our button is targeting
to the model more info
so it is always going to pull
that model itself and it is not going to
be
unique per item so the way that we can
change this is changing the location
of where we import that model and
actually
import it inside our for loop and that
way we can customize it to be unique per
item so let's go ahead and do that now
i will make this market.html bigger for
a second
and i will grab the code snippet which
is
include includes items html and i will
paste this in right inside our
for loop like that okay so now i made
the items on the score models a little
bit bigger in here
and the market is still on the right
pane so now that i have completed this
step
basically what is happening here now is
that
we start our for loop and then we load
our items models html and we
do that for each item that we are
iterating on
so what that means it means that this
items underscore modal html is having
the
access for the item object
and i'm talking about this exact
variable where my
mouse is located at so what this means
it means that we can refer to
that item right inside our items
model.html file
so this is quite important because we
want to turn
our models to be unique per item
so we will start by changing the
identifier
to something like dash and then we will
call those
ginger brackets and we can say item
dash id now by doing this we basically
give a unique id for each modal
and now we could also do that for the
title of our model so we probably want
to display the title as the item's name
so we could say item
dot name like that and we could
also say inside our
modal body something like
the following so we could say item dot
description
because if you remember we have a
description field
for each of our items and now
this is great and we have completed the
customization of the itunes underscore
model
now i'm going to work on the market.html
and if you can remember our data target
is now pointing to a wrong
location because it should be the same
as the
identifier string of the model
itself so now i will copy this out
and i will paste this in like that
and now that i have done this then
basically we were able to
achieve to create models that are unique
per item
so let's test the result of that okay
i'm going to go to our browser
and i'm going to refresh that out and
now if i click on
more info then you can see that we have
the title as
iphone 10 and we have the description
that we have created for the iphone 10
now if i close this and click on more
info
in the second item then you can see that
the title is changing and as well as the
description so this is perfect because
now we have
models that are unique per item
okay so now we know that when we click
on more info that the result is great
but the purchase this item is not
configured yet
now the entire process for the purchase
this item is going to be quite same
because all we have to do now
is basically creating one new model that
is going to be
dedicated for purchasing an item and we
probably want to display the same model
pretty much
and this is going to be like a
verification model
that asks the user if
he is sure that he wants to purchase
this item
so it is also a good opportunity to
really understand the entire process
that we have
done here so this is going to be just
basically the same as
what we have done with more info so
let's go ahead and
implement this as well so i will go back
to our python
and i will make the items models bigger
a little bit and we will make the font
smaller now you could pay attention that
this is the code for the entire model so
i can basically copy the exact
same code and change the attributes that
we have
changed in the previous example as well
so i will copy the entire code
and i will paste this in right here
now you can see that this gives us an
error because it says us that we have a
duplicate
id reference now this is great because
we probably want to avoid
to having the same identifier string so
this is why it makes a lot of sense to
change this
to something like purchase
confirm like that and maybe
in the title itself we'd like to leave
it
as the item underscore name but it makes
totally sense
to go inside our model body and
give it here some different text so this
could be
something like are you sure
you want to buy and then we could say
item dot name and then we could continue
this sentence
by saying for and now we can add the
price for that item so it will be
item.price
and if you remember it displays it just
as the number itself so we could add a
dollar sign
and right after it we could include a
question mark okay so
it is important that we display this
sentence in here
and i think this is pretty much great
for now
and only we'd like to change the comment
here to
something like purchase
confirm like that okay so now we have a
new identifier that should be
implemented for the green button that we
have on our website
so now we can create the market html
bigger and we could
change the values for this button
so we should also create the same
attributes like we did in the previous
button as well
so we could create data
toggle equals to model like that
and we could say data dash target
equals to and here is again the exact
location that i want to paste the value
of the identifier so i will paste this
in and make sure that
you do the exact same thing as well so
this is great and now i can save this
and
go to our website and if we refresh that
out
then we could basically try to click on
purchase this item for iphone 10
and nothing happens so
what we have missed let's see
that the target okay
good mistake so don't forget to add the
hashtag sign as well it is quite
important so we also have done that for
the previous one so it is very important
and now if we refresh this page and
click on purchase this item then you can
see the perfect result that we probably
wanted to see so we see the title again
and we see the sentence that says are
you sure you want to buy
iphone 10 for 800 so this is perfect
okay this is actually
the logic that we wanted to implement
from the very beginning
and on the next part we are also going
to
include some more buttons inside this
model
that are probably going to be
responsible to actually buy this item
so the close button only closes the
model but we'd like to add some more
buttons into that model and then if we
click on that button
then it will make sure that the process
of purchasing
is going to be implemented for that
specific user
all right so if we remember previously
we
wrote the model for purchasing an item
now i said that this model is going to
lead for an external form
that is going to ask us if we are sure
that we want to
buy this item so to demonstrate that
this is exactly what is happening when i
click on purchase
this item now we'd like to have here one
more button
that is going to confirm that we want to
purchase it
so to achieve this we have to create a
form
and then we have to create inside that
form a submit field
which is pretty much the exact same
thing that we did in login and register
but this time the action that we are
going to take behind the scenes when we
post a request is going to be quite
different so
let's see how we can do that okay so i
will close this
and we will go to here and the location
that we have to
put the form is going to be right here
in items on the score of models
so if we scroll down a bit then maybe
under the
question mark i mean the question itself
that asks us if we want to buy this item
for
that amount of price we probably want to
create a
form so i will just start with creating
the
tags of it so it will be form and then
we will say method equals to
post like we did with the
login and with the register system now
i'm going to stop here
and i'm going to create those forms in
our forms.html
so let's go ahead and see how we can do
that so i will go to
our forms.py and we will go to
here and we will create two new classes
now if you remember we said that we want
to implement the
selling process as well so it is going
to be quite same so this is why i'm
going to
create here two forms so i will start by
saying
class purchase item form
and this is going to inherit from flask
form as well and the only thing that i
like to create here for this stage will
be submit
field okay so it will be just the exact
same line like
we did in register or with login okay so
this should be enough
now i will scroll up a bit and we will
change the label
to purchase item okay so now i can
copy this class and i could paste this
in
and we could change this to cell item
form so this is something that i already
create for the future and we could say
cell item like that okay so i think we
are done with the forms
now there might be some other fields
that we might create in the form html
itself
but actually creating the submit fields
in the backend side
is pretty much enough for me right now
so now
i have to send these forms as a context
to our templates
so if you remember if i open our
routes.py
then we can totally remember that we
send our
form instance as an information to our
template
so i'm going to do the exact same thing
with the items.html
but we will start first with sending the
information of
purchase item form okay so it is
imported
up top here and now i can go just in the
first line of our
app.route so i will zoom in a little bit
and i can say
purchase form equals to
purchase item form and create an
instance of that
like this now if you pay attention then
we already send the items as an
information in this route
so we could basically add a comma here
and send one more information
and we could say purchase form equals to
purchase form like that and then this
purchase form is going to be accessible
from the
items.html itself now once we save this
then you could remember that this is
sent to market.html sorry for saying
items.html basically i refer to
that html template so if i open the
market.html
then we have this include in here
so what this means it means that we
could access the purchase form variable
within this template as well so we could
go
here and in here we could do the actions
that i'd like to do
right now okay so we said that the
purchase underscore form is accessible
from here now if you remember from the
previous examples of login and register
in order to perform a post request
successfully
we have to create this secure hidden tag
that we always initialize so this is why
i will go and
write a code like the following and now
i'd like to
give this entire div a little bit nicer
customization
so to apply this maybe it is a greater
idea to
move this text here to an h4 tag or
h3 track something like that so i just
cut this text from here and i'm going to
locate it inside our form so i will
delete the line here
and i will go down here and i will open
a new h4 tag for example and we could
paste
the sentence back in here
now we could also say style
or class excuse me text dash center and
it will centralize the text itself
now it is also a great idea to write
here even a smaller text than that
and to centralize it as well by saying
class equals to text center and we could
continue on by
saying by clicking
purchase you will
purchase this item so
this is a great sentence to write here
because the user can totally understand
that there is no
way to go back if he clicks on purchase
this item button
okay so once we have wrote those h4 and
h6 tags
then we can basically continue on with
creating the submit field
so if you remember the way that we can
do that
is by calling the ginger syntax and we
could refer
to that purchase form
variable and we could initialize the
submit field that we have created
previously and now i can give it a class
like class equals to and we could say
here
btn btn-outline
dash success so it will give it a green
color
and we'd like to initialize the button
block as well so
the entire button will be expanded to
the entire form
okay so i think this should be enough
for now and
let's test the results of that okay so i
will verify that our website is up and
running
and it is so it is great and now i can
go back to my web browser
and close this alert and refresh our
page
now if i click on purchase this item in
here then we can see that we see
this nice title and also we see
the smaller text that says by clicking
purchase you will purchase this item
now i pay attention that it might be a
great idea to throw some brs in
here so we could throw a br in
here and we could do the exact same
thing
in here okay so now let's test the
results of that
and i think now it looks a lot cleaner
so let's continue from
here okay so we do not do anything
special when we click on purchase item
right after we enter the modal
so let's see what we have to do when we
click on it
so if we actually go to our pycharm
then i am already inside the routes.py
and you can see that we initialize this
purchase underscore forum
now regularly we would like to go
with the approach that we have done for
the login and the register
forms as well so we probably want to
run such a code which is going to be
like purchase form
dot validate on submit
okay so it is going to be exactly the
same thing but
let's not forget the if statement in
here so
now everything works fine now before we
actually continue on writing
some more code within this conditional
i'd like to show you
how the purchase form looks like when we
print it on the server side so if we
actually go ahead and
do only print purchase form when we
click on purchase item
let's see the results first so you can
understand the following things that i'm
going to do right after it
okay so once we have done with this then
it is a great idea to go to our website
and make sure that it is up and running
and maybe it might be a better idea if
we
restart it great okay so now
i will refresh our page and now i will
try to click on purchase this item
and we receive method not allowed okay
so we should add this as a
method that are allowed in our decorator
so we already know how to do that so
let's just copy one from our register
page
so it will be copying from here and
pasting in
right there okay so now if we click on
purchase this item
then we are totally fine and now i want
to show you the results of that on the
server side
now you can see here that we
receive the object of the form itself
and there's nothing surprising with that
now i want to show you a little bit nice
trick that we have in
class instances and that is the
attribute of underscore
dict like that so this takes the entire
instance
and displays it in a nice dictionary so
it will really give you a
look of what are the keys and values
that are available
within this purchase form instance so
once i save this
and i go back to our web browser and
let's try to click again on purchase
item
to really launch the sprint line and now
i can go back to our terminal
and we could see down here that we got
some
more information now if we search
for the key of submit then you can see
that
we actually see the submit field
as an object itself now this means
that we have an available key within
this instance
so we could access it with a square
brackets
so we could go to here and we could
delete this
from here like that and we could say
submit like a dictionary okay so it is
fine to
run such a code and now let's see the
results of that
again so i'm going to go and
click on purchase this item and i'm
going to go
back to here and now you can see
that this is actually translated to
an html code so this means that we can
pretty much implement the same html code
hard coded inside our form
and then this way we will have our
custom
form that is also going to be accessible
within the route itself now let's see
what i mean by that okay so
let me grab this code snippet from
here and go back to our
items underscore models and right
before the submit form in here
i'm going to paste this in and customize
this a little bit
now you could remember that this ginger
syntax is actually
responsible to this ginger syntax
because this is what we saw so i'm going
to change this
to being in id of purchased
item and i'm also going to change this
name to
purchased item and then i'm going to
change the type to
hidden now when i do this hidden
this means that this input is not going
to be displayed within the form
basically this is just a background
information
that we are going to consume in the back
end of our application
meaning in the route of market itself
so this is why i put in here hidden now
the value for that
is going to be the item dot name
and the reason i am doing this it is
because the second that i click on
purchase item
i want to know which item the user tried
to purchase
so then we can continue on taking the
action that we need
to assign this item to that user so
once we have done this then we can go
back to our routes dot
py and we can take some different
actions in here
now i'm going to change this code from
here to
something else and let's try to see what
happen if we try to
write in here purchased item
now the reason i may think that this is
going to work it is basically because
in the submit field we were able to
access it by the
square brackets and type in submit as a
string so
if we create a field with the name of
purchase item
then why it won't be accessible so let's
see the results of that now if i
actually go to our website and try to
click on purchase this item
then we will end up with receiving key
error
now the reason for this it is because
this purchase item
is not going to be accessible within the
form itself
beside it is going to be accessible from
an entire different area
now as we know already there are a lot
of request types that we create to
actually manage this website
so flask library gives us access to that
built-in request object
to really have a fully control of how
the request object looks like
every time that we create some requests
like get or post
so in that case we try to create a post
request
and then this means that the information
about the purchased item
is going to be available within the
built-in request object
so let's go ahead and import that okay
i'm going to go to
python and i'm going to go to that
second line
where from flask is and i'm going to
import the built-in
object that is request like that
so now that i have done this basically i
can
allow myself to go down here
and change this code to something like
the following
so it will be request dot form
now the reason that i have this form
attribute
it is because the built-in request
object already includes a lot of
information about all the forms that are
built in in the request itself so here
i could say something like dot get
and here i could access the value of the
purchased
item so now that i have done this
then let's test the results of that okay
so i'm going to save that file
and i'm going to verify that our website
is up and running
and i'm going to try to go back to
homepage
and then go back to get started which is
the market page
and let's try to purchase the iphone 10
so i'm going to
click on purchase item and once i have
done that
then you can see that we see the output
of iphone 10
so that means that we have now fully
controlled
and we are aware which item our user
tried to purchase
so now we can continue on taking more
actions from here
alright so if you remember i said that
we are going to fix the
always being shown output about the form
resubmission thing so if we actually go
to
here and we try to refresh this page
then we
always will end up with receiving this
message from javascript
that says us that you are in the middle
of form submission
so to avoid this we actually have to get
rid of the conditional
form.validate on submit because the
reason this pop-up
shows here it is because every time that
we go inside this route
then it tries to submit some form that
executes
and the reason is because we don't
differentiate
between get request to post request
but now that we have fully control of
the request object
we can differentiate between those
request types so
let's go ahead and do that okay so i'm
going to cancel this
and i'm going to go to pycharm actually
i'm going to cut this
code snippet from here so we can copy
this back later on
and i'm going to delete this entire
conditional and now we can change this
to
something like the following which is
going to be look like
if request dot method
equals to post like that
so this is pretty much equal to
form.validate on submit but
again this is going to avoid displaying
the output that we saw about form
resubmission
so now i can basically go with something
like purchased underscore item
equals to and i'm going to paste back in
the code that i cut previously
so it is going to be equal to
request.form dot get
purchased item like that and once we
have
done this then we can continue on
and we can try to filter the item object
based on the value of purchased item
so we could say let's actually write
this in a
shortened version so i will say p
underscore item underscore
object like that and we could make this
to be equal to item
dot query dot filter underscore
by and we'd like to filter by its name
so
it will be name equals to
purchased item like that
now if you remember i know it is been a
long time ago since we applied this
but to actually inspect into the object
of the item
we have to execute this dot first method
so we will really have fully access to
the
purchased item object now okay so now
that we have done this
it is a great idea to verify that this
object is not
none before we continue on and before we
continue and take some more actions
so i'm going to say if p item object
and then enter this conditional and now
once we have this p
item object we'd like to assign an
ownership to the
user that is currently logged in now
we did not see this before but we have a
built-in object
that is always going to refer to the
current logged in
user object so the way that we can
import this
is going to be as easy as going up top
here and
import from flask login the
current user built in object so make
sure to do that
like i did as well and now i could
basically
access each user field like we have in
our user modules
okay so now we should remember how we
can assign an ownership
to a specific user so let's go ahead and
remember that
now i'm going to go inside my modules
dot py
and i'm going to show you the item
module which is right here and if you
remember
for each item object we have the option
to assign
an owner feel to it so in that stage we
can assign the owner field
to the item object that we have filtered
out by using the filter underscore by
function
just a minute ago so we could basically
go back to
here and say p underscore item
underscore object dot owner
equals to and then i can basically refer
to that current user object that we have
imported
and now to assign the ownership
successfully
i have to put in the id of the current
user so it will be
dot id like that and if you're confused
by that line
it is mainly because in modules.py we
gave the foreign key of user.id
so our database expects for the id of
the
user that we are going to give the
ownership to it
so i'm going to go back to our routes
dot py
and in that stage it is not enough to
leave it as it is
because in real life when you purchase
some item
it makes great sense to decrease the
amount of the budget
of the current user so the way that we
can do that
is by easily decreasing the budget of
the user
by basically subtracting the current
budget
by the items price itself so it will be
something like the following so i can
say current
underscore user dot budget
minus equals to the p
underscore item object and then we could
basically say
dot price like that and once we have
done such a change
we need to execute that db.session
dot commit line to really perform a
save operation towards our database and
this should be pretty much enough to
really
writing the algorithm of how a user can
purchase some item okay so
let's test this out so i'm going to go
to our website
and i'm going to refresh to home page
and before that let's make sure that our
website is up and running
great so now i can go to our website
and we can try to purchase the
iphone 10 now the next thing that i
expect to happen
is to really see again the market page
but now i should see the budget of 2
200 so if i click on purchase this item
and let's actually see the result okay
so we see that
two hundred dollars and this is perfect
now i know that there are a lot of steps
that we have to complete here
and first of them is to actually remove
now this iphone 10 from here
now the way that we can do this is
displaying the items
that their owner is none only
so let's see what i mean by that so i'm
going to go to our pycharm
and let's zoom out a little bit so we
can see what is going on here
and i'm talking about the line
that is responsible to send as
context to our market.html so if you pay
attention
right here in the item query dot all
here is our mistake now we'd like to
filter those items
by owner equals to none because it makes
sense to display those items in
available
items section only if they don't have an
owner so this is why we should change
this line
to something like item dot query
dot filter underscore by and we should
filter by owner equals to none
all right so now that we have changed
this in the next reload we should expect
to not see the item that i purchased
so if you remember i purchased actually
the iphone 10
and now if i actually refresh this page
we again see that resubmission
output but don't worry we said that we
want to totally differentiate between
get to post request
and we did not write in a conditional
that is looking like
equals to get so this is why we still
see this message so don't worry about
that
and let's actually go back to home and
then we could
go to market now you can see that we
only have
one item that is available on market now
one more thing that we'd like to
implement here is to
basically display a message that we
purchased some item
so we could flash a success message or
something like that
so let's go ahead and fix this so once
we
commit our changes we could say flash
and we could raise a message like
congratulations
you purchased and now
we could refer to the variable of the
item name by changing this to formatted
string
and we could say p item object dot name
you purchased item object.name for
and we could specify the price of the
item itself so we could say p item
object again
and we could refer to that price
attribute
so this should be great to really flash
the message itself
now i said that we should fix the
resubmission output that we see always
so let's go ahead and fix that
and the way that we can fix this is as
easy
as going down here and to
conditional this up like if request
dot method equals to get
and then we could basically execute
those lines
only if the request type is get
and this should be enough to really not
see that confirm resubmission
output that we see always so
if we want to verify that then we could
now refresh the page and you can see
that now it is totally fine and it works
correctly
and we don't see that from resubmission
output okay so
now we are going to continue on to
adding some more security layers in here
and now think about it if i am going to
click ahead
to that purchase this item then it will
probably end up purchasing it because we
don't have any logic implemented
that says if the budget is actually
not greater than the item object price
then raise an error we don't have a
logic like that so
this is why we should write some logic
to prevent from our users
to have the ability to purchase an item
that their budget is not
enough for it so this is why we should
write some more python code
so i'm going to go here and now we could
basically imagine a code that
is going to say something
like if current user can
purchase okay so executing a conditional
before we actually assign the ownership
could be something really great and
amazing so this
is why what we could do in that case is
writing some function in our user model
that is going to receive the item object
as an argument
and we could really verify that if the
user's budget is not greater
than the item object price itself then
we should prevent from them to purchase
this item
so this is why i'm actually going to
remain this code in here but
you could guess that we don't have such
a method yet
but let's go ahead and create it so i'm
going to go inside
our modules dot py and i'm going to
scroll up to our users
and we could write some more functions
i mean methods in here so we could say
def can
purchase like we wrote in the
routes dot py and i'm going to receive
as an argument
item object so it will be item
underscore obj
something like that and we could
basically
return self
dot budget greater or equal
than item object dot price
so by doing this i am returning a
boolean
value that is basically going to return
true or false
and this step is going to really verify
that the user could purchase this item
so once we have this in here then it is
a great idea to
go to our routes dot p y and this now
needs an
argument so the argument is for sure
going to be the
p item object like that
and this should be enough to really
verify that our users
could purchase this item so now
if we don't hit this conditional then it
quite makes sense
to go here in else statement
and raise one more flash message that
is going to say let's actually
scroll up a bit before we write this
message
and we could basically say unfold
through
nately you don't have
enough money to purchase and let's
actually refer
to the object itself in here and we
should change this to formatted string
and now we could say p item object dot
name like that and now
we should add some categories to both of
these flash messages so here we should
say
category equals to danger and
up top it is obvious that we should say
category
equals to success like that okay so
now that we have completed this there's
one more step that we have to complete
before we really test this out
now pay attention to the following code
that we have in app.route
so we have request method equals to post
and we execute some lines of code
and we have request method equals to get
and we execute some lines of code
but if you pay attention we don't send
our users to
anywhere right after the post request
completes so this
is why we should decide where we want to
send our users
once the entire conditional of if
request dot method equals to post
finishes so it totally makes sense to
grab the indentation in here
and redirect our users back to this
exact route
so the user could really continue on
purchasing some items
so i'm going to say here return redirect
and i'm going to launch the url
underscore for
built-in function and i'm going to write
here market
underscore page okay so this really
should be enough to test the entire flow
so i'm going to verify that our website
is up and running
and it is and now i can refresh our
website
and now we should expect for a red
colored
message if we try to purchase the laptop
because we only have
200 left so if we click on
purchase item then you can see that we
receive this output
that says unfortunately you don't have
enough money to purchase laptop
we could add an explanation mark two
here to really make it nicer
but the point is it works and this looks
great
and we actually completed the entire
process of how we can assign
an item to a user that is logged in
okay so one more thing that i'd like to
do before we close out this topic
is to moving those three lines of code
into being a method inside our item
model
so if you imagine a situation it could
have been a lot nicer if we
don't have those three lines of code and
besides that
we could have a code that is going to
look like p item object
dot assign ownership something
like that or basically this could also
be
dot by okay so anything that you like
will do
so let's go ahead and do this okay so
i'm going to undo here
several times to really not ruin things
out in here
and we are going to create an additional
method inside our
items model and this will be responsible
to
turn the entire flow of this items route
to a lot nicer
so i am going to go to our modules.py
and i am going to create a method this
time in the
item module itself because now we should
assign an ownership
to a specific user so it is going to be
something like the following so we could
say
def by and we could receive a parameter
that we will name it user and the
lines of code that i'm going to be
executed in here is pretty much going to
be the same as in routes.py
besides we are going to change the p
item object to self so i'm going to
cut this out from here and i'm going to
paste this in under by and
every place that we see p item object
is going to be changed to self so for
that and for that we should change to
self and for the user we should
replace those with the user that we are
going to
fill in as an argument so now that we
have this method which we name it
by we could basically execute it
by only going here and
say p underscore item object
dot by and we only have to pass
in the current user object so it will be
just typing in here current user and we
pretty much done with the entire process
okay so now
to actually test this out we have to
create a new user because it will save
us some time
because the jsc 6 user is having
currently
200 and we'd like to test this with a
new user that is going to have as
default
1 000 so we could log out for a minute
and you can see that we see this
informative message
which is perfect and we could register
with a new user so
i think this will be jc8 that time and
we could
put in some valid information
and we called create the account okay so
we are inside the market page
and now we only want to test if this
change and moving the code to model.py
is going to work for us so i'm going to
click on purchase
item and now you can see that we see
this message
that we see you purchase laptop for 1
000
and i see that we forgot the dollar sign
in here and now you can see that we
don't have any items remaining
in this available items on the market
section so this is perfect
and the budget is updated as well to
zero dollars
so really the entire flow is starting to
work and this is perfect
only i will just change this message to
being with a dollar sign
and this is going to be as easy as
adding it
in here and this is now
perfect
all right everyone so i'm currently
logged in with the latest user that we
have created which
its name is jsc8 and if you remember
with this user we purchased an item that
its price was one thousand dollars and
this is why our budget is zero over here
now to really show you how we should
display the owned items for a specific
user
i am showing you our page because i
imagine that
we could basically create some bootstrap
cards
and by saying cards i mean like a nice
looking square shapes
where we will display the old items that
the user has
and each of those cards will include
some buttons that says sell this item so
let's go ahead and start working on this
but first of first
we should be able to query all the items
that
the current user owns so this is why i
will go to my pycharm
and i will start by going to routes dot
p
y and if you remember we have this
built-in
object that says current user and it
knows how to identify
the object of the user that is currently
logged in so we could write
a query that basically filters out the
items
that the current user owns so let's go
ahead and do this
right under our market page route
but it totally makes sense to write such
a filtration
under the if request dot method equals
to get conditional
so i will go here and i will
say something like owned underscore
items
equals to item dot query dot
filter underscore by and as the
expression in here
i will say owner equals to username
dot id i mean current user
dot id okay so the reason i'm doing id
because if you remember from the db
relationship that we created
we mark the relation between
item and the user by its identifying
number so this is why i can allow myself
to filter this out by current user
dot id and this should be enough to
bring all the items that the current
user owns them
so now i will pass this as a context
by saying owned underscore items equals
to
owned items like that
okay so this really should be enough to
go now to our market.html
and start working on the implementation
of how we want to display this
okay so if you remember we have this
call dash 8 which displays
available items on the market and right
here we have div class 4 which is
basically designed for displaying the
items that the current user owns them
now in here i can write some nice html
code to really start working on the way
that i want to design this
so we can say div class equals to row
and you will see in a second why i'm
creating one more
row under this column and i can now
start writing the iteration that we'd
like to do probably
so we could say for owned item
in own underscore items and we could
close our expression
like that and right here i will say
div class equals to call dash
md-6 okay so i will stop here and really
explain
why i did what i did okay
so by purpose we want to declare this as
6
because if you remember from the
previous session that we created div
class equals to
row div element we implemented the
reading system of bootstrap
and the maximum size that you can locate
an html element within a row
is only 12. so this is why
if i create six and there is more than
two items
then each two items it has to force
itself to
jump down a row and it looks nice if you
display only two cards in a single row
so this is why
i implemented this in that way okay so
right
between those div tags i'd like to paste
some html code that will be responsible
to create those
bootstrap cards that i talked about now
you can find the code that i'm going to
paste
it in in my official website so just
navigate to the episode 16 of this
entire
tutorial okay so i will paste this in in
here
and explain what is going on here as
well
so we have one more div tag that says
card
text center and bg dark so nothing
really complex in here
and right after it we have the card body
class
and right after this we have some class
to display car title so we could imagine
that
this code is responsible to display
probably in the up top of the card
and the button is basically made for
the option to sell the item that the
current user owns
and you can see the data toggle and data
target as well
and you should be familiar with this if
you watch the last episode
and here we have some paragraph that
says additional text
so we could edit this by displaying some
more text about this item
okay so if i save this file and go back
to our website
and refresh that out then you can see
what the
code that we wrote is responsible for
and you can see that this is a really
nice card that displays the item that
the user owns
now you can see that there are a lot of
placeholders that we have to
change them so the way that we can
change them is easily
by going here and edit the
text that we should edit them okay so in
the card title
we probably want to display the item's
name so
it will be by accessing the variable
block of jinja
and we could say owned item and
this is actually accessible because of
this
for loop and we could refer to the
attribute of name
of this item and by doing this this will
be responsible to display
laptop besides the placeholder that we
saw previously
and we could leave the cell this item
because this is the actual purpose of
the button
and in the additional text we could
basically
give a nice informative sentence that
says something like the following so
this could be
this item costs and then we could refer
to the price attribute
so it will be owned item dot price
and we could add a dollar sign right
here
and by doing this you can already guess
that this is going to display the
following line
so now things are looking a lot cleaner
and you can already see that
if there is going to be more than two
items in here
so this card would be located in here
and then the third card will have to
force itself to
locate in here so this is why
i went with the following approach okay
so from now
each step that i will be configuring
will be basically
the same as we did for purchasing an
item
so if you remember in the last episode
we also created in forms.py
a form for cell item form as well
so this is why i'd like to create an
instance of that
and send it as a context to the route.py
as well so it will be by going here
and say selling form
equals to cell item form and this is
probably not
up top here as the import line so we
could say
sell item form like that and
this selling form should be sent as
context to the
market.html as well so down here
we could send this like selling
underscore form equals to selling
underscore form
like that now if you remember
when we implemented the purchasing item
we
search for request.form dot get
purchased underscore item because this
was a reference to
an input that its name was purchased
item
so we will go back to this route dot py
to really write python code to perform
action
like for selling the item itself okay so
this should be enough for now in the
routes.py
and now let's go ahead to our
market.html
and create a model for selling an item
like we did for purchasing so i will
open
our market.html and i will also show you
a kind reminder that in order to display
a purchasing item modal
we created this items underscore models
html page
now to really have a nice separation
between selling and purchasing
i'd like to create one more html file
that we called name it something
like owned items models like that
and we could delete the auto generated
html
and like i said because the logic
implementation is going to be quite the
same
i can allow myself to grab the exact
same model from the purchasing item
model
and later on we could change some of the
identifier strings or html text
to make it dedicated for selling an item
okay so i will go to items underscore
models
and i will copy the entire code under
the purchase confirm
and i will paste this in here and
if you remember we had some special
style for
this model as well so i will grab the
style tags and paste this in as a
first line okay so now this is some
dirty job but we have to do it okay so
let's go over the
areas that we have to change from
purchasing
to selling or sell or something in that
kind
okay so you could already notice that we
have an identifier that says
model purchase confirms so we could
change this to
selling confirm like that and we can
also change the comment in here to
make it nicer and if i scroll
down a bit then i think it is okay to
leave the item name
like that and now in
here you can see that there is a
reference to an hidden tag
that comes from purchase form and if you
remember we also
initialized the selling form as well so
we could
change this to that and now here we have
a sentence that says are sure you want
to buy so we can say
change this to sell and in here
we could say by clicking sell you
will put this item
back on market like that now
you can already see the input inside
this model
as well and you can see that it has an
identifier that says purchased item
so it totally makes sense to change this
to
sold item okay so we
created this in past tense so we will
leave it as it is
and this will be sold item as well and
we'd like to keep this in hidden and the
value
as the same so again we have this
purchase form here and this has to be
selling form and besides doing this
success we'd like to do is danger to
really differentiate between the
different actions
so one will be green and the ceiling
will be
red okay so the close button that is
here we could leave it as
it is and that will be pretty much it
now if you remember to trigger a model
we have to trigger this identifier
in here so i will allow myself to
copy this statement and to really start
working
on two separated windows to not confuse
us so we could really understand the
further changes that we make from this
point so i will split our panes and this
will be by window
editor tabs and we like to do this split
vertically
and in the left pane we will keep the
owned items models
and in the right pane we will open the
not the items model excuse me we will
open market.html
okay so from here we are good to go and
let's scroll down a bit in here and you
can see that we have under call for
some more things that we'd like to
change in here
so we have this button right and this
button is actually what responsible to
trigger sell this item model and if you
paid attention
we have here a data target that says
your data target now this should be
changed to something that is related
with the
owned item variable to really have
a unique model per item so
this is why i will make the owned items
modal a little bit
bigger and i will change this
to owned underscore
[Music]
item like that and we should probably
change
all of those for all the places that we
see item
to owned item so i will do that just in
a minute and that will be
in here and as well as in here
and also in here
and let's catch up if we have more of
that
so to really make our lives easier in
here we could basically
search for item and we could
pay attention that every item is with
owned item right now so we are good to
go from
here and now i can really copy this
identifier string
and copy that out and now i will make
the market.html bigger
and we could paste this in
right in here like that and
this should be pretty much enough to
really see the model itself
when we want to sell an item so
now i can go to our website and we could
refresh it
and if we click on sell this item
nothing happens
and this really means that we probably
forgot something important
and this is why i will focus for a
minute in what is going on in
market.html
and have a look in here so in here
we start our iteration and yeah we
i think it is because we did not trigger
this include line so if you remember to
really
trigger the model itself it should be
recognized as an html code in the exact
same
page so this is why in each iteration we
have to use this include
in order to really have the model
implemented
inside the for loop so each item will
trigger
a separated model regarding the
information inside of it
so this is why i could go with something
like this we
could grab the code from here and we
could paste this in right under the
for loop and we should change this to
owned underscore like that because we
want to import the
models html that we have just now
created
now i want to have a look in owned items
models
to really ensure that we don't have any
leftovers
with the owned underscore item because
we iterate over a different
variable name so here we are good
and here we go as well and as well as in
here
and if we take a look
in the input okay here we should also
change this to
own underscore item as well so i have a
really nice trick that you can
do for such a scenario where you want to
make sure that you replace
all the variables with something so you
can basically use the control
f and search for a specific text in your
entire page
now if i search for double curly
brackets and item
then you can see that we are good to go
and nothing really exists
with this expression so we could now
go to our page and refresh it out and
test if this works
and you can see that the result is quite
great now we see
the title in here and we see this
sentence and this button currently will
not do anything because we did not
configure the functionality of this
button so let's go ahead and do that
okay so in the left pane we have our
route dot py
and in the right pane we will work on
some html code to display some
differences
now if you remember the way
that we grab the item that was attempted
for purchasing in the previous sessions
was by going to here
and say request dot form
dot get and then we use the name
of the input itself so this really
came from this name attribute
of this specific input now if we take a
look
in owned on underscore items dot model
so i will put it in here
then we have an input with a
name sold underscore item so basically
what we could do in route dot py
we could really implement the same logic
for selling the item like we did
in purchasing it so i will close
those and start working on the way that
this should be implemented
okay so we could go after the if
expression in here and start working on
the area what happens if the user wants
to
sell the item so to really differentiate
between those
i'd like to add a comment here that says
purchase item logic and
down here we could say cell
item logic like that okay so we
can say here sold underscore item
equals to request dot form dot
get and right here we could say sold
underscore item
now pay attention how i am keeping the
same logic like in purchase
okay so once we have this sold item then
we probably
want to grab the object of the item
itself
because in here we only try to
get the items value itself
so we could say s underscore item
underscore object equals to item
dot query dot filter underscore by
and we could say name equals to
sold underscore item and we could hit
the dot first method in here
now like in previous sessions if this
item object is going to be
not null then we can really start
working on assigning this item to
no one so we could go ahead
and say if s underscore item underscore
object and hit the column sign and enter
this conditional all right so now
we probably want to look to execute
some method that will ensure that the
logged in user
is really have an ownership on this item
so the way that we can do this
is by creating a method in the user
module
we could name it can underscore cell and
the can underscore cell will return
a boolean variable true or false that
will basically explain if the user has
this item
for real so this will be by
saying something like if current user
that can underscore cell and
we call pass the item object in here
now i know that we don't have this
method but this is just in theory
so we can really understand the idea of
how i'm going to implement this
now again you could pay attention how
this is quite
equal to what we did for purchasing the
item itself
so if you remember if we press here
control b
then this can purchase returns a boolean
variable
that basically ensures that the user can
purchase this item
so by creating a method that will say
def can sell and this will receive the
item object
one more time like that
we could really verify in here that the
user really owns this item
and the way that we can do this is by
the following expression
now if you remember up top here
we have these items which is basically
responsible to be a reference for
all the items that this user owns so
we could say return
item underscore object in self
dot items and this should be really
enough to
return us true or false because if this
item object is
in self dot items then it means that the
user
really owns this item and he can sell it
so we could go back to here and
if we hit this conditional again this is
going to be the same
approach like we did in item purchasing
so here we called execute again in
theory
something like s item object
dot cell and we again
like to pass in here the current user
object
for this method and this cell
should do the exact opposite action
from the buy method so if we inspect
inside buy
then you could see that first or first
we assigned a new owner
and then we decrease the budget and then
we
executed the tb.session.comit so the
exact opposite of this method
would be def cell and we could receive
the user object as a parameter
and we could say self dot owner
equals to none so this is the exact
opposite action of assigning an
ownership
we assign the ownership to nobody
so we could say here again user dot
budget
and you could already guess what i'm
going to do here this time beside
minus equals this will be plus equals
because we want to give the money back
and
this will be again for sure self.price
and again we can say here db.session.com
it
like that okay so as we have done that
we can continue on the logic
implementation so i can go back to our
routes dot py
and after we perform this action we
could grab the flash from the
conditional of purchasing
and paste this in here and we could
change this
a little bit so we could say
congratulations
you sold s item object dot name
back to market
and i think this should be enough okay
back to market and we could add an
explanation mark
and we could delete this and we forgot
to close the
double quotes in here and so this should
be enough and we will leave the category
success as it is
okay so let's scroll left in here and go
down now if the user could
not sell this item then we probably want
to
raise a flash message that something
went wrong and the user does not really
own this item
so we could say else and we could
grab this from here and paste this in
and we called say in general
something went wrong
with selling and we could refer to
s item object dot name
and we could leave the category equals
to danger as
it is all right so i think we are ready
to test this out
now i hope that the actions that we have
taken in the last minutes
made a lot of sense for you because the
selling
implementation is pretty much the same
like purchasing it
so this is why you saw a lot of copying
and pasting stuff
so i hope that you understood everything
pretty much clear because
from this point if the selling item
works properly then it means that we
finished everything with this website
so let's go ahead and see if this works
great so i will
refresh our page and we can now click on
sell this
item and once i click on sell this item
then you can see that everything is
pretty much working and we
see congratulations you sold laptop back
to market
and you can see that we have a new one
thousand dollars
and you can also see that the available
items on the market
is really updated with the information
that it's supposed to
so this really means that the selling
logic implementation is working perfect
as well
alright everyone so i think this will
close out our episode
and like i said in the beginning the
feedback of how this series was for you
is really important for me so i can
really know what i should improve in the
next series that i will be creating in
the future
and i will be creating one more episode
that will basically
explain in general how you can deploy a
flask application to production
but this is not going to be specifically
for this website
basically i will be creating a general
video that will help everybody with
their flask projects how they can deploy
it on production
alright so if you like this video please
hit the like button and also consider
subscribing to my channel if you already
did not
and i will see you very soon